foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
in competitive chess
the weight of a win draw or loss is all
on one's shoulders it's easy to feel
alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my God
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
this might have just been the most
insane PC all around I've ever seen what
the heck did we just witness welcome
back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives the car spent like two and
a half minutes and he beat a guy that I
would probably not beat so it's
unbelievably impressive entering its
Fifth Season 16 teams will reboot the
PCL Legacy with a new format and new
schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion I would go back there no he
wonders the ball are you kidding me
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
yeah he is both players are holding
their heads this is the most rarest
result I've ever seen
and we're about to kick off the weekend
with some incredible just action as this
is the final day of week three here at
the protest League I am I am
International Master Tanya sat there and
today alongside me calling the action
taking us through everything is super
streamer super commentator super coach
super Captain superhuman Larry Rosman oh
no no no no no we can we can leave it at
the super YouTuber uh definitely not
superhuman uh aspiring to that one day
Tanya it's uh it's great to be with you
uh I I'm usually watching your
commentary uh from the comfort of this
very chair so it's great to be
commentating with you and I'm super
excited to talk about some chess today
saying I'm excited would not make it
Lavi today we've got so much action and
seeing you Adorn the commentators hat I
wonder if that has something to do with
the action that we saw yesterday what a
blowout performance there by Levy
rosman's themed Gotham Knight defeating
the Shanghai tigers with a 9-3 scoreline
now Levy we saw how you guys did it but
the question I have for you is why did
you do it
why did we do it uh well I didn't do it
right I didn't do it like I keep saying
the captain of the team is the glorified
cheerleader uh and I and I stream the
games and I tell people to buy the
hoodies to support the team yeah it was
incredible obviously I I have tremendous
respect for the players on the Gotham
Knight starting with Hikaru and
everybody uh everybody who's aboard two
three and four but the way we did it was
spectacular and
um you can't really ask for a better
result so yeah I'm here today to
obviously look at some of the other
really good teams Scout them out talk
about them and um on the other side
obviously Croatia and then the blitz
Tanya they it was not 9-3 I mean it went
down to the wire and also a bit of a
shocking result right but that's what
the protest league is all about
now while you guys wrapped it up in just
three rounds this one as you said went
down to the wire Levy uh we saw a
nail-biting tiebreaker but I have to say
no matter which team you're cheering for
it's always so much fun to see it happen
and get decided in the blitz playoff
yeah unless it's your team and unless
you lose uh right like if it's someone
else's team absolutely I learned this
when I when I got a dog I it turned out
that other people's dogs were much
better than taking care of it full time
it was very stressful to do so so it's
kind of like yeah I loved watching The
Blitz playoff but oh my God I mean if
the if we went to a blitz playoff I
would be extremely stressed uh so yes uh
that that is the long and the short
answer and Croatia listen Croatia was
down in the dumps after week one and now
they're two and one and one went away
from from a playoff birth so super super
fun one and two two and one doesn't
really matter but it's first to three
and that's how you make it to the
postseason
that is the aim getting to that three
win three match victories takes you to
the playoffs and this is where we are
with our week three standings we've got
two teams we can see that they've
flinched their way for those two tickets
out of the eight uh for the protest
League playoff Indian yogis got them
nice of the first two teams to punch
that way into the big playoffs and of
course six spots remain we see Shanghai
Tigers levitov just wizard Wizards with
two wins and one loss and love you as
you were mentioning that indeed the
golden Squad is three match wins what
what's what stands out to you in this uh
in this week three standing that we see
uh what stands out to me so first of all
obviously going going 3-0 in your first
three is great uh and uh I'm not just
saying that because we're up there uh
India was extremely impressive they had
a crazy crazy match against uh the chess
bras which could have gone either way
but then they beat who in my opinion is
probably the best team in the league not
named the Gotham Knights and that's the
video of like they're they're playing a
world champion on the fourth board
Alexandra Costa nuke like they they have
a ridiculously stacked Squad top to
bottom they have this young guy Dennis
lazovic on board three and even they
lost to in the India yogis so uh this
page right here Tanya is ridiculous like
you've got Croatia coming up you have
Magnus repping the bras Norway gnome
surprising little you know two 2-0 push
after after losing a match and yeah
Shanghai and levitov like they're just
the win away so uh and by the way team
MGD who we are going to commentate today
hasn't played their third match so they
very well could be two in one and on the
next page of the standings we got
another team that could be two and one
so uh yeah I I have no clue someone's
gonna be unhappy when they season is
over
because Levy as they say when you've got
winners you've got to have losers as
well we saw the two teams that have
qualified one team has been eliminated
the protest League started with 16 teams
we are down to 15s it is goodbye to
Charlotte cobras but not just them Levy
there are quite a few surprising names
in there who do face elimination the one
that stands out for me is Saint Louis
archbishops they are three times
champion of the protest league and
currently on zero to two facing
elimination that's exactly right and
okay in every single competitive event
when there's 16 teams and you got to get
down to eight there's the teams that you
look at ahead of the Season you're like
they're not gonna make it and I'm not
extremely surprised Charlotte is
eliminated from the playoffs but of
course to be the first and to be the
first to lose all three matches it's
like oh wow so I'm not extremely
surprised I do think Berlin who is
playing against St Louis today is
probably also next to go but yes when
you talk about St Louis you associate
that with chess excellence and they have
multiple super Grand Masters on the team
I think they've just struggled to figure
out the best mathematical lineup that
they can create with one two three and a
very powerful board four
um but Spain is here and they were the
last team to qualify so that's not crazy
surprising the two teams that are the
most surprising Tanya the Blitz and the
algories shook board one and two one and
two right no pun intended uh and the
Garden State passers were up three
points against the Canada Chas bras it
was a Monumental comeback or collapse
whichever way you want to look at it so
that could be a total we could be seeing
the chess bras there right now I mean
this is chess it comes down to one move
sometimes and that's essentially what
happened in their match so but they're
not out that's the most important thing
one and two does not mean one and three
it doesn't they're not out but one team
will be today it is a high stakes
matchup and like you were mentioning
Levy Blitz with former well World Blitz
Champion Maxine Russia lagrav and a
Grace took with them struggling with one
and two it just goes on to show the
strength of the protest league and these
are the matches that will decide the
fate of these four teams well especially
that second match that you see with
Berlin Bears versus the St Louis
archbishops that is an elimination match
these two teams down to O to two and it
just comes down to the one that wins
keeps their hopes alive the one who
loses is out of the protest league but
we do start with the California unicorns
versus the MGD one let's take a look at
the Players the soldiers for these two
teams we're going to be fighting it out
and wow Levy I'm taking a look at the
California unicorns roster and that's
three incredible 2700 players including
lukesh 17 year old the second youngest
Grandmaster in history the third
youngest player to ever reach 2700 we've
got Sam Shanklin farmer US champion and
some very dangerous teenage players
that's right and seeing good cashier
must be wild because there are two teams
completely from India essentially 90 of
their roster including the one that
California is going to play against
today and they have every guy singing
halsarin like you name it they're on
that team so this is this is super fun
to see and I think when you think about
the protest league in the past a lot of
people like the local element you needed
to have a player from that specific
Place uh but if you want to think big
picture your favorite football clubs
have players from all over the world who
then in the World Cup represent their
home nation so I I love it I love the
gukesh is repping California I hope he's
getting compensated well uh and yeah
they have Ilya niznik right like he's
just he's a beast they have Christopher
you who is a just a ridiculous board
three we thought about adding him to the
Gotham Knights he didn't quite fit
mathematically
um but the question is like is the drop
off to the board four going to be a big
factor because as we're going to look
ahead just in a few minutes here uh it's
a massive mismatch and the MGD one
roster has a ridiculous board four so
yeah California is very very good but
they are top heavy and I'm a big
concerned for them
well speaking of the lineups and just
the inclusivity in it take a look at
this this is the all Indian team except
one player where you see on the number
three spot Amin Tabata by this is
stacked with all the young talents the
prodigies of India and some of the very
experienced players in the country a
great storyline there that you hinted at
a levy with kukesh playing against his
country team and how that's going to
play out well this one's being led by
Arjun aragassi at the top a very
balanced team from the top to the very
bottom the last player Divya Deshmukh is
23 38. this is one strong uh roster it
is and you have to remember that India
and China when when players have ratings
there's an asterisk because it's like
200 points actually better than their
rating probably like on any given day
and they just need to get the
tournaments under their belt so yeah
this is a ridiculous team the fact that
they have even lost the match is crazy
it shows you the
unpredictability of the protest League
like 9-3 Gotham Shanghai that's
unpredictable and it looks great on
paper but this team actually lost the
match despite having probably top three
roster like in the entire league uh
anybody can beat anybody on their team
in a given day so today we're going to
see if they can uh take a look on the
other side of the of the of the playing
field and go kukesh what are you doing
over there you should have been with us
should have stayed with us kukesh so
we'll see how he does against uh all of
his uh country men and women but yeah
Tanya this is a this is a tough tough
team
um don't agree more with that chat if
you're hyped after seeing the rosters
what makes the protest League even more
exciting is that there are certain rules
and regulations that the teams have to
follow to pick their lineup they can't
just go with the top four because that
would make things super easy you know
you just have four players in your teams
you keep playing them again and again
but Levy I love the fact that their
regulations and this makes sure that
every match remains even
that's exactly right uh we've got some
rules every team has to uh have a female
player the average rating has to be
25.50 based on a November 2022
supplement so you can be higher rated
now uh uh if you're under 2200 you get
bumped uh uh that's exactly how it works
right you get bumped up to 2200 because
you can't you know drop your average
rating by having a 1500 play uh and uh
well we've talked about this quite a bit
listen our lineup that we fielded
yesterday was
2549.75 because
literally if anybody was one point
different the lineup wouldn't work yeah
we listen we we were like the It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia I mean with
all the red lines and the uh staring at
the wall so these rules are in place for
a reason and they have contributed tiny
I think to some really fun matchups
a hundred percent and that lineup worked
in Perfection for you guys well I think
for today's board assignments the one
board that will really matter is that
one woman player because that is where
the big difference is let's take a look
at the big reveal of the players playing
in today's uh in today's matches and
we've got from the California unicorns
it is going to be gakish elianism
Christopher you he is such a tactical
Wizkid super strong strong in those
tactics and Sabina poison now love you
when I look at this uh these board
assignments the counterparts the
California unicorns it's very clear that
it's super evenly matched in the top
three boards well there is a little
discrepancy in the second one with
adibon being a bit lower rated than Ilya
but it is really that fourth board and I
think Sabina Forza has her task up that
she needs to try and save as many points
as she can to win this for the
California unicorns yeah you have like a
2500 GM who's on the fourth board I mean
it's crazy right like it's and okay we
like we feel that a couple 2450 IMS but
the thing is you have to there's a very
important distinction here you have to
drop between the classical chess rating
you see on the screen and their rapid
ability 10 minute is completely
different adibon might be at lower rated
than Ilia niznik but he's got a wild
style just like mikola portnick on the
knights has a wild style you can take a
point off of anybody at any time or
generic I say has gone toe-to-toe with
Magnus Carlson he's extremely
experienced I don't know much about uh
diption's experience right okay he's
2544 classical but what's his what's his
rapid experience Christopher you is a 3
000 rated Blitz player like he might
very well be the best player suited for
this format and he's playing on the
unicorns because he's so good at speed
chess so I don't know there's more than
uh more to this than meets the eye and
we've got a few minutes and we're about
to get rolling
absolutely and Sabina Faso is also the
former U.S women Champion so cannot
underestimate her she's got half points
out of four for her team so far while
harika has been quite a solid
contributor in MGD one's win uh where
she's got two and a half out of four so
it's going to be it's going to be a
tough one let's take a look at our round
one matchups and this is how we start
the day now as we know with the protest
League that it is game one which has the
most unbalanced matches the most tilted
matches so to say where board one Meets
World four and so on and we've got
guppiesh taking on harika these two
players they know each other really well
uh they've been part of training camps
together played with Indian team
together it's going to be an interesting
one harika Levy I'll tell you one thing
about her that reading difference of a
little over 200 points it doesn't really
matter because harika is just such a
super solid player she's one of the
toughest players to beat
yep and she's white which is a huge help
right she's going to be starting with
the white pieces yeah our generic icy
plays somebody who he's 500 points
higher rated then right and Haruka is
playing somebody who has the same title
as she does that's the incredible thing
about uh about about these matchups and
you just don't really always know what's
going to happen but Tanya if listen if I
gotta make a prediction I I team MGD is
a very strong favorite you know who I
think is the wild card for this match I
think Chris Hughes got to go like three
and a half he's just got to win three
games and draw origin like literally
because without that
I don't know if they're even going to
get up to eight or seven points
they can because at least
it's leading Sabina every Point saved is
a bonus for that team so each of each of
the other players needs to really really
make that contribution and we saw one
crazy pairing that really got my
attention there Christopher are you
taking out our demand now I have to say
that is going to be one exciting match
Levy the kind that the fans will love
that we will love commentating on
because both these players just bring on
the fireworks yeah they do they
absolutely do Chris you is so so good he
was part of the California comeback
against us we were just running away
with the match and then we lost three
games in the last round that he just won
a beautiful game against a really really
good player uh shamsidian volkida from
from Uzbekistan and unfortunately it
kind of flies under the radar because we
won the match anyway but I was sitting
there going oh my God like I'm terrified
you know Chris you is uh ridiculously
ridiculously good he only lost to Hikaru
and well frankly everybody in the league
loses to Hikaru except Josephine
heinemann so uh we are underway Haruka
uh by the way you want to make a draw
with uh with white take the pawn French
defense from guest just take the pawn
but I'm not sure that's her play style
she's gonna go Knight C3 or 92.
that was incredible and she goes for the
exchange variation of the French keeping
things as solid as possible harika is
the board for playing against Mukesh who
is the board one that explains this
approach he doesn't want to make this
the position super complicated and in
fact we have Magnus talk about employing
the French when you want to play for a
win with the black pieces harika saying
none of that happening today
yeah now I think she's deciding here's
the other thing like if harika did not
expect the French and she's sort of like
I want to neutralize his his opening and
not take any risk that's why she chose
this but here's the thing if the
exchange French is not in her repertoire
and the French is in gukesh's repertoire
and he knows all the little ways to
imbalance the game he'll probably try to
play for a 97 you know Bishop G4 long
castles approach and if she doesn't stop
him if she doesn't play the move B4 B5
like too quickly he'll just get a wild
exchange French and we've seen people
lose games with white in the exchange
French when they are playing for a draw
uh and I don't like the time usage
already right like if she had the
exchange French prepared and she wasn't
winging it she would be playing a little
faster she's trying to find like the
most solid approach and in 15 moves you
might be down six minutes and she has
played C3 I wonder what he's gonna do is
he gonna play Knight E7 or is he just
gonna go symmetrical well I'll tell you
one thing I've known harika since we
were done we played in the same team
together we played against each other
she herself used to play the French she
has a pretty decent idea about the
opening from both sides but the point is
that last move by gokish Knight to C6 is
not the most common move by black in
this opening usually black does develop
the king side Knight either to E7 or to
F6 keeping that C7 Pawn free to move up
to C5 so with that last move dukesh he
kind of took harika a little off guard
off the normal Theory and that's why she
slowed down she made the move C3 just
making sure that the pawn on D4 stays
defended and once again this little move
on the other side of the board Levy I
like it H3 not rushing with the normal
King side castling because you really
want to take that G4 square away from
Black's Bishop
yeah and and she's she's trying to not
let go cash develop in the way that he
wants and he he now is making this uh
this decision of okay and you see he
castles uh and I think
um if he had been given the opportunity
to play Bishop G4 and queen D7 he would
have gone long but now they're basically
both like all right we avoided all of
the little intricacies of of the
exchange French let's just play a
symmetrical game but not totally
symmetrical like you said there's a
knight on C6 there's a Pawn on C3 that's
already a big difference and they're
gonna fight against the natural
development of each other's Bishops so
there's still a lot more uh to this
position than ah boring game Draw
oh it's far from that I mean if gokish
wanted to just you know with the black
pieces played safe in the last move he
could have think thought about trading
pieces with putting one on F5 but that
last move Knight to G6 uh just keeps it
very clear you know you want to give up
your Bishop for the night I'm up for an
imbalanced middle game destroying my
Pawn structure opening up that f file
I'm gonna come down for your king so
good cage making his intentions very
clear by not trading any minor pieces
that leads to a symmetry but while this
game heats up I see some hot action on
the other boards already let's bring up
our bird's eye view our bird's eye view
as we'd like to call it uh Levy what
catches your attention the one game that
has really developed take a look at the
top right what do you think about that
uh wow that looks like a tremendous
amount of theory yeah let's go take a
look at um at uh Ilya nijnuk I hope his
username on translate Yes okay terrific
it's literally just news because you
know you know these guys like they some
some of them name themselves their
actual username and some are you know
fireheart123 and no disrespect Mr Mr uh
Mr Beast over there uh the the Indian
Beast right uh I don't know what that is
I don't you know so uh luckily the full
name is there and I was able to find uh
Ilia news quickly Have You Ever Had The
Misfortune of playing a classical chess
game against Ilya nuznick
sorry I lost you there a classical chess
game yeah have you ever had The
Misfortune of playing ilionic in a
classical chess game I actually have
played Ilia but that was a long time ago
it was at the Vikings when they had the
secret and I played again there uh it
was back in 2010 it was a crazy insane
Kings Indian defense and absolutely
thrilling game really to play a bit in
the end Ilya is the one who won and the
bit of fun one nonetheless and he's kept
that style of being an attacking
aggressive player and that's exactly
what we see today as well with his
opening Choice let's take a look at
what's going on Levy I mean now Queens
might get traded but if not white
already has control over the D file it
just looks more activity of the pieces I
think it would be wise that no matter
how aggressive Ilya really wants the
position to get trade those Queens off
yep exactly right and I only asked the
question about Ilya because I don't know
how he played in 2010 oh he was but but
he plays a little kid who actually came
to the board with a stuffed toy so it's
kind of really interesting to see him
now in this extremely strong Grand
Master but back then I mean he he
started playing chess when he was four
years old that's the kind of Prodigy
that he was
yeah he was like the highest rated in
the 1996 uh birth year for a while like
he got the 2700 his playing style is
extremely annoying because he's really
fast I don't know if he was really fast
when you played he plays every move
classical chess in like a minute which
is nuts because he gets 90 minutes on
the clock now if he does that in Rapid
that's great right but it also could
backfire because you could make some
mistakes
um yeah he has this repertoire that he
likes that's just very solid and this
was just a typical semi-slave but it got
forcing very quickly it's interesting to
see that he's not taking a tremendous
amount of risk early it's a completely
symmetrical Pawn structure DNC is gone
so I think that uh
you could be in a situation where you
don't mind a draw with black even if you
are the rating favorite because it's
around one time you don't want to do
anything too crazy right you don't want
to go nuts
it's too early in the day to go
completely nuts but it will happen at
some point and it might even happen in
this end game because we see it's you
can't even call it an end game you know
this is like a queenless middle game
there are all four minor pieces are on
the board the Rooks are on the board and
there's everything to play for it's easy
to think that this might be even and
completely without poison but far from
it take a look at that bishop and B7
it's on a stunning diagonal and
immediately blocked
while all of this and the King effort
coming to the center as you're pointing
out blacks might will jump onto C5
there's still a lot a lot to play for in
this position now uh Levy we can talk
about this end game and break it down
but the position that needs our
attention immediately is actually
another one and I'm gonna bring up our
bird's eye view because you're gonna
love what is happening on that bottom
left board that we see we've been
talking and hyping up the Christopher U
versus adiban matchup and this is good
reason why take a look look at that
white spawn Christopher's already
marched on the board with H5 and
absolutely insane Pawn structure adiban
has got only one Pawn on the seventh
rank the G7 moved all his pawns up the
board what on Earth is going on here
and this also was a French
so we had a French from gukesh and we
had a French from uh the Beast Bhaskar
nadiban uh and uh Chris you takes a very
unorthodox approach he plays in the
style of a king's Indian attack so
what's gonna happen here as we go
through the opening is it's going to be
by the way we see this 97 Knight C6
setup but it's very different than the
one that gukesh played this is a super
close position and basically it's like
the door locks and you just fight right
so the center is deadlocked and the
computer in these positions it's
important to tell the audience we'll
always say black is doing well but it's
so hard to stop White's attack Hikaru
won a game in the first week that was
exactly like this the engine was just
saying minus 0.7 and then he just
checkmated his opponent like uh and uh
this one's opening up though Chris got
his Knight here yeah we're gonna have a
trade Rook is gonna arrive and Tanya
this is very quickly going to become
like a positional game some backwards
pawns and weaknesses and I like Chris's
position
it's looking really good with that
Bishop on E5 that pawn that you match
your mentioned black has the light
squares that the PC Pieces come on also
that White Knight on F1 can actually
jump to H2 come to G4 also sack someday
on eight six so there's a lot to worry
about with black and
I'll tell you one thing about adibon he
doesn't fear the fact that he has the E6
weakness he's not thinking about the
fact that white has all these ideas of
coming after his King he's actually
eyeing his own gun to play on the other
hand adima's got this open F5 he can
have this idea of actually doubling up
on it with Moves Like Queenie at Queen
of seven or even a maneuver of getting
the queen side Rook with a nice little
lift on the queen side rookie summon
Rook F7 and start putting pressure on F2
that move last move Bishop to A6 eyes
that D3 weakness it is a position with a
lot of give and take both sides have
their own trumps and look at that Queen
D2 once again eyeing on that 8-6 Quest
some fine day continues developing also
guards the F2 Pawn
you know there was like a really really
wild idea uh I I don't know how good
this is but you could play Bishop to F4
which attacks the pawn on E6 uh it's the
most terrifying thing in a commentator's
life to make moves while stockfish is
watching and then I had I had just very
briefly seen Queen D7 Queen B3 which is
a fork and if you guard the pawn I don't
even know how like let's say you push it
I saw rookie 6 Queen E6 Bishop D5
which would have been real nice little
Rook sack uh and then Bishop D5 but
sadly he played Queen D2 so that will
absolutely never happen wow that was a
nice stunning idea but that actually
shows the kind of tactics that actually
exist in this position you know I've
been talking about the 86 Bond watch out
first sacrifice on the E6 pawn and
adiban goes for the move Queen to E8 and
Levy
I I I was just gonna say is there Bishop
C7 Bishop D5
something like that we've got to try and
look at that Queenie it does put
pressure on the H5 Pawn so you're saying
you don't care about your H5 Pawn
it's a lot easier to give away other
people's pawns than my own so I don't
know I I but I the thing is I don't have
the I don't have moves open I just have
the eval bar it still thinks it's kind
of balanced but I like Bishop C7 Tanya
because I feel like if I can get this I
can get everything else but you're right
I mean am I but also Queen H5 rookie six
I think black actually has a lot of
problems in this position after Bishop
C7
D5 bond is an absolute okay I've got an
idea Levy what if I track your Bishop
down with Queen D7 and I'm I'm begging
you to take on B6 I'm begging you to
take you spot it you spot it
yeah yeah yeah no no uh Chris you played
this by the way and oh my God
if it does not approve
a pro because the C5 Pawn is hanging
Levy I thought after Bishop B6 I could
go Rook B8 and win that pawn on C5 uh
win that Bishop on B6 but actually the
C5 Pawn just hangs is this what adiban's
missed
maybe he thought maybe he thought that
he could trap the bishop with something
like Queen D6 maybe that's what he's
thinking but what has he missed
what has he missed
uh is there a D4 Bishop basically
they're gonna find out he just picks up
the pawn Christopher you going for it
he's is not someone who shies away from
it and the eval bar does approve Queen
D6 you called it and now Rook be it is a
massive threat queen of four Queen F4
and like is the damage to your structure
oh but then there's maybe E5
and then and then that that's sort of
that's sort of not nice so how do you
get out oh just D4
just lend a helping hand to your bishop
and now you'll get out via C5 Pawn takes
oh man this is about it he's funds it in
seconds this is getting bad to worse
position but you know what it still
creates a lot of weaknesses and
practical chances for black yes you lost
the pawn now after taking on D4 first
big question do you recapture with the
pawn he says yes because it makes the
most sense you're threatening Bishop C5
with his cure on the queen and the Rook
there is no time for a good night jump
night before just lands into Bishop C5
it looks like adiban after all these
complications just ends up down a pawn
and this is not a free Pawn because
after that trade black would play Bishop
takes F1 and you would be under attack
that does look like a very nice Pawn to
capture though however if there was no
Knight on F1 maybe you could get away
with it but here's the problem for
adibon is that he's still positionally
in serious trouble and he's now down
upon so usually it's okay to be
positionally in trouble if you can get
out of it and create some complications
but like if he moves anything he's going
to lose something else this Falls this
Falls that's falling Chris used position
is Rock Solid so yeah Tanya we predicted
a sequence of moves but it has not gone
in adibon's favor it's not gone in
aduban's favor at all and we see the
eval bar give a huge advantage to the
California unicorn player Christopher
you he's up upon still hard to find
where adibon's initiative is but I'll
tell you one thing about ADI he is so
resourceful and so good at creating a
mess on the board he's a fighter I know
this one's still going to go on and it's
not over till it's over some of the
other action is also developing uh and
at what speed let's take a look on all
our boards now Christopher you they're
leading his aboard against adiban but
take a look at that it's not just him
case against harika also for the
California unicorns on that top left
board it looks like our eval bar is
screaming that harika is in big trouble
out of that exchange French yeah let's
just pop in over there and and see what
went wrong uh it is just completely
winning for gukesh I mean she has to
play Knight H1 and if your options are
play Knight H1 okay or go into an end
game of course but Bishop is better than
Knight and he's a pawn up what happened
I mean how did we go from dead symmetry
how did gukesh kind of waver a red flag
in front of like a speeding bull right
like what did he do to provoke
weaknesses in the white position right
she went Knight G4 maybe it was that
maybe you know she thought that she was
getting the upper hand here with the
bishop pair uh and she had an okay
position but what happened was it one
mover
oh it was this one Knight F5 G6 and now
you just end up losing a pawn yep yep
yep to be honest I don't know what he
what she should have done I mean she
should I guess G3 maybe but I
I don't know uh or go back and I don't
know repeat move somehow but then you
lose the G4 Pawn so yes she she kind of
like baited her in Knight B8 classy move
reroute oh what a reroute nice
and now he just wins that G4 weakness
Tanya if you gave me like
five attempts in this position I would
never in my life play Knight B8 which is
uh so karpovian this Nitro treat and
rerouting it through F6 to attack that
weakness to win the pawn and that's what
he did and then showing some good
technique because as you can see come up
to date with our current position where
he did a trade-off all the pieces that
were necessary and now he comes with an
extra Pawn into a bishop versus knight
he can fall back with the bishop to E5
as well where he controls the knight
from getting anywhere you know you keep
two squares uh distance from the night
to take away maximum squares from it
yes that's exactly right and uh the pawn
is also too far I mean black is just
gonna walk up to it and take it the only
way you can protect it is with the
knight from any of these three spots and
what do they all have in common they are
all on dark squares so that Bishop will
remove or extract the Knight and uh in
fact I think it's already happening I
mean Knight F4
because I thought it was King E5 does
Knight F4 you attack G6 defend D5 but
after G5 you've got to give up the G A
D5 Pawn
and watch out you can't go Knight to H3
G4 would be even more devastating yeah
G4 and and that's it I mean the pawn
will come and uh by the way the that
would be really unpleasant it would send
the king All the Way backwards so kukash
is gonna is gonna clean it up and this
is exactly how you beat
folks who play exchange French right
like you just keep the tension and just
because the position looks symmetrical
there are still 15 pieces left per
player that's a lot of pieces it's a lot
of pieces to blunder in one move if
you're a beginner it's a lot of pieces
to put inaccurately on squares If You're
a Grand Master and we just is just so
ridiculous like he made it look so
effortless if I played Haruka in this
game I would I mean I would lose with
black like no problem right and he just
makes it look effortless and that's why
he's the board one
he's showing Amazing technique in this
one and looks like he's got everything
under control harika in big trouble here
but let's bring up our bird's eye view
because she's not the only one in
trouble things seem to go from bad to
worse on that bottom left board
Christopher you continuing to put the
pressure as we can see bottom left take
a look at that the eval bar loving
White's position he's picked up that E6
Pawn D5 is weak let's do a deep dive on
it let's bring that up on our screen as
we see with that last move he's putting
pressure on D5 with not just the Rook
but the bishop as well yes you can trade
off the Queens what you can't do is
defend that D5 Pawn
yeah this is gonna be a situation where
adibon has to just sacrifice two pawns
and essentially hope for the best
because
I don't really know what Christopher you
could possibly mess up if that Rook ends
up on D5 the A5 Pawn is also in trouble
and then the game plan is relatively
simple for white me have pawns so me
push them and I don't really know what
you could possibly do with the black
pieces you cannot get to this King this
king is completely safe and incubated
white can always go here to defend this
and just a very convincing game so far
uh from Christopher you I mean uh I'd
even gonna have to
probably avoid a queen trade but Tanya
how what is Black's next move I don't
know
yeah it's tough to come up if you take
on D2 white can even just put in a check
and enter meso because he's not it's not
just a rook that's attacking D5 you know
you can just pick it up with a bishop go
Bishop D5 give a check and then
recapture the Queen the thing is when
audible sacrifices his spawns he wants
the Queens to be on the board for the
initiative but once it goes into the end
game where is your initiative you're
picking up the pawns as you said me got
pawns me going to push them and that
looks like a clear plan for Christopher
you I look at the clock situation even
there it's him who's ahead by a minute
and a half
and the problem on an open board like
this is that you have nowhere to plant
your night your night is just completely
uncomfortable in the center of the board
and by the way anywhere it goes it's
like also not covered and if it goes to
F5 it's still barely covered because I
can attack it and kick it out once again
so he needs his Knight somehow to end up
like
here and not get captured you used to
make a movie he's down to a minute now
his position is very hard right like
it's just not it's not easy it's not
easy and the thing is when you're gonna
tank like this with a minute on the
clock in the next like five moves it'll
be plus six because
you just don't know what to do and when
you don't know what to do it's extremely
hard to just sit there and defend the
position you see that red bar on your
clock you're like oh my God you start
being desperate and then Chris you just
calmly defends everything wins why is he
not playing like you said it's a hot
position but
but
finally makes a decision falls back with
the bishop to B7 that's not a move
that's going to help you can still
capture on D5 in fact maybe you can even
capture with the Rook but Bishop D5 the
only thing you shouldn't do is probably
capture with the bishop and I just want
to show a line why white still needs to
be careful let's say you go Bishop D5
and after suddenly after Bishop takes
d55 there's a knight F3 check and that
is game over for white so you know still
there are some subtleties some tactics
that exist adibon doing adiban thing
setting up the traps there but
Christopher you will find this he won't
go for Bishop D5 does he pick up the
queen on B4 what does he do here yeah I
mentally I really don't want to open up
this rook and at the same time
just because like in chess uh what I
always tell and I've always told
students is like you cannot evaluate a
position by words oh that looks scary
but it just might be the best move I
mean who cares if it looks scary Queen
before and then you take on D5 or put
your knight on E3 and I mean you just
calmly go on to win the game but there's
even attack there's even tricks there
Tanya like just this is like Knight B3
and all of a sudden you can't take yeah
and then you pick up the A2 Bond once it
moves now this board looks like it's bad
news for team mgd1 but no
let's bring
but take a look at what is happening all
across especially the top right part
we've got Ilia nissnik there calling the
shots with his Bishop versus knight
another Bishop versus knight as we see
on the top left as well with gokish now
the problem on diptan's board on that
top right board is that it's kind of
like a zook song White has got no moves
if the Knight moves the B3 Pawn Falls if
the king moves black king advances we
saw ilya's Pawn push there with H5
forcing white to do one of the two moves
and he gives up the B3 pawn and with
that it looks like California unicorns
are taking this board
absolutely yeah just bring the bishop
down and it's not even running with the
pawn uh it's the fact that the king will
shoulder this King away and B3 B2 is
just totally Unstoppable and when
everything is said and done it's very
important Tanya we have to point this
out that color promotion square is the
same as the bishop so that is a very
very important thing when you talk about
these kind of corner Pawn end games but
for now yeah I mean the king can just
walk and uh great technique and if the
top two boards win for California it
will ultimately come down
taking down uh aliban bhaskaran and he's
the wild card right he wins it's 3-1
this round let me
let it he gave up that beep on that
passer that he had
King advance and now he's just gonna go
win the king side pawns that is some
incredible technique by Ilya you know we
often think about how can we clean our
own pawns but instead he sacrifices it
for peace activity and very key Point
made by you that H1 square is the same
color so white Khan even sacrifice his
Knight for the F Pawn
yeah this is just a very very nice
technique Bishop G4 that's it and that's
it we've got resignation
that takes the lead
uh tremendous game from him very
convincing win with black but this is
what you need your 2700 feet a classical
as we take a look at our bird's eye view
there where do you want to go we can go
to Chris you maybe
wait can we Chrissy was losing
has done what he does best he somehow
swindled this position let's go to the
bottom left I have no idea how we got
here we've got no time to check it out
we will do that later but both players
down to 20 seconds on the clock
Christopher you in huge trouble how did
he manage to allow the alkyne battery on
the f file with the queen and the two
Rooks and the white king I mean this
looks like he should be getting
checkmated any moment yeah I don't want
to even go back because he's got four
seconds I love how this bishop is just
hanging it's just like it's just dead
adibon was like I don't need the bishop
I don't need my knight I'm just gonna go
for your King how did he do this
it had to be played to ease the pressure
he's trying to get rid of The Rook right
now the B7 Bishop his attack can't be
picked up with some light on F1 is
hanging what a move d4 opening up
bringing on all the toys into the attack
into the nursery a check with the Rook
move would be game over that is it and
adiban bhaskaran he takes the point and
levels the score
Wow Wow Wow Let's Take a look at her
bird's eye view here for a moment I
think we've got one game remaining uh
and it's uh it's the Arjun game
with nine seconds on the clock
what just happened he was up two pawns
for nothing how did I even do that I
think I think the Indian Community just
knows it's like ah it's adibon it's yeah
that is literally the answer to it no
one can do what he can do that is um
he's a master swindler and that's what
he did and this is such a critical match
because if mgd1 does win this then they
level the score currently the unicorns
are leading with that gokish win as well
as the niznik win and adiban surviving a
youth care and saving his team keeping
the hopes alive look at this queen D2
trading it off your up three pawns you
want to go into an end game this is
busted mate coming in on G2 and that is
it Sabina FASA throws the towel we have
got a level round one wow Levy
yeah what can we can I let's let me just
quickly pull this up before we go to a
break and talk about the summary what
just happened in that game how did it
get so bad what happened I just want to
find the answer all of life's problems
that's true
wait Chris you
Bishop B7 he just went here and he hung
his Pawn
what did he plunder oh he blundered
maybe Rook B1 and like Knight F3 check
and queen E5
and he blundered the F2 Pawn is hanging
as well you have two as a thread on the
board
they just hung everything oh my goodness
just hung everything and this is the
position we left it saying that Bishop
D5 is the biggest blunder but no the
biggest blunder is the one that you made
with Queen D3
oh not you Levy but yeah no all right I
I understand but uh what but I don't
understand what what was missed because
you you know you're giving up this Pawn
so I guess he just oh my goodness and uh
wow it's just over I mean one move just
one move changed the whole game a knight
F3 threatens a mate and one on G1 so you
had to trade that night and after work
after the queen was a thought you go to
G6 and he just bought the other Rook
into the game it wasn't even like a
Monumental combat he didn't like do some
crazy thing Chris you just lost two
pawns oh my gosh yeah Christopher you
just walked into this queen D3 that was
such such a big moment there and with
that we've got a round that ends with
four decisive results not just that Levy
four wins by black you don't get to see
that every day
no you don't but it also happened
yesterday in our first round against
Shanghai so 2-2 in the first four games
is like the perfect setup for complete
chaos I mean it will either continue
exactly like this or it'll be 4040 and
we can go home uh early or stay home
early uh I suppose uh yeah I mean wow
what a first round uh my prediction goes
right out the window and uh I think uh I
think we'll continue right where we uh
left off Tanya uh we're just gonna go to
a quick break first
what a chaotic round this was indeed
lovey tutu is the score we set the tone
for the big fight that this matchup
between California unicorns against team
mgd1 will be and we'll be back for round
two in just a few minutes
hey everybody it's Danny here and as you
may know chess.com and chessable are now
one and I'm here to show you how you can
make your chest.com and chessable one in
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click login scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
gonna ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's going to
pull positions from the games you've
played on chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from the mistakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
chessable.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki and
Josh Toth everyone's favorite social
media troll known as Anish Geary and so
many more chessable can help you raise
your game to the next level you're
getting started on the fundamentals you
should check out everyone's first chess
workbook maybe you want to stop letting
all those points slip away in the end
game 100 end games you must know is the
course for you did you not notice your
king was in check and still can't figure
out why the pieces won't move
actually uh chessable can't help you
with that maybe try refreshing your tab
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
[Music]
foreign
and in the chest wall for a while we've
been talking about the new wave of
prodigies and talents and seeing this
shift at the very elite level now one of
the youngsters who's been taking the
World by storms and leading this
movement is the boy the man in front of
you kokesh there all at 17 years old he
is the second youngest Grandmaster in
history he's the third youngest player
to have ever achieved the 2700 Mark he
had a breakout performance at the
Olympiad in 2022 with eight straight
wins and that's when the world took
notice he's been Unstoppable since Levy
we've seen gokish perform so well in
classical chess and that's really been
his Trend but looking at what he did in
round one against harika with that
convincing win he's clearly been working
a lot on rapid and Blitz and speechers
formats as well
yeah that's exactly right I really
enjoyed watching him on camera just a
trophy the size of his entire upper body
to his ride a whole trophy case above
him yawning because he's bored and he
just wants to win more games uh great
start for him right obviously this is
his debut we don't know how he's gonna
do uh and he's done all right in some of
the online rapid events that he's played
but he's he's the big boss like when
you're board one in such a pivotal
matchup you gotta get three you gotta
get three and a half and what better way
to start than a convincing win with
black against a GM like our generic ice
he had to play at 2200 and and my man
goo cash had to play a 2500 level GM and
to start so uh it's his warm-up set and
now he's got to keep it moving uh
throughout today's match
as you said the warm-up is done and now
that the most unbalanced the most tilted
lopsided match around is out of the way
it is time to get a little more even
things only get tougher here at the
protest league as we go into round two
and these are the upcoming matchups
kukesh takes on depty and Ghosh Navi
there's definitely a lot going on in his
mind about the fact that he plays his
countrymates over and over again cannot
be super Pleasant and then we've got
Ilya against harika harika who did
suffer a loss in the first game
Christopher you wow what do you think
has he let go of what happened against
adiban because that was the big Swindle
yeah yeah that was a that was a wild
wild uh turn of events uh but yeah I I
don't know will he let go of a loss and
not carry it over into this game you
know what I've realized Tanya and I I
kind of wanna I wish I had said this in
the introduction of this matchup in any
given round between these two teams
who is the team more likely to 3-1 the
other it's California
like I I mean Chris you if he gets a
game like that against ariban he just
has to win he has to not lose if he can
do that Ilya and gukesh can do the heavy
lifting and I that was a really
convincing first round from the top two
boards of California now they both have
white
if you just lock them in as wins it's up
to Chris you he really like it
ultimately no no no no disrespect to all
the eight players involved and not to
put more pressure on Chris you shoulders
but winning and losing and ultimately
making the playoffs in this match
completely comes down to Kirsten for you
well there you go that's my take
it's
he firstly picked up the bond but in the
end the one moved London those kind of
Misses are hard to come back from but
here we've got liftoff in round two
gokish uh is here fresh from his finish
at the WR Masters where he died for
first after the defeating in the tie
breaks so definitely rapid is something
he's enjoying these days he's playing
against diptan gosh what do you make of
this opening choice this is um
this is some uh wild prep if you're
watching at home do not play chess like
this you can only play chess like this
once you become an Olympic gold medalist
or silver medalist uh yeah this is some
super meta stuff white plays here and
still has a Pawn on E3 and the idea is
not to play D3 and E4 it's to have a
whole dark squared complex and the
reason I say this Tanya I'm sure you you
also would not play positions like this
with white what do you do with your
Bishop okay you're gonna put it on B2
and like then what where's this Knight
going if Black Goes A6 I think the
knight's gonna come around this way it's
like a super super weird setup uh but
again
if you put two players who don't know a
huge amount about a position up against
each other and one of them is as
experienced as gukesh you gotta give him
the edge so I like what he's doing I
really like what he's doing and his
opponent is gonna have to beat him just
kind of on an open board and gukesh
obviously is the favorite right so I
like the opening from him
I'm just glad that gkesh answered that
question about the bishop before I have
to I like the idea that it's headed on
the long diagonal A1 to h8 that's why
you want it you can create
counter-attacking chances I someday one
can imagine that F3 Knight Landing up on
F5 as well there are ideas like Knight
D4 Knight F5 Knight H4 Knight F5 really
putting pressure on G7 with black isn't
giving white any time to do that Knight
C5 was hitting the pawn on D3 forcing
white to retreat really the only way to
defend that D3 Pawn Knight E1 that
doesn't look very pleasant somehow I
mean you're defunding D3 but the Rook on
F1 disconnected it looks a bit scary for
white
yeah but how does blackstop B4 hmm
that's a good question right and then
and then B5 air Queen A4 play
ah B4
it's gonna happen it's gonna happen and
as you mentioned the pieces that have
come forward are going to be forced to
move back and that was some really cool
understanding by gakesh she doesn't care
about bringing his own Knight back he
knows he's going to start pushing his
opponent's pieces as well but he's
slowing down a little bit he is not
immediately jumping in with B4 which is
a little surprising because it looks
like the kind of move that you really
want to make is he actually thinking
about capturing on D5 is that an option
yeah I was just looking at the position
going is D5 hanging because Knight takes
Bishop takes we don't need an analysis
of sports right for this bishop takes
okay there's a discovered attack on on
the bishop
but you have Bishop takes F7
right
and then you just win a pawn but maybe
he doesn't like it because the position
kind of opens up by the way Tanya I want
to play B4 can I also play G4 G5 it's so
much easier to push pawns that are not
mine but
oh it just looks great it's so much
easier to push bonds that are not ours
it's so much easier to give bonds that
are not ours but here white has got to
make the decision whether he grabs D5
whether gukesh goes for B4 or G4 G5 that
sounds like an absolutely insane idea do
not try that at home Levy even if it's
Levy Rosman recommending it I do like B4
or 95 I will be shocked if a gokish
decides to go G4 it will be fun but
there's fun on other boards as well as
the games have kicked off let's bring up
our birds eye view and take a look at
that what openings we've got going on
and you know the one that's caught my
attention it is the bottom left board
what is that why is Black's King in the
center and the pawns doubled up on the f
file already I see that valbar says it's
fine but this looks like an absolutely
crazy middle game
uh yes and before we before we go there
we just want to draw the viewers
attention to the uh top left did in fact
Advance with his beep on but yes let's
go there let's look at this Christopher
you game
this was a trumpowski love it
uh and then he took on F6 so already
very imbalanced stuff black damaging
their own structure to open up the Rook
probably won't be castling that way Pawn
takes C5 and this is all relatively
well-known stuff
and it's a very tense position and black
has to decide what to do with the King
uh I don't like these positions with
white I never understand them I always
think I'm doing all right against the
structure and then I get a terrible
position so is Chris you gonna play D4
is he gonna take
I don't think you can ignore it I don't
think you should go Bishop E6 but I'm
not sure
it's very tempting to try to keep things
controlled in the center with this
default push I would be super terrified
to pick up the C4 Pawn open up the D5
because even a quiet move like Queen to
C2 uh just moving away by the way as I
said I would be scared of course that's
me Christopher you is absolutely
Fearless he picks up the pawn and I'm
expecting Arjun to find a way to pick up
that pawn again but to recapture the
pawn but without trading queens now if
you play Bishop C4 I think moves like
Bishop G4 are possible as well you can
trade the queens and things still look
fine
but what I would be worried about is
what happens if white actually goes
Queen C2 instead I want to bring my Rook
to D1 I want to capture your C4 Pawn
next uh Levy would you be happy with
black yeah well uh you literally
finished your sentence I would be
worried about Queen C2 and he played it
so yeah Chris he was gonna have to
answer some questions and the bar is
just saying plus one I did not like Pawn
take C4
I really just thought that uh
D5 to D4 was gonna be the way to go or
stabilizing the center a little bit but
um
he's not concerned the thing about these
structures with black
and Tanya I know you're a very well
prepared player and you play positional
chess you would never do this to your
pawns right so
because it's like what do you do with
them now and like none of them can move
you move the F Pawn that's weak you move
the E Pawn what are you even doing right
like ah
I don't know I completely feel your pain
there I mean that pawn structure with
the king in the Santa you haven't
finished your development and where is
your attack on the G file it's going to
take a long time coming meanwhile white
has all these temples of going Rook D1
hitting that Queen if you're not
advancing the F Pawn then what's the
point of taking these double pawns I'm
really liking arjun's position out of
the opening and I just wonder I just won
the levy because we see that Christopher
you has also burnt the kit he's taken
his time Arjun has almost a two and a
half minute lead on the clock
it's got to be a little bit of the after
effects of that first round you know
you've got everything under control you
feel you're so close to Victory and then
you make this Queenie through this one
more blunder and everything falls apart
okay yep I'm pretty convinced that
Chris you
severely underestimated the idea of just
Queen C2 or queen A4 and just not
trading because
I don't know I actually don't know what
he's gonna do if he castles he will
always be a subject of attack if he
doesn't Castle White's gonna try to get
a knight to F5 at some point put Rooks
on d and c and this could go from bad to
worse very quickly yeah he really might
be suffering the effects of the previous
game
um what's going on on the uh on the
bird's eye view everybody looks kind of
balanced I'd like to pop into news
nuke's game uh if we have an opportunity
uh if you look at the top right of your
screen Black's Pawn structure and a king
in the center white is already castled
visually as well what is happening there
double edge with the King still in the
center the long Castle the pawn
structure what is going on there it's
it's as crazy as the Christopher you
position we have
Ah that's why Bishop g5f okay that's why
the pawn is on F6 because he played this
move and yeah Haruka playing uh
okay you do not play chess like this if
you do not have a tactical and
aggressive Style
and
wow
I like her position I've played like
this with black before
and I get fun positions I mean I lose
plenty of them but they're fun I have
fun that's the most important thing so
but this could backfire very quickly
right C5 Bishop C4 Queen B7 diagonals
this is very scary for black because you
can't really move your king
yeah I mean you've got this horrible pin
down the D file firstly that Bishop on
D7 you can't really move it and you
could lose it really quickly you need to
spend one tempo uh I was just gonna say
shark Castle feels like a move it is so
brave to make you know you're just
allowing white to go C5 with a check
you're saying you don't care about that
about it's not just a check your queen
might come into D5 your Bishop comes
into C4 with ideas of Bishop E6 but
Haruka says that she's calculated it all
shock Castle is a brave move but I don't
see a direct repetition to it
yeah even if she hasn't calculated at
all she calculated just enough not to
tank and maybe in a classical game you
spend more than the minute that you
spent there but she only has five
minutes left on the clock it very
quickly becomes a Blitz game it's
definitely I would argue way too it's
way too dangerous to take on B7 uh but
you have to work out that you're
completely fine here
maybe you play C5 check and then take on
B7 because that way there is no Rook B6
but I would just be so worried I'm gonna
put that pawn on C5 and then I'm just
gonna lose it like an idiot you know
like why did I move my Pawn to Z5 uh but
I do I think it's the best move probably
C5 and yeah just like you said put
something on this diagonal and by the
way can we H4 H5 right at some point if
the king is going to go to h8 might as
well uh but when what do you do and at
what moment is the question
what would be the dream
diagonal with the check Force the king
on the chair and then find a way to open
the age file that's game over but
anytime you go H4 you have to calculate
lines with the bishop being captured on
G3 and your entire structure being
destroyed Also let's not forget once you
get H5 in Black Will have ways to even
block it with G5 or trade on G3 and
somehow put that Bishop on G4 which
means that harican needs to find the
time to sidestep with her Queen and get
out of that pin as quickly as possible
maybe we can pull up the analysis board
and just take a look at some quick lines
because it's such a tactically
tactically sharp position with where you
can have an attack really quickly if
here you go C5 and the King goes to h
she's gone Queen C8 so she does sidestep
it after C5 you go King h8 and let's say
you were to play H4
I think what harika wants to do is
perhaps just take on G3 and I'm stalling
because anything can happen in these
positions I Feel Like Anything Can Be A
blunder and now as you're pointing out
the H3 E3 Pawn is weak but I like the
move
I was gonna say I like the movie H5 but
it hangs G6 as well Bishop 86 pick up
that pawn on E3 this position is wild
Bishop 86 H5 what is happening Levi yeah
I I don't even know what I would play
here with black like I guess Bishop E6
just try to fight back on the diagonal
makes a lot of sense maybe Knight A5
like just kicked the Queen off the
diagonal yeah I also was thinking I I
don't know what the top engine move is
but I I hardly think this is this is
minus one uh this bishop D3 idea from
him is such a nice Nook style move just
keeping the tension trying to play
quickly and haruk is responding I mean
queen C at rugby is Grand Master stuff
that's why I don't have the title that
she has because never in my wildest
dreams would I play Queen C8 Rook B8 and
she's just playing it and she's like
come and get me I don't Bishop D5 no
problem I'm not scared
um and this is the kind of position that
you play with white where you have to
call the bluff yeah you got to do
something see another nugenic move but
look he's worse
but he likes to make simple moves
quickly and sometimes just like slowly
build up the pressure before he doesn't
want to do anything too aggressive right
C5 H4 but if Haruka plays her cards
right here she could just win a really
nice game like Tanya I don't know some
Knight G3 Knight G3 A5 E4
etc etc like this should be six okay
threatening Knight A5 and just winning
that pawn on C4 that was a devious
threat in the position but he says not
happening brings the bishop to D5 you
want to try and get rid of that bishop
and I think that's what Ilya wanted all
along he wants to try and trade the
light Squad Bishop because white has
managed to create these weaknesses for
black on light squares but I like that
harika is also not taking too much time
she falls back with the Knight so she's
saying I'm okay to trade but on my terms
if you take Bishop E6 the queen jumps
onto E6 and we see a lot of pressure
being eased off here already and the C4
Pawn might just be a weakness here
it could yeah he never moved it to C5 to
attack and now the queen on E6 basically
prevents it from moving so it's a very
tense moment in the game so to kind of
defuse the tension a little bit why
don't we bring in uh I I don't know if
he's one of the team captains because
they're California unicorns are all kind
of captained by uh a team of folks
what's up Costa you're the manager there
we go that's your official title I wish
uh I knew that prior but how's it going
man welcome to the show
hey hey Levy hey Tanya thanks for having
me it's uh it's going great yeah so I am
the I like you said I'm the cheerleader
for the the unicorns I'm just like
rooting for the team hyping them up uh
International Master David Perez he's
like the official manager he does most
of the the lineup decisions and and
stuff like that
um behind the scenes so he's been he's
been doing a ton of work as you guys
know
from the very start has been abs
olutely thrilling to watch and what were
your feelings in round one especially
that big turnaround in the Ilya audiban
match
how stressed were you at that moment
yeah that was uh that was a tough I
think you mean uh Christopher against
adibon right like Christopher was doing
uh really really well
and um and then ended up losing and then
Ilya we thought was not gonna win his
game as black but then ended up
squeezing it out in the end game which I
feel like I've seen uh nishnik do many
times so I was kind of like waiting for
it to be honest but no that was
definitely very very fortunate that it
went ended up going uh 2-2
wow
sorry go on Levy yeah I was gonna say uh
uh question as you look at this position
we've been
we've been very curious to see at which
point Ilya will will make the jump into
the position apparently the computer did
not like that move C6 uh he's got to do
something right but what is this
something is it E4 is like now that
moment you can play E4 and suddenly
you're just getting in with the Rook
what do you think Costa what are we what
are we looking for here
yeah very surprising that C6 is some
kind of blunder I don't know if it's
yeah weakening the D6 square if it's
Rook D7 maybe 94 Knight Knight C5 might
be uh annoying for black
um yeah surprisingly nice position for
white I definitely wouldn't think it's
like about to be over but he goes E4 so
it feels like he's uh he's seeing
something oh and uh oh there it is
that's what he like wow and the
reasoning was that if you recapture
there is Bishop H6 which is maybe what
she overlooked Tanya but I I don't know
I mean now she's gonna move her Queen
like there's no in-between check right
so
I'm not sure
your time I like her idea of an
in-between check as well because if you
were to move the queen
and then white can actually
click on the H file at some point and
the g-pawn marching down with G4 G5 so
why give this addition additional
chances and I think the fact that Haruka
is taking her time she might actually
trade the knights a midnight E2 saying
that I will not give you counter play on
the H file
oh yeah that's very very delicate moment
in between we're just to affect the
structure
wow I feel like that could be included
in a future chess Dojo lesson if it's uh
if it's the best move in fact you know
you oh no oh Tanya you might have been
100 right by the way because now it's
yeah the eval bar at least seems to say
that falling back with the queen was a
big mistake and he3 immediately captured
cassia opening up the H final and it
looks like Elia will be setting up the
attack but I want to take Costa to the
bird's eye view and really uh ask his
opinion on all the four positions and
what he's thinking about his team
chances here one ball the Costa you're
probably not happy about is the bottom
right board
yeah this one is of course going to be
tough but Sabina I mean she's uh she's a
huge fighter I don't think she's gonna
get like shut out this
ton of experience and like really really
solid Defender so honestly like okay he
always says White's like plus five in
these positions but it's like no
material ahead and it's like hard to
break you know your two Bishops are are
closed but uh okay obviously adivan is
super strong and uh
um yeah we were thinking in in this
round actually another 2-2 result was
very likely because both of the both of
the higher seeds are playing white on
all four games
um so that's it's gonna be a lot of a
lot of blood I think in in this round
I'm gonna jump in here for a moment and
just draw our attention to the
Christopher U game because for the
second game in a row
he has a fantastic position
and taking down
MGD ones board one would be huge now I
don't want to jinx it Tanya because I
feel like last round we really couldn't
have jinxed it any harder not that we're
cheering for anybody in particular as
we've basically almost immediately
jinxed it but even just holding with
black here would be huge uh coach yeah I
just have a quick question before we
talk specifically about uh the moves uh
how did you all get gookash how did that
how did that go was it hard what you
know how was the process for that
yeah no great question
um we we had Shanklin and Robson on the
team so we wanted like a really really
strong player here and we were just
through the list we uh we saw freshman
to to still be available like he wasn't
on any of the the lineups which was
definitely surprising and then um it was
it was David David Bruce's idea he was
like yeah maybe I'll reach out to gukesh
and I was like okay sure David great
yeah reach out to gukesh see if he's
available you know I'll keep looking for
other players on my end and then he
accepted like in the middle of the WR
Masters he was playing the Super
tournament
um but he was in a very response super
professional
um that was great I mean I'm I was so
pumped when we got him I feel like it
really really elevated the team
that was quite a good pick and
especially
especially since performance and this is
we know a huge match for the California
unicorns who of course are looking for
that three those three match wins and
we're gonna leave you to enjoy your team
performance here it is quite a stressful
moment with all boards uh fireworks have
we wish you all the best for this one
and hope we'll see you again thank you
for joining us thank you thanks so much
guys appreciate it see ya
wow so they do have Costa under
the going mgg MGD way on a couple of
boards here we've got this one really
important for our generic acid with the
white pieces offering a queen trade now
even in end games with that H Pawn being
a passer I I feel like it's such it's
the kind of position where the middle
game margins better but even the end
game
absolutely the end game and let's not
forget Chris you made that decision on
the fourth move
now when you make when you do this you
really hope the game does not go to an
end game because when that H Pawn does
get cleared out uh you will have a past
Pawn as you just mentioned so very tense
game very tense game and the thing about
guys like Arjun with all this experience
is not to say that Christopher doesn't
have this experience but they are so
accurate for ever for it and they will
make things so practically challenging
for you because you know I feel like
Eric geise has played Magnus in 15 20
rapid games that is a massive experience
boost you know how to stay focused for
70 Moves straight right so if you apply
that to your other games you're going to
be super accurate Chris use getting down
to that 40 second Mark and when I say
that he was the Wild Card the kind of
Joker card of the match he's had two
very very tense fighting games Tanya
right but
so far it's looking like he might not
even get half a point out of these first
two rounds uh which is okay because he's
the board three and he's playing boards
one and two but I really would have
liked to see him score uh this one is
going down to the wire and he's only got
25 seconds on the clock I mean I don't
even know how much of a wire it's going
to be with that h-bond advancing you set
it at the start of this match me got
that pawn me going to push that pawn
that's what Arjun is following up with
Levy Arjun arigasi is a beast in speed
chess he not only has the Champions
Chester experience of playing against
the very world's best and holding his
own but he was also the winner of the
Tata steel chess India rapid and Blitz
where he took down lab on arunian and
several of the other top Indian Grand
Masters as well he is such a strong
player and look at him marched on that
board he doesn't even blink an eye the H
Pawn has reached eight six meanwhile
Christopher used Bishop on G6 is a sad
sad piece Arjun has to find the winning
blow and it's got to be around this age
Pawn how do you build this attack is
Knight H4 an idea luckily for
Christopher you that Bishop still has a
square on H7
wow yeah I thought it was maybe bringing
the Knight but I would never in a
million years play that move I don't
know if it
I think he's going F1 to G3 and then to
H4 is that the point yeah yeah yeah I
did I think so and then bringing the
yeah and then bringing the other oh my
God he doesn't it's nice F1 9g3 Knight
H4 you attack the bishop you attack that
one on F5 the Knight jumps to H5 it's a
nightmare position for black and we see
the eval bar moving up and Christopher
you with a tough task of defending this
position with just 13 seconds on the
clock
absolutely uh we've been we've been
given breaking news by the way that Ilia
newsnik has made a very big mistake in
his game
against harika dronavali and uh she's
breaking through oh my goodness it looks
like a buzzer beater who's gonna win
this Pawn race
I mean it's Queen for black to win it
right it was the H bond in arjun's case
it's the H Pawn here for harika as well
if F3 what a nice move getting rid of
that G2 Pawn your C6 Pawn will be
stopped by The Rook on G8 but who is
stopping that H Pawn harika goes G4 and
now she's he's gonna pick up the she's
gonna pick up uh the pawn on G4 with a
check but she says I don't even want
that whatever oh my gosh and white is
like a move away C7 Knight d8 shield and
then Queen but the King has to choose
the that's it I mean it's game over
oh be careful maybe if you take there's
a way for black to get back white to get
back with checks she sticks with the
Rook H1 is coming in and if white goes
C7 and that's it
celebrating with a fist bump because she
knows she's got a very crucial point for
her team wow wow what an absolutely
massive win I mean ultimately this match
is going to come down to clutch
performance as I said at any given
moment it seems like California is the
team uh to win 3-1 and oh my goodness
wow it's over between Arjun Eric icy
wait he's just ending one after the
other as we can see and Arjun aragassi
wins with the white pieces if you see on
the top left I think uh Christopher are
you there did he just get flat no the
game is still on I'm sorry about that
Knight G7 rookie try what is happening
here no he just lost the Rook
he just hung a rook I mean it was in a
bad position already but he played Rook
H5
and Knight takes that was the end of the
game
wow but it was still a very difficult
position to defend regardless of that
but this is what happened and you've got
no time on the clock and indeed
Christopher you uh we're just seconds
made a huge blunder and lost that and
here this one's going to end in a draw
as we see this is a big save butyan gosh
for the MGD one against the board one of
California unicorns a stalemate at the
end gosh saves half a point
half a point but it's three and a half
to half Tanya I said when last round was
over 2-2 is a perfect setup for a 4-0 I
don't know how it happens that the teams
have this little feeling out process
like a round one of a five round fight
and in round two absolute pandemonium
and Chaos Chris you better for a little
bit loses ilionic winning out of the
opening in a couple of moments loses
kukesh unable to break through three and
a half to half oh my
you know how it is expect the unexpected
in these formats you've got no time on
the clock that's when blunders happens
nerves come in and that's what we saw a
three and a half to half margin that is
a huge score line and with that going
into round three Levy it means team MGD
one leads with a three-point margin and
they can they can potentially wrap up
this match in the very next round we
know that the golden score is eight and
a half for a match win if they win 3-1
they already won this three and a half
to half if they win 3-1 the match is
over
absolutely we very well could be done in
in three rounds
this is shocking this is completely
shocking and I am thrilled to eat my
words because I I enjoy these completely
insane turnarounds but you couldn't have
predicted three and a half to half you
just absolutely and
welcome to the pro chess League
I love that Welcome to the
computer and we're gonna be back with
round three as California unicorn
unicorns trail with three points they
need to start scoring big we'll be back
with all the chess actions in just a few
minutes
yeah
so I loved puzzles I loved solving any
puzzle you put in front of me so chess
was unnatural for my brain it was the
unsolvable puzzle it wasn't one of those
things you just looked at here is the
puzzle what's the solution it it was a
puzzle inside of an enigma right inside
of a mystery like what is this game and
there was so much to it the more you
learned the more there was to learn so
that puzzle solving uh gift that I had
or desire wish you know I would do
crossword puzzles back in the day as
well as a little as a high school kid
fell in love with New York Times
crossword puzzles had to do one of those
every every day that the puzzle came out
in the paper so I always was a puzzle
solver and I think that that made it
easy for me to to transfer over that
skill set to chess
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
in competitive chess the weight of a win
draw or loss is all on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my God
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
this might have just been the most
insane PC all around I've ever seen what
the heck did we just witness welcome
back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives the car spent like two and
a half minutes and he beat a guy that I
would probably not beat so this is
unbelievably impressive entering its
Fifth Season 16 teams will reboot the
PCL Legacy with a new format and new
schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion I would go back down
are you kidding me
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
yeah he is both players are holding
their heads this is the most rarest
result I've ever seen
we have Arjun aragasi who was the star
player for the Indian team winning a
board medal at the Olympiad and right
now he is the star player for the MGD
one as he's got a perfect 100 score at
the start of the day with two out of two
we see him on our screen that is his
chest room with a lot of books at the
back you can see where the inspired play
comes from and it's also really nice to
see Levy a young player with a chess
board and a book set up because usually
these kids they're just always working
with the laptop
what kids aren't you never guess he's
like 20. I just I also have this effect
like I look at Arjun and I've been
covering his games for years I'm like oh
he's a kid and then I look at his gear
I'm like wait a minute he's like 18 19
years old he could uh you know he he has
like oh all all of the uh all of the
signs of uh of adult life already but
you're right and I gotta tell you Tanya
uh I really really struggle to use a
physical board like to study chess I
mean it's all online it's all looking at
a stock Vision we have this beautiful
graphic up shout out to The Graphic team
our generic icy wins everything that's
the summary of this graphic he's a beast
uh and Tanya do you you know you you
grew up
playing chess in India obviously is is
there a buzz in India for chess like is
is like because in the Chess World we
see it we see all the results but is
there a buzz truly
it's huge I mean the Jasper meringue has
been so massive and these young players
that we're seeing are all an outcome of
that you know the whole pandemic had
this massive effect in the Chess World
for India at least I think all over the
world but we saw so much happen and now
these youngsters one after the other
just a lot I think just a couple of days
ago India got its 81st Grand Master as
well Arjun argessi they're all in well
you say now he's 20 but they're all
players who are so young so bright and
talented and we saw him crack one of the
biggest deals in the history of Chess a
1.5 million dollar sponsorship yeah
definitely chess in India is booming the
fans are loving it but for now it's all
about the chess action and we're loving
that because round three is about to
start and it would be potentially the
end of this matchup if mgd1 takes the
win with 3-1 the California unicorns
have to do everything that they can to
ensure that doesn't happen they need to
start winning the match with a big score
it is look at this we've got dukesh who
scored a point and a half Ilia who's got
a point but the bottom two boards
Christopher and Sabina Levy they need to
start performing for the team and they
need to do it now
they need to do it now everything that's
coming true is sort of unfortunately
coming true very quickly like having a
board for Grand Master really helps I
mean she beats Ilya niznuk which is just
fantastic Christopher you had two really
really good positions but unfortunately
when you're kind of the wild card that
could mean anything that could mean that
you go 2-0 in your first two games to
support three or you go oh two so
unfortunately things have gone
bad and when they go bad in this uh in
this event they can go bad really really
quickly we've seen the chess bras come
back from being down three the one
problem is they had Magnus Carlson now
Agnes cannot play all four boards which
by the way if Magnus simult a team of
four he might still win I'm I'm just
gonna say that right now but as we look
at the head-to-head matchups I don't see
a Magnus Carlson so there is no board on
which a guaranteed point one point it is
possible except obviously maybe like the
California unicorns have a weaker board
for than MGD one but I don't know Tanya
I mean five and a half two and a half is
terrifying seems like mgd1 is in really
good form today
a hundred percent I mean with that score
line it's clear that all the players
from mtd1 are performing so far I think
it comes down to that both three that we
just saw with Christopher you against
harika that's going to be the X Factor
but harika has been informed today she's
shown some really great chess but
Christopher you currently zero two but
he had great positions he needs to start
converting them uh and a levy it's so
important for those bottom two boards
really to try scoring for the California
unicorns to try to get this into uh into
round four and uh our players are about
to get ready a big round coming up
yeah I'm glad that we don't have the
players up on the screen yet because
it's a very funny image I mean we could
bring it up for comedic effect but we oh
never mind they just got fixed yeah we
had adibon baskaran stacked like the
wrong way so he was his camera was and
then we had no goo catch which black
screen like
um uh the wrong way sounds a lot like
his chest it's
it's all the way around so hard to
understand what's going on there I know
I know know that listen these matches
come down to one game like imagine Chris
Hugh just wins that game it changes
everything it just completely changes
everything and we saw yesterday in the
second round we nearly four owed
Shanghai I mean our board four almost
beat or I guess board three very close
Alina kershlinski almost took down way
these things happen uh and and uh we
ended up winning 4-0 in the third round
so if we saw anything from yesterday one
of two things is going to happen right
now either mgd1 is gonna literally win
4-0 and this day will be over or a
massive comeback will happen and then we
will have a blitz playoff as this is no
in between
oh that sounds exciting either ways
right well from
good case taking on his very good friend
adibana both these players know each
other super well they know their Styles
they've again trained together they've
spent a lot of time together played
against each other a number of times so
it's very interesting to see that so
early on gokish has managed to surprise
adiman with just his third move it
started as a Queen's Gambit Decline and
Knight F6 now Levy even if adibon was
not expecting Knight F6 in this position
it is one of the big common moves here
it can't be that big a surprise that you
take over a minute on this position
yeah I don't know what's happening there
uh
uh I I've already Bond it's Knight F3
that's the move here there we go all
right it took him a little while I mean
foreign
takes Pawn he wanted to play exchange
variation I don't know
oh he took his wall and eventually he
took a while and then eventually made
the moon night after he as you said this
is the most common move and now are we
going to see ra goes in with Bishop to
B4 are we going to see a Queen's Gambit
decline with Bishop to E7 or maybe a
third option of aggressively picking up
the pawn on C4 while gkesh decides what
to do we do have liftoff on our other
boards so let's bring up our bird's eye
view and do a little quick opening tour
to take a look at what's happening
because I see a certain a certain London
system levy on one of our boards Arjun
he goes for it and it's not something
he's doing for the first time what side
are you on because I feel like in the
world there are two kinds of people one
who love the London system the others
who hate it what team are you on
I'm on the side of you should play
openings that you understand if you if
you can teach your opening in an hour
time the moves and the ideas in various
positions to a five-year-old
then you understand your opening I am a
firm believer you could play as many
londons as you want I think all of these
Grand Masters who say that it's sabotage
is your long-term chess development got
no clue what they're talking about they
need to stay in their Lane by the way we
can pop that game open we can take a
look at uh Eric I see uh his game and
I'm going to take this a step further
I think openings like the grunfeld the
night ORF and so on they should be off
limits to people who you gotta like pass
a graduation test you know like you get
your belts purple belt and blah blah all
these like 1400s playing Knight ORF
they crazy I don't know what they're
doing uh and uh yeah player London
player London do you I feel like I'm
gonna take the pro London stance what do
you think you're the pro London I I'll
tell you one
that played in London but I also hate
facing the London so it's kind of I'm a
little torn on that but this is quite an
interesting outcome because we see that
archons managed to get his Queen on H5
and that would be really scary if he had
a Supporting Cast and I mention it and
Arjun says one second you guys wanted a
Supporting Cast I'm gonna try and open
that Bishop on D3 G4 that is a
spectacular move not only opening up the
G file but trying to open up that Bishop
let's see how we got there it's
interesting that Arjun didn't play
Bishop D3 He played Knight E5 yeah
newshnuk really likes to play if I
remember correctly he really likes to
play Bishop E7 and he really likes to
play uh Knight H5
he likes this line a lot going for the
bishop if I remember anything about his
repertoire uh and in fact I've looked at
his games before because I was trying to
get inspired so 95 is a very aggressive
way to play it and now you know what's
weird though every guy I see is playing
like he's the one down three points like
he doesn't need to play like this he's
just playing chess so win lose draw he's
gonna play aggressive chess he's gonna
take on F5 he's gonna play Rook G one oh
oh you know this is gonna blow up and we
will come back to this but take a look
at what's happening on the bird's eye
view on the bottom right board there the
bar is saying that white is absolutely
lost we've got to go quickly to the
Sabina Falls
she's just lost one board what is
happening what is happening is she just
lost the piece
she just lost the piece it's a threat on
the bishop if you take I take my Bishop
hits your queen and then I'm gonna play
C3
like I'm it's a it's a it's I mean it's
a very uncommon exact position but this
is a very common kind of theme where you
attack a piece It's gotta go and then
you have a fork that what makes this
possible is this well what did she walk
into it what was her last move she
played 95 she played oh my God she
played Queen F3 to go here losing the
game on the spot to C4
that's it you just lose
you just lose I mean I don't even say
hope you can take on C4 and if black
takes on C4 you might go Bishop E4 but
it looks like you won't survive it
because let's just show that if you go
Bishop E4 you can perhaps just pick up
the bishop and then go F5 because the
Bish the Knight is pinned on e4 yep
that's that's probably like the absolute
final
kind of dagger is probably that it's
probably just F5 and uh yeah you're just
completely lost
she takes on D7 fast but it's not really
gonna help because after Knight D7
you recapture with the Knight and the
same threats if you move back with the
bishop C3 is a fork a fork on the bishop
on B2 and the Knight on D2 if you take
on C4 we've seen these lines
wait if if Knight takes D7 I think you
can play BC DC now Bishop E4
because the Knight is no longer able to
take on e4 right so what so you have to
oh this is a big moment then he has to
recapture with the queen to win the
piece yeah take with the queen BC DC ah
and that's it that's how you do it and
then you still preserve this F5 F5 is
the key with no F5 this is not possible
so you need your knight on F6 to be able
to trade that Bishop on e4 to be able to
eventually win the piece dip down taking
his time he's going to calculate this so
being out there shaking her head she
can't believe what she's done with the
white pieces out of the opening and this
could prove to be super costly for her
team
well literally right before this game uh
I had mentioned that when you're down
three right and you have a Magnus on
your team you look at a Magnus you look
at a Hikaru in this format those are the
only two players you look at and go I'm
gonna get a win
right like I'm gonna get a win and if I
don't it's it's crazy it's we it's it's
a wild like they're the favorite against
anybody and then when they play each
other it's 55 45 on any given day in
Rapid and Blitz so uh
this is the only you can put it in
quotes massive favorite and he has
played Queen takes D7 in this matchup
right the three to three but
the rest is not and the unicorns can't
afford to keep bleeding points like
Sabina this was a bat round she had to
buckle down really really fight for the
half point because harika Tanya Haruka
is capable of beating anybody on the
other team we just saw that so yeah MGD
is a terrifying Squad absolutely
terrifying Squad and um terrifying but
Levy look at I was just gonna say now
that the queen has moved how do you win
a piece and there is more to the stack
the point is that he goes C3 anyway
gives up that pawn white takes that
Bishop the pawn with the bishop
Bishop E2 C3 happened
oh my gosh and Rook C8 a quiet move
because you don't have a good Square for
the bishop Bishop B4 falls to the bishop
on E7 you've got to go back to B2 then
he picks up the pawn on C2 it wasn't an
option so instead Sabina Retreats with
the Knight defending that Bishop the
Knight jumps forward she hasn't lost the
peace
how does she do that I like I that's
crazy I just put on my 800 ELO hat I
just saw a pawn and I was like I have to
take it like the pawn on C4 I completely
forgot there's no more C3 oh my God
and Levy this was exactly the reason
instinctively one thought of taking with
the Knight but regardless of that Queen
D7 is the right move as we saw Yes black
doesn't win a piece but you won back the
pawn on C2 and just compare the pieces
and what's the point of having that Rook
on A1 what's the point of having the
Knight on B1 that's not one piece down
you're playing two pieces down in this
position
I know
that's all I have to say back I'm
looking at this like
it looks like white played Fisher random
and gave black 10 moves to start the
game I mean look at White's starting
setup right right oh my goodness
Ah that's tough yeah that's tough so
Rook C1 is actually a really nice move
there really pinning the Knight on B1
forcing white to move the bishop to try
to get rid of it to try and trade but
don't forget that diptown can get the
other Rook into the game as well Rook
have C8 coming in this is full piece
domination on the board by black and it
looks like so being a Forza is going to
be in big trouble I don't think the eval
bar is even doing Justice to Black's
Advantage I I I feel I feel bad keeping
this on the screen any longer like it's
almost a little bit bullying let's go to
the bird's eye view real quick uh and
we're gonna head over to Christopher U's
game because I don't know what on Earth
is going on in his game I never know
what on Earth is going on in his game
and I especially don't know what's going
on in this game when I'm playing against
them uh so Bishop takes F5 is this
heading for a win or is this heading for
a Perpetual check because one of those
moments where white does not have more
attacking pieces than black has guards
but it might be geometrically in a spot
where white can get some big kind of a
thing going and uh Bishop takes F5 is my
style of move Tanya I know you uh you
might go Rook F3 Rook H3 we're very very
clashing Styles which is why when we
played against each other it was a lot
of fun uh it was actually a lot of fun
no no I'm glad that you bought that up
no no no no no I only knocked out but
thank you for bringing it up listen I
only won that match one of my DACA
moments in life I I only won that match
because they made us play bullet if it
was more 5-1 and I would have I would
have jumped out of a window I mean your
playing style is so tough to plug it in
that wine
but it was because the bullet right it
was because you know silly one minute
and because of your ability to take
decisions like Bishop F5 in these faster
formats
automatic questions my big question back
would be that if hurricane just grabs
that bishop and let's say you take it
back with the knight uh if we can just
have that on the analysis board Bishop
F5 I get greedy because I really don't
want to let that Bishop live and I fall
back with my king to h8 I'm a little
afraid of falling to G8 because I just
feel Queen S6 Queen G7 ideas I want that
g file for my Rook so King h8 lovey come
come at me with your attack here how are
you doing it
yeah I guess you have to play Rook F3
because if you play Queen h8 I'm just
gonna go Rook G8 and then I have bishop
f8 and you're dead
so that doesn't work uh which means by
the way it's happened by the way
they run for it yeah Rook F3 Rook H3 but
um
I mean this is like a massive investment
is he sure he has a mate
I mean it's very scary and Hurricane's
got four minutes how difficult is it's a
lot more difficult for Haruka right to
find the resource here because Rook H3
is a direct threat Rook G7 doesn't work
there's a knight on S5 Rook G8 Knight f8
I think he missed
oh wow
actually
is there like a queen
's completely nuts no no I don't think
it quite works there's wait does it work
no way
ah it doesn't work
yeah but the king runs ah it would have
been so cool
oh the King goes all the way out here
and I have no pieces left oh but it is
completely lost but why okay three and
then Rook G7 doesn't happen after Knight
f8 maybe you just pick up the F7 Pawn
oh yeah it's on the board by the way
you're calling this out naira fit play
it and now well he can't take Queen F7
which looks super tempting attacking
that Bishop on B7
oh that might be that even that's that's
a problem that's a problem Knight F7 is
very hard to meet in fact it's like
almost impossible to me I have to say
wow I think that's just all actually
much stronger than Queen F7 because now
you're not only hitting the Rook but
Knight F7 is a massive threat and if you
go Rook G7 then you go Knight F7
I I almost want to be annoying and not
even play Knight F7 but I think you
probably have to yeah you probably it's
about time what was the move there I
thought Rook G8 not a fake but I missed
Knight F7 so what what why was she
winning what
I don't know
why was she winning how how is she
winning
you know there are ideas of trying to do
a seven track defense with F6 but it's
so complicated you've got F6 Rook H3 the
Knight on g6's pin oh my God not only
can we not find it harika did not find
it and instead she's in this dead last
position we can see it on the live board
Levy let's get up to date with that yeah
wait I just very quickly want to show
what the engine shows is the saving line
Bishop C8
which looks like it does nothing because
but but Knight H4
and whatever you take with I take that
and then that loses a guard and if this
then I take care
brought up stockfish that is so absurd
what Bishop C8 Knight H4 put that in a
book oh my God I would have never found
that in three minutes good luck finding
that ever I mean that is just impossible
and so easy to miss which is why
Christopher you went for this line I
don't think either of them saw that
result and you can't blame them no no no
no they probably they probably just both
thought that white is winning and uh
yeah if there's one stockfish line that
saves a position like that and it it the
position's lost like like nobody's
finding that you know what I mean so
that's it's very important as a also as
like a as a intermediate player and so
on to understand that if stockfish shows
that one line Saves the Day
all that good stuff um yeah Chris is uh
in good shape very good inside actually
because so easily we can say that
there's a way out of this position and
you know if you've got the eval bar
guiding us and then you see the engines
and then you say that you know this
could have just this is winning but if
actually it's only one move that does
that in
in almost nine out of 10 cases that move
will not be found unless your Magnus or
Hikaru in this time format
you know I I would be willing to bet
they wouldn't they wouldn't find with
four or five minutes on like I mean I
just don't know like I actually at 984
yeah it's kind of hard right wait what
why Queen H6 I thought Queen okay fine
fine I'm not you know
fine
uh it's still not over I mean we you
know we can talk about the imbalance in
the position with the material white has
got a rook and how many point pawns is
that that's seven to four three pawns
and a rook for two pieces and an attack
against the king so it looks like
Christopher you is better but Levy we've
seen him we've seen him mess up enough
winning positions today so he has work
to be done but he needs to make sure
that he takes this point for the
California unicorns let's bring up a
bird's eye view really quickly and take
a look on how the other boards are doing
because while Christopher you looks like
he's doing a really well Sabina Forza
against dipty on gosh I think she's
managed to get things a lot better we
see that on the bottom right at least
her pieces are out there's no more pain
on the last Rank and then on the top
right board adeban again with what looks
like quite a strong position his Rook is
on the seventh rank I'm loving it that
pawn structure that we've been talking
about that black has looks like bad news
F7 weakness so this looks like MGD one
is doing well on that board again kukesh
yeah let's uh pop over there and um yeah
regassi and nishnux game is a draw every
half Point matters right you're up by
three every half point just means
another game in the books
got a nice position I I you know
interesting decision by gukesh to play
Queen's Gambit to Club
he makes a blunder
96 that's 96 yeah I don't know wow
or Knight A5 and the computer approves
he finds that he hits that Bishop moves
I'm still struggling to see where is the
hill Oh F3 and uh rookie seven
but Bishop A8 yeah but like Adam maybe
that's the whole point like you have to
put your Bishop on A8 I don't know
maybe that's the point I
and Levy let's show your point because
this is so important that actually you
want to get rid of this Bishop from this
diagonal because there's a nasty little
tactic and let's say you go Bishop B1
you take an E7 black recaptures and then
there is a fork on the ball you fork and
you win The Rook you win the game uh
that will be the end of it which means
that black has to maintain that Bishop
on this diagonal which is why after F3
you can go Bishop D5 for one move but
that's all that you're hanging in there
with E4 and what Levy's saying is that
the bishop is dead on it
completely I mean just look at this
position like black has no moves okay
maybe A4 is not the most accurate move
but it doesn't even well it just has no
moves but I can't move any pieces oh my
God
and he's played it yeah and uh what I
was gonna say is odd decision
to play for a win with black
and play qgd right like I it almost
feels like you know adibon does not need
a second invitation to go party so play
something a little bit just more a
little more provocative right but but
now it's all gone wrong and uh can the
match end seven points is gonna be for
MGD I don't know
I mean they need three one to end this
they're already on Six Points so really
this is a huge magnification needs to
find a way to survive it E4 on the board
Bishop A2 runs into the sacrifice that
we've been talking about on E7 and the
Falcon C6 Bishop eight you can make a
move like group two A7 not allowing the
Black Brook really paralyzing it down
the board as well hitting the pawn on
Asics dukesh with 20 seconds huge
trouble he falls back with the bishop
doesn't give material is busted
three such a disrespectful move just
just B3
and that's it I mean uh whether or not
we even play a fourth game will
completely depend on how Chris you and
harika finish their game and he he is
still applying a lot of pressure in that
game as we take a look at the bird's eye
view uh uh if we can pop over there I
think sabina's game she is indeed
completely lost so let's go look at
Chris you this this completely
determines if we talk about this match
for another hour or not
wow and it looks like Christopher you
has continued to build on that Advantage
now Levy these kind of positions it's
still hard to call a result because if
harka is able to find activity for the
minor pieces it could be anyone's game
but the problem is with the attack on
the king that's really hard to do and
rookie it takes control of the e-file
Rook G6 you're pointing out hitting that
Knight the Knight will have to jump to
E4
yeah I was also looking at like Knight
G8 if that if that's anything okay it's
played and It's gotta be the best move
because
I mean she's gonna eat all the pawns
like what can you do right
I thought you were gonna say it's got to
be the best move because you called out
and you did oh no no no I'm always
terrified okay yeah and there it is but
I don't why is this like completely how
are you doing this I thought 94
. yeah yeah okay Queen H5 is apparently
self-pinning is the wrong way to go I
would have probably gone to F4
apparently it's losing again now why is
it losing I don't know G4 just just push
all your Pawns
he I don't like his time trouble he he
has blundered a bit today in the time
trouble and it's different being 3 000
when you start the game with one minute
each okay versus getting to one minute
out of a 10 minute game uh that's the
difference
when you play Queen H5 and on the next
move you go Queen H4 that's when you
realize that the player knows that
something in a
ction just one move but but Christopher
you saying I've got enough time to fix
the error Now The Rook is free to pick
up the B6 Pawn as well Bishop F5 is that
something that black can even consider
putting your own pieces into the pin
would have been super dangerous The Rook
could have fallen back and hit that
Bishop instead harika coming out with
the Knight she's got to take this F5
Pawn it's her only chance in the
position yeah it's her only chance but
uh I don't I I do not see Christopher
messing this one up uh it's very hard I
think what makes it much easier here is
that this bishop is completely useless
like it does not partake in Black's
attack it's only sitting there defending
uh
if Chris U gets down to five seconds and
panics and blunders a fork somehow he
might lose but other than that I mean
black can't move like he's just gonna go
Rook C8 Queen F5 and he can always win
an end game up I'm not even gonna count
them he's up 87 pawns I think he'll win
uh close enough yeah and uh it will be
a very practical decision as well just
uh getting rid of uh any counter play
but he had to watch out for that mate in
one on G2 so he first defends that yeah
G3 Knight falls back to E7 now a white
can even think about just trading Queens
going into another winning end game yeah
Pleasant choices but very often that is
the problem in every position Levy when
you have too many good moves and you've
got seconds on your clock yeah that can
be a recipe for disaster yeah this is
how I lose basically all my games in
title Tuesday uh there the positions are
usually not this good but it's very
demoralizing for sure you but like I
said I mean white can move back and
forth and black just does not have
anything except Maiden one which some
people would have blundered right like
it's never too late to blunder mate in
one so he didn't and now it should be
easy
it does trade off the queens and now
it's just all about attacking he does
attack the D5 Pawn to try to create a
parcel in the Santa harika can't afford
to give up that pawn bishop B7
unfortunately is not possible it invites
Rook D7 and the other Rook jumping on to
F7 which would double up then on the
seventh rank that would be disaster and
with no Bishop B7 on the board I think
harika is going to lose the D5 Pawn next
and the game yep
you just you got nothing you're quickly
running off of Rook D5 Bishop B7
but oh Rook D5 Bishop B6
oh my God it's never over
Maybe
three and go Rook to see
unfortunately she is down four pawns
three pawns never mind she took only
three but uh Knight and Bishop are
better than a rook like nine times out
of ten but not when you are down
three Pawns in an end game and uh you
have to stop passers so in this case uh
yeah this is gonna be crazy and you know
what's crazy like we live in a world
where Chris you could have drawn or won
one of the last couple of games and he
would have had like two and a half
you know
and look at the math score it's three to
eight if Christopher wins this one he
keeps the California unicorns alive but
going in the next round mgd1 with their
lineup of Arjun aragasi adeban harika
deeptown gosh need half a point to win
the match
a little demoralizing there for the
unicorns yep yes it is A7 and uh
slide The Rook over make a queen
and that that's even more brutal ouch
and Chris you picks up a a very
necessary win as the unicorns are now no
longer down three they are down four
points and if
even if they win every single game in
the next round we get a playoff
crazy 8-4 is uh eight four is tough it's
like if a boxer can throw in the towel
but they won't they're gonna fight and
they now need to win Tanya on every
single board
to take us to playoff and that itself is
a Monumental task but with that win that
Christopher you had he makes sure well
the unicorns they say don't exist but
they do exist in this match still
because of that win which means we get
around for Levy four out of four it's
something that we've seen happen before
in the protest League you can't write it
off but it's definitely a tough one uh
and I I mean I have to be honest with
that roster not getting half a point
that's going to be that's unbelievable
right now but the match goes on and we
will be back with the final round of the
California unicorns taking on MGD one
hello and welcome to this video
my name is Christoph zileki I'm an
international master in chess from
Germany and I'm here to share with you
why in the opening plays such an
important role in modern chess the
opening in chess is like coming prepared
with a battle plan you play a move but
it's part of a larger strategy you want
to have an idea what to do against every
possible response that your opponent may
play against you want to have a plan a
strategy laid out before the game even
starts this can be really deep on the
top level of 10 20 30. you don't need
that much but you want to be prepared to
get a game that you enjoy playing it's
more fun to play and give you more
chances to win more games I've always
loved studying the opening figuring out
new ideas how to beat my opponents and
set traps this is now my profession
writing courses on openings for
chessable I've created more than a dozen
the most popular ones being of the keep
it simple series I have received an
award this year the author of the year
what I invite you to do is go to
chessable.com and check out how to play
the opening better get fun positions and
win more games
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know
foreign
[Music]
thank you
the California unicorns need a clutch
win at this point and there is big
responsibility on Augusta's shoulder
with a big trophy behind him trophies
all around him really giving him all the
inspiration that he needs to play some
inspired chess in this final run of the
California unicorns versus the team MGD
well I say a final round that we might
have more chess but for that the
unicorns have to
win with a four to zero margin to take
it to playoffs now we've seen that
happen before in the protest League
Indian yogis did it against the chess
bras to take their comeback but will it
happen now it is a huge moment for these
players Levy
what chances would you give to the
unicorns to make this a reality
zero chances
I mean listen I I know my job is to
convince the audience they got to
continue watching uh
go for a walk like put in your
headphones it don't sit by your screen
like you want to watch put it else in
your airpods this match is over MGD just
absolutely showed up to fight today
however here's the big question how many
points are the unicorns gonna get back
they are no strangers to being down
three to four points going into the
final round I don't know it just seems
to be their style Tanya against us they
were down seven and a half four and a
half all right and uh
they ended up winning three out of four
in the last round so who knows maybe
they just saved their best for last but
again this comes down to their big
discrepancy on board four and you have
to play a GM the day has not gotten any
easier for Sabina she played 2700 2600
2500 now she has to play another 2500.
is actually the only one of the only
teams who has the ability to stack up
their team with four grand Masters the
only one of the other teams is was
Charlotte cobras but yes you're totally
right with this lineup of four grand
Masters them needing half a point it
looks like a zero percent chance it
isn't too far from reality so lovely
they're just keeping it real you've got
gokish taking on Arjun and that's a big
match up there Mukesh needs to win
Eliana needs to win Christopher you need
to do it Sabina needs to win how is this
effort going to happen I know and listen
uh given that we are an all-im broadcast
I will just say having the G in front of
your title is a nice vanity number uh
and a nice vanity title but uh there is
a level difference it takes a level
difference to get the title of Grand
Master there is a reason that they all
have it and they should be proud that
they are Fielding a team of four GMS the
only other one in the league is the
leviedov chess Wizards who feel
Alexandra Costa nuke who is like the
second or third highest rated woman in
the world uh In classical chess I
believe and they have Dennis lazovic who
is probably 120 feet a points underrated
uh and here we go I mean this this
matchup in and of itself is crazy
because gukesh has to win on demand
um Queen's Indian chosen by Eric icy
little queen's Indian action this is not
a Catalan even though white is playing
the Catalan setup
but uh the unicorns have to win on every
board
they have to win on every board and
Arjun chooses what is known to be a very
very safe line for black almost almost
the borderline boring there but he
chooses an aggressive choice in it he
takes out the bishop on A6 instead of B7
and this can be a super super thrilling
middle game because the C4 Pawn was
attacked White had to step up with the
queen Arjuna gives a check Bishop D2
very often the black Bishop falls back
to E7 in these positions and what you've
done is actually made it more difficult
for white to find that coordination
within the pieces with B3 Bishop B2
coming in and we might be seeing Arjun
falling back with the bishop but the
fact that he's taking his time I'm
wondering if he's actually thinking
about trading on D2 or developing the
queen like you're pointing out
he's thinking Tanya hot take
hot take give it why did they name the
team MGD one why couldn't they have
chosen like a cool name and just put the
sponsor logo big somewhere come on guys
like isn't this marketing 101 I don't
know what an MGD is does anybody know
what an MGD is uh like maybe I'm not in
the right spot to get professional
advice I don't know what MGD is I'm just
like all right whatever it's MGD I guess
but what if it's come on
I guess they're the Hollywood MGD one is
Manu gurtu who is one of the uh managers
and you know the leaders behind this
theme and I don't know what D1 is but I
have my own theory that I wonder if D1
is on it because it's the square of the
queen so and they do have harika on
their team who is the queen of Indian
chess so just the fact that you need to
do just the fact that you need to do
this Sherlock Holmes to figure out the
team name they could have just named
themselves something cool like yogis all
right
now on broadcast so that we do have the
answer of it it's a great question Levy
we'll get down to the mystery the bottom
of this but whatever that name is you
know it doesn't matter what the name is
it matters what your game is that's what
these guys are doing today
and you know what they say right
they say that we don't really need to
care about their name because the chess
speaks for itself there it is
there it is Bishop G2 on the board in
this game and the well the unicorns have
to pull off a fairy tale that does not
exist just like their name and win all
four boards brutal I know listen I I'm
sorry but
they're in trouble Tanya I don't know
what to say
all right well this one is going to be a
long grind we do know one thing for sure
that gokesh is going to play till the
very end on this openings and actions
have started on the other boards this is
uh the update from all the other three
boards and take a look at that top right
screen adiban against the Ilia now I see
Ilyas King is still in the center he's
trying with the white pieces it's so
important with him to create chances and
imbalances and that's what he's done
he's taken the double pawns on the F
line adiman going in with Knight G4
there are all kinds of tactics in this
position also take a look at that bottom
right table now this is the one where I
think it's going to be super difficult
harika with the white pieces against
Sabina if Sabina wins this she is the
star of the day regardless of what
happens on the other three boards yeah
she's the goat if she wins uh but I'm
concerned like even bottom left just to
really quickly show the Chris U game
that's uh a ridiculous theoretical line
uh which is from this kind of like
English type of thing if we can just
pull up the analysis board yeah and uh
it's this E3 line D5 and then you play
Knight takes you ignore the Knight you
go here while the Knight is stuck and
can't really come back although that is
a line in and of itself black kind of
gets induced into playing this and white
plays Bishop A3 trades the King goes
here and you play H4 I I will I've won
so many games in Blitz because Black's
King is so weak but the 95 line in my
opinion is a little bit more resilient
here sacrificing the Knight Chris you
clearly going for this one I guess he's
taking risk right I mean like he has to
win so he's gonna have to take some
risks but uh this is the best position
that MGD has right now because it's just
cleanly better for white
that's really nicely pointed out all
these ideas of the opening
the dip down with the white pieces H4 H5
as you mentioned has happened with that
there's been more weakness on Black's
King side more dark Squad weaknesses
than Knight on F3 can't jump to G find
forcing the Knight to A5 when I say
forcing because black could not have
allowed to trade there just weakening
his Pawn structures in such a big way
but that really doesn't help putting
that Knight on the edge of the board it
has no future whatsoever Queen B2 eyeing
ideas like C4 D5 opening up the center
targeting that black king White's Knight
can jump to E5 The Rook can come to E1
so many Pleasant moves for white uh Levy
completely agree with your judgment that
it looks like diptown's the one for the
MGD one team to get the better position
right out of the opening
yep but if you have a better position
that often means it comes with a little
bit more forcing nature so maybe while
he tries to convert his Advantage
Christopher will get an opportunity by
the way Advantage more or less
squandered apparently by those last two
moves according to the the god that all
the chess players look up to this little
sliding thing on the left-hand side
um but this is a very tense game we see
Chris there focused we never know if
he's playing on an iPad on a on a
smartphone on a on a laptop on a smart
computer I mean on a smart refrigerator
he's like just always playing on a
random device and um let's take let's go
all around I see ilionuk on our bird's
eye view hasn't castled his King is on
F2 this this is a wild game this is a
matchup of the two most Wild players I
think on both sides uh at the top right
there we'll pop over to a niznik versus
Mr Fireheart uh AKA baskaran adiban
how does Bhaskar and adibon play when he
needs a draw
that's a that's a really tough one to
answer I think if a team needs a drawn
any bird adibon would be your last pick
to get that result but when you need to
win those matches he's exactly the
player you want on your squad Pickers of
the kind of chaos that he creates on the
board he is known as the Beast for his
aggressive style of play Monica on chess
come fire hot it is a reflection of the
kind of Chess and his personality he's
fearless and in this position we see
it's niznik being Fearless with that
King but it's heading to H2 where it
will be a lot safer and I see her eval
bar say that black is in a little bit of
trouble but Levy that's not so clear to
understand because actually it is white
has an extra Pawn
but the point I was trying to make was
it looks like black has compensation
take a look at those open files why are
you laughing I did I just didn't even
realize I was like oh it's an equal
position and one guy has a king on G3
okay thank God the guy who has this King
on g3 at least has something to show for
it in the form of a c Pawn oh my God I
was like I don't know why this is here
but whatever it's there he has to win uh
yeah okay King on G3 put up a pawn not
bad so it's like having first class seat
on the plane but you're sitting next to
a baby there you go so the King on G3
and but at least he has a c Pawn to show
for it
that's a great analogy uh yes there is
some pain and some gain here we see and
it took me I completely understand
because it took me a while as well to
figure out that white has an extra pawn
and that's why the bar seems to like the
position but Levy regardless of that
pawn it's clear that adiban has got
compensation and initiative not only is
the King on G3 there's so much peace
activity that F4 Pawn is a bit of uh it
just sticks out of this orthomas uh
Queen C7 targeting that F4 Pawn in
certain positions I think regardless of
what the uh the bar tells us it's
everything to play for here all three
results are possible White's extra Pawn
doesn't matter right now no for sure if
I if you make a move like B3 to just
kind of make sure your queen black queen
can never take your Pawn just even
Bishop F3 is super annoying because what
do you do do you damage your structure
do you bring your king closer to the
center
nothing looks good that doesn't look
very safe
I don't know I do not like that at all I
also don't want to move because if I
move my knight somewhere rookie 3 check
comes in which just looks absolutely
horrifying in fact that might just win
for black rookie three check I mean that
just looks miserable uh the fact that
it's not winning on the spot black is
better it's not winning though I don't
know uh super unpleasant decision now to
make for Ilia this is like I mean it's
like adibon's backyard this kind of
position
I will be super happy with why to try
and trade pieces and the idea that comes
to
comes to freeing a trade and at first
blunder because after Queen F2 let's not
forget that if black takes I don't know
if we can have the arrows that would be
just to express this idea Levy that
Queen F2 and black actually trades on F2
King F2 and it looks like you're hanging
the D3 Bishop after Bishop F3 but white
actually has a nice little Intermezzo he
can pick up the Rook on E8 with a check
distract that black Crook and then
recapture the bishop and then we can be
talking about that extra Pawn
yes this is very much an extra Pawn you
have you you now have the first class
ticket and there is no baby uh and it is
a completely winning position uh at end
game but we are far from that and I
don't think the Beast is gonna go down
into a uh into a root canal of
equivalent of an end game down one Pawn
I think he's gonna keep the position
Dynamic and it's up to Ilya to figure
out how to
maybe he's gonna have to Brave it and
put his I just want to see what's the
eval after Bishop F3 is it losing
oh my God it's not losing after King F3
wow so scary
but maybe there's nothing immediately
happening and the king is safe on F3
that's just unbelievable but I can't
imagine anyone going for this position
voluntarily you know just putting your
King on F3 in this time control when
you're down to five minutes
but I don't know Ilia might decide we
know he's a Fearless player he's taking
his time it's an important position
while he navigates through all these
troubles trying to prove his extra
material let's bring up our bird's eye
view you've got a couple of moments
before we jump back to this game but it
is hot action on the other boards in a
match where you call it California
unicorns have to win on all four boards
against Arjun on that top left it looks
like Arjun has everything in control
he's the one in control of the D file
well now the Rooks have been traded he
falls back with the bishop I don't
really see a big Advantage there for
white it is on the bottom right board
where harika with the white pieces is
the one who's with the dominating
position look at Black's queen and the
two Rooks it just looks like no space at
all she wants to she's taken control of
the B4 Square
it looks like mgd1 is the one who's
doing well on all the boards
Ilia did play Queen F2 by the way uh in
in this game just uh just to kind of
point that out uh in the meantime Krista
for you uh
uh is just much better on his board
maybe we pop over to check uh check on
the board for a matchup because that's
that's the biggest lopsided matchup
frankly so that's like the one where the
unicorns are
hoping and praying
that uh Sabina survives against harika
who's a top 10 woman in the world so
oh but oh God White's position oh my
goodness the Bishops are so strong
I don't know
well I'll tell you what Levy that is
definitely a strong Bishop pair like
you're pointing out with that G2 Bishop
which cannot be challenged not just that
now harika also potentially threatening
at a king cycle in advance with G4 and
this F5 Pawn sure it's double but it
takes away so many squares from black
Black's pieces meanwhile really
struggling the knight from Asics can't
come to E6 because of the F5 Pawn that's
why Sabina is trying to trade off pieces
when you've got less space you try to
liquidate the position but harika says
no thank you I'm keeping my Bishop there
so maybe night
Knight C7 your Bishop is loose on C5 I
sometimes the computer does these things
where it like gives back advantage to a
person and I just don't understand I
guess it's Knight H5 yeah very short oh
and you're in a trouble situation
because if you try to save your Bishop
you're pinned and you're gonna lose the
G3 pawn and another Pawn
so
that's a great move Sabina might might
be very close to equalizing
the position but Bishop D6 nice move
trying to get the Bishops off and
yaharak is just too sharp
I mean I think it's far from equalizing
harika wanting to trade now but again as
we say you trade on your own terms in
chess that's the way you get the
advantage and if black does accept the
bishop on D6 she'll go in with the rook
and the next move she'll double up on
the D file taking full control of the
only open file and like it's hard to
point out any nice juicy outposts for
blacks nights meanwhile the bishop on G2
is still a very strong piece we can
imagine a future B4 B5 breaking open the
C6 B7 Pawn structure that black has I
think harika knowing her style of play
knowing the kind of position she likes
to be in her style actually reminds me a
lot of Wesley extremely positional but
seizes the opportunities that she gets
and I think she's this one is up her
alley she's going to convert this into a
full point
yeah this is a really really Pleasant
position for white I mean this bishop is
just so strong and this Knight is not
getting into the game
ah it's tough I mean if Sabina can
somehow buckle down and defend and get
this to like a messy scramble that that
is their best chance because Chris you
uh I'm looking at at my screen here on
the bird's eye view wait a minute
wait a minute wait in the words of your
usual very famous in esteemed co-host
Peter lecko hang on
hang on because gukesh and Ilya niznik
both have good positions you choose
where we go
before we jump in let's just take this
in actually on all those three boards
with gokish with Christopher you and
with Iliana California Dreams I would
call them right now seem to be coming
true the unicorns doing really well
there so it might very well come to the
Sabina board I think we have to jump to
the u-board uh against diptan with the
white pieces it looks like ZIP down is
in trouble here
let the record reflect if Chris U wins
this game he had a winning position at
every single stage today I mean talk
about a wild card he goes two out of
four four games up and down sometimes
the Wild Card doesn't get you three or
four points but we'll take two beating
two very very strong opponents he's got
a total positional bind here God of a
bishop turns out that it was White's
King that was weak and even though white
was slightly better from the opening it
was just Chris understanding the
position talk about Tanya a light
squared bishop and a bunch of light
squared pawns and yet the bishop is
still a beast super strange position and
almost every white piece in fact the
move ago every white piece was on a dark
Square
like
talk about a light squared catastrophe
uh for the for the squad of white pieces
that's really nice he pointed out just
not all the light the pieces the pawns
as well are on the dark Square which is
what makes the position an absolute
disaster that Bishop on D5 is a monster
Imagine at some point if the queen and
the bishop can line up on that diagonal
that would be game over which is why the
Knight on G5 and The Rook on E3 are so
important trying to control that E4 F3
Square
and the H3 Square because ideas like
Queen F5 Queen H3 would be game over
right now it still looks like it's going
to be game over as a Christopher you
goes for that A5 Pawn Rook A4 played
there's no good Square for the queen
defending it Queen D6 trying to get some
activity but that's a lone Queen I don't
really see white creating any chances
here
Rook A5 and I mean
he's just gonna come down the board I I
don't know this sometimes the eval bar
feels like a Reviving heartbeat like a
defibrillator you know like oh white is
alive and I have no idea why Queen D7
and queen D7 he's hitting the Rook but I
don't think I think you can make any
move with the Rook you could be very
active with Rook C4 but you know it's
fine to even just keep the Rook on the
eighth rank to keep things defending
moves like Rook f8 come to mind you just
overgot the F7 square but knowing
Christopher you oh what
mate in one
wow Eight in One knowing Christopher you
he will not care about the Rook but go
for the king Rook F1 played because
Queen F2 was game over and now he's
gonna defend the Rook I think Rook C4 is
what I'm expecting because he just
always goes for activity
you know what's funny if he does go Rook
A8 the bishop look at this supporting
both Rooks what a Beacon of Hope
what a position what a position white
just has absolutely no play and yet give
give Hikaru this position I would not
put it past Hikaru to beat somebody with
this position when he had white I mean
there's just levels to this level uh to
the defense of these kinds of games and
uh okay Chris goes Rook d8
um can we go back to the bird's eye view
just for a quick second uh the the ninja
game is nuts I I want to go look at
gukesh because we kind of left them
because they're the board of Wands and
it was very balanced position but isn't
this very very much a good catch type of
game like if he had this with white in
the Olympiad when he went eight out of
eight he would just win right like he's
gonna beat everybody but what's his
winning plan here
but you're totally right these are the
kind of positions that gkesh really
enjoys and the reason for that is you
compare every each and every white piece
with black space white has got full
control of the d-line the Knight on E5
is better than Black Knight on 87 he's
got the space so what he's doing is he's
just defending that H4 Pawn there with
the King he's saying I'm not only gonna
play with the night Queen and Rook but I
want my king to be an active piece as
well a potential exchange on D7 is in
the air if we have an end game with Rook
D7 Rook D7 Queen D7 Queen D7 97 take
take take and then the C5 Pawn will fall
as well so Arjun not giving the case the
chance just yet trying to create play on
the king side but I'm expecting rukesh
to shut this with H5
H5 looks H5 looks very nice
but sometimes in these end games taking
the pawn is better because you know
black has a very odd decision do you
okay he plays H5 which
apparently was not the best move I was
gonna I I was just wondering if opening
the H file was beneficial for white but
uh I would play H5 like my first
instinct was like G5 H5 so natural yeah
it's just so natural because your king
is that you just want to keep everything
defended you keep all your pluses and it
doesn't matter if the computer thinks
it's the best move or not it is the most
human approach and now after Queen F6 uh
White needs to think about what to do
you're pointing out Queen E3 I like it
you centralize the queen he does it as
you're calling it out defends that
Knight puts pressure on C5 watch out
Knight D7 is a threat in the air picking
up the C5 Pawn
uh we have some breaking news seems like
things are going from bad to worse uh
for the unicorns on the fourth board
even though gukesh is doing well
harika in in control I mean Black's King
is
wide open that bar is now
up to plus four even though material is
equal that's how you know things are bad
so probably Queen C1 rookie four and I
mean her Knight literally did not move
and that and neither did this bishop but
when you talk about the quality right
just because a car doesn't move that
doesn't mean it's uh it's got a low
value this is a Ferrari and I don't even
know what that is
it's a it's a it's a
Ford it's just a Ford on A6 is what it
is
yeah it hasn't and queen E4 on the board
you want to get the queen to H4 next and
I like you said or the E7 Queen E7
hitting that pawn on B7 hitting that
pawn on F6 uh that Knight as you're
calling it a Ford I think even that's
overstating it right now it has been the
dead piece in the position it's just
this metal scrap no wheels nothing it's
just hey I I don't know I don't know why
she didn't like Queen C1 I was thinking
maybe Queen D2 but then there was like
rookie a check but it's a very natural
move computer maybe The Rook had to go
first like now The Rook can't go you
know maybe The Rook had to lead the
attack but uh
what can Sabina do
Queen Seven right Queen E7 but now Queen
E7 Queen E7 you hit the Rook on d8 you
hit the pawn on B7 you hit the pawn on
F7 the queen can't move from A5 is Queen
E7 just came over yeah because I think
she thought King G7 Queen B7 Queen E1
but first of all I have B4 and second of
all I have I have rookie for Rook G4 and
I like rookie for Rook G4 I mean anyone
would write rookie for Rook G4 would be
game over once the king comes to G7
expecting Queen E7 maybe Rook D7 might
give her some hopes because you want to
try to get the queen to D7 and then pick
up the Rook on E1 Rook C7 yeah actually
it's funny like that's that's a move
that you that that would be very very
annoying to face she's like oh man but
you take an
this hangs that hangs if if B7 if a
queen gets to B7 it's uh everything is
gonna die like the whole Queen side will
die wow so we've got to rush to the
dukesh board let's bring our bird's eye
view Levy I'm sorry to interrupt but I
think we might be having a result there
as well as we see it's a night Bond
ending but gkesh on that top right of
your screen is up not only upon but what
upon it is on A5 just marching down the
board let's pull that board up this
might be the California uh unicorns
first video
uh
uh yeah there was also a moment Sabina
actually had a moment to get back into
the game but yeah this is over here
yeah I'm sorry I was just trying to
think of
finger position but
I can still pick up the pawn on B3
Knight F5 he goes yeah it's probably
just this I mean it's the concept like
you cannot stop a h it's just not
possible and five the white king is
still in the Square by the way for the
spawn so Levy nicely pointed out that
you just go for the H Pawn and the H5
Pawn will Queen
uh it's over let's put let's go bird's
eye and then let's uh quickly pop in we
might be seeing the final moments of the
match here as harika dranavali is doing
what a dominant board four should do
use the rating mismatch and her opponent
down to seven seconds and Rook A7 Bishop
C6 should
end it I mean
wow anyway but if a and b get traded
white has to go B5 but
yeah that's that's it I mean she's just
dominating this position now these two
pawns on the king side will decide well
Bishop E5 A5 black can start pushing the
pawn but White's F Pawn is just too fast
Rook f8 Bishop F5 that's it Bishop F5 GG
there it is
and mgd1 she does it but not just how
adiban bhaskaran also wins his game
against Ilia and harika beats Sabina
with that the
mgd1 have taken the match oh my God
nishna got forked
like unbelievable we still have action
on one of the boards Christopher you
still trying to win his game but I don't
think he can do it anymore diptyline out
of trouble because look at that C5 Pawn
he's not losing this he's got a clear
parcel that he can start pushing
what happened he was like minus five it
was over oh now he's winning again what
I I okay apparently he's just winning
yeah I mean
even if he wins yeah it's tough it's
tough um yeah blunder the fork with low
time
that was always going to be a tough game
that game looked never easy and
obviously you're giving away a lot of
Elo on board four which Tanya as I've
said like on the nights we try to avoid
that we always try to be able to fight
harika Costa nuke any monster on board
for Juan June who actually happened to
be Chinese board too so yeah I mean the
better team won
and now he can take on C6 and if you
give a check on D4 you go Queen F6
because you take on B4 A2 is Unstoppable
it cleans it wins the game diptyline
Ghost resigns Christy Christopher you
finally converts a winning position but
it's too little too late Levy for the
California unicorns yeah one of the
benefits of going to a fourth round when
you're up eight fours you can get double
digits very pretty and even though this
round ends exactly like the first round
ends two to two
uh your your overall score is ultimately
uh 10 points for team mgd1 name tpd may
be subject to change in the future and
the California unicorns uh fall
uh to their second defeat in a row I
believe uh and that's they're still not
eliminated
but they've got two more weeks to Stave
off elimination
wow what a match this was as you pointed
out it ends with the same score as we
started the day with but in the middle a
lot of Destruction happened and with
that let's also take a look at the
individual's cause in this match and how
this turns so badly for the California
unicorns and I think the answer their
Levy lies in front of us take a look at
that insane performance by adivan you
want four to zero and I think that's got
a lot to do with his style of play he
just knows how to create a Chaos on the
board and in these speeches formats it's
always the most difficult to be on the
defense to find a resourceful way to
handle imbalanced attacks Arjun did his
bit on the top board and harika super
solid on the fourth board with 50 on the
other side we see California unicorns
they really struggle and I think
Christopher you he's got two out of four
it could have been four out of four for
him it could have been four I definitely
could have been three right like it he
was just totally totally winning against
adibon and look at that I mean ariban
got a present in the first round of this
matchup he was just down basically two
pawns and he got them back and
checkmated his opponent in five moves
and that just propels you if you can
walk through fire then you've got the
heart to uh beat everybody else and win
uh win with four points out of four
that's why he's a fireheart92 on
shells.com drop him a follow uh he does
what the Beast does right he gets four
out of the team's ten points but listen
like
your worst performer had one and a half
I mean when your worst performer has one
and a half you're gonna win the matches
buy a lot that's what's gonna happen uh
and yeah MGD just showed up and uh they
uh they did super super well
eleven was definitely on fire today now
that means team mtd1 moves closer to the
ultimate dream of making it to the
playoffs let's take a look at our week
three standings after this matchup we
see Indian yogis and Gotham Knights have
already punched their tickets into the
playoff meanwhile team MGD one with two
wins and one loss they need one more win
it's three match wins that gets them
into the second stage of the protest
League this is where we stand let's also
take a look at the other teams that
we've got going on and the California
unicorns now one step further from their
qualification one step closer to being
eliminated with one loss and two wins
Charlotte Cobras have been eliminated
already Levy I'm gonna ask you
watch this this was this felt like
destruction
it did feel like destruction yeah uh I
wouldn't I wouldn't be mad uh about that
whole first page qualifying to the
playoffs the only team that's a question
mark to me is the Norway gnomes because
I feel in the bottom of my heart like
the Blitz and the Garden State passers
both have better teams than it's not an
insult to the Gnomes I'm just telling
you as an analyst of the league that's
just what I thought and talk about St
Louis at 0-2 I mean that is that is nuts
but I think what teams have struggled
with is deciding whether to field a giga
stack like California did today with a
weaker board four or a balanced lineup
and in the teams like MGD and levitov
you get a GM on board four who's a woman
in 2550 and you got monster players all
around right and all of the Indian teams
have a strong 24 2500 on board four
seems like balance is the way to go it's
really risky to run three and then uh
one player rated around 2200 uh Tanya
the next match I won't be here for that
that will be James Canty filling in for
me but Berlin is going up against St
Louis and if I'm gonna make a prediction
uh this is the last match Berlin is
going to play I also kind of am
terrified it's not going to be close
because I don't actually know the
lineups but St Louis has like two 2700s
and Nicholas theodoro Tanya
uh I don't know I ain't confident for
the Berlin Bears they might go extinct
first they've got on their top board
Fabiano will he make an appearance today
but St Louis has to also come up with a
strong strong team because they're also
facing elimination one of these two
teams will be out of the protest League
after this match Levy with his hot take
saying it's going to be Berlin Bears
lost last match of the protest League
we're gonna find out with GM Canty
joining us Levy it's been so much fun
calling the action with you and
congratulations once again for the
Gotham Knights making it to playoffs
already you must be a proud captain
super proud super proud of my uh of my
squad uh but uh jokes and all that aside
yeah yesterday was was crazy I did not
expect that we would do so well like one
of the biggest blowouts in PCL in three
rounds uh against Shanghai we have a
great team and we look forward to seeing
who else is going to join us I think
we're going to be second or third seed
in the playoffs so uh uh yeah
let's go it's like the Hunger Games
everybody everybody uh can can come join
us in the playoff bracket we welcome all
challenges we got Magnus we have so many
good players in the protest League Tanya
it's been great uh I hope you have a
good second half of the show uh as we
will see one team stay alive and one
team go home
thank you so much lovey and Brilliant
time doing this with you we will be back
chat don't go anywhere don't leave your
seats because we've got an elimination
match coming right up
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
in competitive chess
the weight of a win draw or loss is all
on one's shoulders it's easy to feel
alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my God the
protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
this might have just been the most
insane PC all around I've ever seen what
the heck did we just witness welcome
back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives the car spent like two and
a half minutes and he beat a guy that I
would probably not beat so it's
unbelievably impressive entering its
Fifth Season 16 teams will reboot the
PCL Legacy with a new format and new
schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion I would go back down
are you kidding me
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
he is both players are holding their
heads this is the most rarest result
I've ever seen
[Music]
welcome back everyone this is the
protest league and the action continues
as we're about to start the second match
of the day we saw a dominating
performance in the first one by the MGD
one and alongside me four the big
elimination match coming up is the
inimitable the one and only GM Academy
what's up girl welcome hello hey Chad
what's up how y'all doing I am here I'm
stepping in for the big boy Levy he got
some big boy work to do so we're gonna
be here today and we got some big
matches it's elimination today oh my
goodness I'm glad they brought me for
the elimination match because these are
my favorite ones done
they are so exciting James I mean
anything can happen here it is literally
a question of life and death for these
two teams because one will be eliminated
now I you got on the action of the MGD
one versus the California unicorns that
was a dominating performance by mgd1
it's pretty scary I mean they are the
Indian I always say it's something in
the water over there because India is
definitely powerhouses with the chest
you ship the water and literally you
just become a GM over there it feels
like you breathe the right air and you
become a GM and that team is definitely
a monstrous team as they took up
unicorns unicorns got three I think
three 2700s maybe four or something like
that but it's a very strong team and
they just got blood out of the water
there from the MDG I mean MGD right so
yeah so I heard you guys talking about
the name earlier it was I was cracking
up oh my goodness the chat was going
crazy I was like yeah it's a it's a beer
I was like wow like but they're showing
you the name it doesn't matter uh
because that chess is all that matters
on the board there
it didn't matter because they had the
game on and there we see the week three
standings it's not the only Indian team
that won there's one that's already in
the playoffs Indian yogis along with
Gotham Knights are the first two
participating team who have made it to
the protest League playoffs and we see
on that table Magnus calls and the world
champion his team Canada chess bras one
match win away from punching their
tickets the Bulldogs are two wins to one
loss now while we've got the winners on
this uh on our screen when you when as
you also got losers let's take a look at
some of the other teams that we've got
Auntie Who currently are struggling now
these are the teams that are one match
away from elimination all the way down
we've got the Saint Louis archbishops
they are the three times champions of
the protest League no one thought they'd
lose one match no one definitely thought
they were going to lose the other and
today they have to win to keep their
chances alive
this is an elimination match right the
Berlin Bears of course will everything's
like yeah they might be going extinct
today I was like oh my goodness the
Bears it's just crazy but then the St
Louis Lewis archbishops right might uh
turn into a pawn today like we don't
know but at the same time of course
somebody's going home and this is the
day where you see like the most
aggressive chest the crazy chess the
rated R chess right the stuff that this
is a this is a family channel type chess
okay this is going to be very very
strong today lots of different choices
through um you know from the lineups all
the way through you know the openings
that they're going to play today
hmm absolutely and I think it's a really
really important for these themes to
really give it up give it their all to
come up with the best possible lineup
because it is their last shot now St
Louis archbishops they've got Fabiano
caruano on the team they've got so many
strong players but the Berlin Bears
cannot be underestimated it is a team
that is dominated by German players
there we see except of course Anton
corabov there at the top we've got the
German number one Matthias blue bomb who
is the current reigning European
Champion now you know
candy I have to say we look at this
roster with all these 2600 2500 so many
Grand Masters all the way down and then
Josephine heinemann and the only female
player to have defeated Hikaru Nakamura
I'm not sure if that's a forever that's
probably not a forever stat but in
online chess defeating a guy like Hikaru
it's no easy task Josephine did it
we're calling them the underdogs in this
match that's a bit strange yeah it is
it's definitely a bit strange of course
if I'm Josephine number one first off I
do have the Hikaru framed like I'm gonna
just have it on me or have a car to say
happy Hikaru at all times right so you
can just flash that that's a good thing
you can do that but at the same time of
course you got to get over that quickly
and we got a match today this is the the
elimination match obviously as you see
how strong these guys are you got core
ball blue bomb who's an absolute monster
but he wasn't doing so well in some of
the protests like weeks so he's looking
to redeem himself he got the Spain
Brothers there Nicholas hutchinvest
really strong as well I mean the team is
really underrated but of course today I
mean they're owing two and they're going
to have to prove themselves they against
the Archbishop
well Navi said it is a potentially their
last day well potentially it is life was
pretty sure it is their last day here at
the protest league and let's take a look
why he feels that way because the roster
of the same Lewis Archbishop oh my God
what is going on there we got Fabiano
caruana leading from the front yeah this
is Chico right here yeah
this is this is crazy stuff we've got
domain guys we've got Jeffrey Zhang
Alice Lee she is she's a super young
super Talent player talented player from
the United States we've got I mean what
is this this is going to be a tough one
and now I see why you and Levy believed
that the Berlin bears are indeed the
underdogs in this one yeah this is a
cheat code here I mean you have two
2700s now of course unicorns did have as
well a few 2700s there too as well but
we have a 2700s here we got some 2625
but everybody knows these names of
course it's Fabiano come on man Mr
calculation himself then you have linear
uh lineae Dominguez they're very strong
Jeffrey Zhang Chef Jeff we like to call
him Benjamin Bach with the microwave
bringing the heat all the time right
Nicholas theodoro is an underrated
player from Greece and nobody you know
uh nobody wants to play him it's not a
good day when you play him at that as
well either right then at the bottom
half done it with the ladies Rochelle
rule very strong Alice Lee Young Phenom
she just scored a norm I think uh very
recently and she's like 12. I think
think maybe 12 years old but you could
be the youngest player on our league I
mean we got we got checked on that stat
but I think that's possible she could be
the youngest player on the protest
League this season wow wow she's uh
definitely he's not Fearless oh she's I
mean she's very Fearless she doesn't
fear these guys to say the least right
Norms he's playing OTB chess as well we
see her a lot doing a lot with chess kid
as well she's a very strong player and
uh the rest of the team looks good as
well so we got matchups coming up and
stuff like that but this is gonna be
scary right Tanya's elimination match
today I'm excited to see what happens
really
I'm speaking of an elimination Marge it
means that the boat that both these
teams have to really put out the best
lineup following the rules for the
lineup as well and these are drum rolls
the board assignments that we've got uh
Canty up for today the Berlin Bears
coming out full guns with the European
Champion Matthias blue bomb they've got
Eric Braun on their team three grand
Masters we see Michael bisold and the
woman board is being led by Sarah Pap
now meanwhile the Saint Louis Louis
archbishops are not holding back they
have come with the front runner one more
time returns for this week Fabiano
caruana along with the Dutch Grandmaster
Benjamin Bach and we're talking about
Alice she makes an appearance with the
nickel with Nicolas theodoro on board
three this is scary that's a scary Squad
I'm not even gonna lie I'm definitely
the Bears have a great chance but the
archbishop's definitely brought all of
the Bishops they could find in this one
I mean this is a very strong team Fabian
I know you got Bach Nicholas theodoro
and Alice who's underrated and then you
know we're in an elimination match where
hey this is all this is all this is it
if you lose we go home right so
everybody has these emotions and the
psychological part too as well I need to
fight for my team here blue bomb is
going to try to redeem himself from the
from some of the bad PCO that he had um
and also Eric Braun I think this is his
first time playing I don't remember
seeing his name there Michael Bizzle
actually played pretty good uh he
actually has some very interesting and
strange positions that I like from him
and Sarah Pap of course is extremely
strong there so we'll see what she does
for the bears but you know it's gonna be
a ShakeOut we'll see what happens any
predictions time
if it's kind of
kind of agree that St Louis Archbishop
team on the right looks so strong but I
will tell you for the Berlin Bears Eric
Braun he is the first
chess boxing oh oh chess boxer of a
Grandmaster level now we've got Ahmad
Hamilton as well after his win over
Lawrence Trend But Eric Braun needs to
box out his way in this match I mean
he's got to get get those skills on oh
yeah he's going to stick and move you
know Bob and weave of the books and then
he'll be ready let's see what happens
there okay well that gives him probably
an extra 50 ELO so that's gonna put him
at like 26 something okay right around
block yeah right around that perfect
they probably even then so we'll see
what happens
wow well it is going to be an
interesting match the Berlin Bears have
a very tough task ahead of them let's
take a look at our round one lineup now
this is the most lopsided round of the
match where the Bold one plays against
odd four and so on and we've got
Matthias blue bomb taking on Alice Lee
while Fabi takes on Sarah back now if
there's an upset on this one if Sarah
can somehow somehow just save the board
against Fabi I mean that would be a huge
bonus that's exactly the kind of start
that Berlin Bears won but it is the
chances of that happening are
very minuscule absolutely they are
minuscule but at the same time it's also
possible as we saw the car will lose the
first game of the PC I mean people still
talk about this right like it's just in
my country hey you know I'm the host to
have a parade you know what I mean I
beat kokaro like that's how it is it was
a huge deal it can happen especially a
lot of times right now with the
psychology part and like that
understanding this is it this is the
last match that we can play so we got to
give it our all here it could be an
upset but also I mean it could also be a
Slaughter as well just gotta find out
and see who is the better team today
well you're absolutely right anything
can happen every board counts every
player counts every contribution counts
because let's remind ourselves of the
match format the team to win the match
has to get to the golden score of eight
and a half points and we say it's up to
four rounds because mathematically and
we've seen teams do this it's possible
to wrap the match up in just three
rounds but eight and a half points gets
you the match win the time control is
the super super demanding 10 minutes
with a two second increment we've spoken
about this how the two second
information means nothing at all there's
barely any time to build on it's an all
playoffs matches the rounds are about to
win are about to start James we can see
the players on the board and I see Alice
there against Matthias Alice looking
confident yeah says it's a mom and Pap
show you can stop right now Mom and Pop
Shop stop it right now near Disney
that's funny commentating not even
commentating us look at them so all
right Alice here Alice is playing
against
blue bomb okay here we go so we have 93
Bishop before let me actually see what
this was again I kind of missed the
first few moves here D4 kc4 Knight C3
Bishop before nav three okay it's easy
stuff so far nothing really nothing
really so this is all right regular
Theory so far Bishop H4 E3 I like our
position oh E3 Bishop D3 right usual
stuff E3 Bishop E3 get the bishop out
Castle Queen C2 is nice some file action
here and cast and queen side Tanya do
you play this so you play eod4 or E4
player what do you play
well you're absolutely right this is a
very very regular position out of the
ragus in and we see this happen often
enough Queen C2 play it now long Castle
is super aggressive but white can also
just think about going E3 next develop
that Bishop to D3 and then Castle
kingside as well uh Matthias going for
the central break with C5 now it looks
like one second what happens after D4
because the Knight on C3 is spin don't
you win a piece but the problem with
that is your idea James becomes a
reality white can go long castle and hey
you pin me I'm gonna pin you watch out
for that Queen my king is out of trouble
I've castled and you end up losing in
fact that D4 Pawn so this is not a
possibility on the board that's why
Alice fearlessly picks up the C5 Pawn
Alice actually I mean look how much time
she I mean talk about booster confidence
in there like see even if you see on
your camera does she looks comfortable
calm playing is actually how she plays
chess in fact like all the time she's
literally very Fearless she doesn't show
any sign of weakness in her game in her
body language at all so he's a very
strong player and very very scary as a
young player she's only in getting
better here so play dc5 very quickly
blue bomb with Bishop E6 defending the
pawn here maybe we just go with a simple
E3 Rook to D1 or an A3 we have to get
our pieces off the back Rank and figure
out what we're gonna do with the King
passing Queen's side now seems a little
bit more risky because the C file is now
open you have to play King B1 to finish
the castle but in this case E3 Bishop D3
seems a totally normal in Castle and
play against the isolated Pawn on D5 I
think that's pretty good
really nicely pointed out as you're
mentioning all the subtleties about this
position you want to long term play
against that D5 Pawn we'll see how this
develops will Alice with the white
pieces this is her toughest round
against the top Board of the Berlin
Bears will she manage to hold her own
but we've got action on the other boards
as well James let's see if you can bring
up a bird's eye view and do a quick
opening tour of what is happening on the
other boards and I see on our top right
our chess boxer Grandmaster taking on
Nicholas theodoro The Grandmaster from
Greece here playing for the St Louis
archbishops that's an interesting
opening with the central pawns having
been traded off we could jump into that
and take a look how we got here
definitely this is actually a specialty
of mine I think I'm Drew uh who is it
John philodoris back in the day with
this opening this is a C3 Sicilian but
it's a delayed C3 it's like delayed
right because he went E4 C5 and then
Knight F3 indicating gonna play a
regular one and then D4 right is the
usual move but you can play C3 to try to
throw them all you can also do C3 and
then E4 later or C3 Knight F3 and it
transposes into what we have actually
right here which is just a delayed
allopant but also if you look at it
through chesscom it's going to say this
was an elephant Sicilian by
transposition after D4 and then Bishop
to E3 Knight takes um an A6 Knight D2
this is all standard stuff you also can
sometimes put the Knight on A3 but the
bishop is uh gonna take it here so clean
ideas that I remember Knight F3 is a
move Bishop D3 castling you actually
sometimes can even get nasty King side
attacks in what they call a slow opening
here in evolve bar just move there Tanya
you see that jump after E5
because if I IFA is not the common move
it's not the common reply for black this
is definitely some kind of a devious
preparation by Eric there usually
blotches develops the bishop instead E5
hitting that Knight he falls back to F3
another question is that at E5 Pawn can
potentially be a weakness very often
James the point is that you want that
pawn on E6 because white is going to put
his Bishop on C4 when that Bishop is on
C4 you don't want that Target on F7 so
the E6 Pawn is used to blunt that Bishop
out once you've committed E5 it does
have that ambitious nature but you're
also creating weakness in your cam now
Bishop C4 will be so much more powerful
imagine Bishop C4 Knight G5 I'm coming
for you I think that's I mean that's
that's it Tanya in fact absolutely the
fact his senses are tingling right here
and I'm a big fan of uh of uh they say
the tempo right so you want to have the
tempo available Bishop to C4 hits the
queen in the Knight to G5 so as many
Tempo or Tempe as you can make in a row
lots of times you get very good
positions Bishop C4 hits the queen he's
going to go back to E6 maybe or d8 maybe
back uh to the house actually quickly
Ace blundering you need to keep Knight
d8 available that's why the knights on
C6 believe it or not after Knight to G5
we can play obviously F7 hit on F7 so
you're gonna have to defend it by Bishop
E6 which is absolute really gross
discussing get it off the board right
and let's actually put this on the board
96 Knight G5 Bishop E6 it's pretty
disgusting here takes takes and we can
even play a move like Queen to B3 right
now hitting B7 and E6 at the same time
this is not fun at all he's gone Queen
D7 he went Queen D7 okay let me refresh
so we're going Queen to D7 here and that
was such a great point that you made oh
thank you it was a great point but after
Knight G5 he wants to put that Knight on
D6 so it looks unnatural like he's
blocking his own Bishop but Bishop E6
was not even a defense because that was
an ugly trade on E6 for black it's
disgusting not after Knight to G5
there's Knights d8 and maybe queen of B3
how do you like I'm just gonna keep
hitting you I'm just gonna keep hitting
you until you do something about it this
is pretty Tangled here Knight G5 there
it is
it's on the board you're calling it out
and 98 only moves to Define F7 and this
is why that move E5 was asking for
trouble in the opening and I'm just
really surprised that Eric went for it
there's a part of me that's asking
what's this a potential Mouse slab
instead of but how could it be but you
know you also don't put your point on E5
and end up in this position Knight d8
you're pointing out some great ideas
here Queen B3 white can also just play
Slowly you know shot Castle put your
Rook on E1 James not only is F7 weak the
E5 Pawn is weak as well and it looks
like Nicolas theodoro is super happy
with his position out of the opening and
I think it's a good time for us to see
who else is happy with that position out
of the opening let's get the bird's eye
view let's see what we got
see what we got looks like all games are
alive
all games are alive indeed action has
kicked off on all our boards bottom
right Sarah against Fabiano caruana Fabi
as well that with the queen and the
Santa the bishop is at he is hinting at
a potential inside castling on that
bottom right board he's also hinting at
developing his Bishop fan shattering it
I think he's happy with this imbalanced
position imbalanced Pawn structure out
of the opening meanwhile James take a
look at that bottom left board what on
Earth is going on there with Benjamin
against Michael beasold 94 D6 week do
you want to jump into that oh definitely
absolutely and uh Michael bezold he
always plays strange things anyway let's
take a look and see how we got to this
position here play E4 okay Knight F3 all
oh yeah Bishop B5 yeah okay he's one of
those guys and I'm a night Earth player
myself and you play Bishop B5 check and
I'm automatically annoyed by you you
know so I spent a lot of time looking at
this the last few days but Bishop one of
the most annoying ones so he takes okay
cool yeah they have all of it
specifically for D3 standard stuff
develop your pieces the night goes
around something and the Roy Lopez
fashion over to G3 then we go to G6 A4
was played Knight F6 develop your pieces
E5 that's aggressive I do like this from
bezo knight uh three five there's Knight
D5 and then Knight E4 and this is the
live position honestly bizode has a nice
attacking like position but he doesn't
have the right piece and he's missing a
high Square basically here and then this
would be uh probably slightly better for
white here but so far I think probably
equal
start for that E5 Square the Knight
jumps in immediately takes control of
that also attacking the bishop on G6
ideas of Knight C4 Pawn moving to A5 to
block down that Queen side really clamp
down on the queen side coming up so even
though it's not clearly apparent why
white is better but one gets the feeling
that it's definitely more pleasant and
Michael does it he's gone with the idea
of A5 at C4 is a juicy Outpost as you're
pointing out B6 is a forever weakness
is really weak you also have to figure
out what do we want to do with this
piece as well you want to have some type
of idea of what you want to do with
pieces now aggressive style is Rook A4
over to G4 I love these type of work
lifts myself do you even Rook lift or
not okay definitely a huge Rook lift
here Rook A4 to G4 or even H4 to SAC you
also have Queen G4 as an idea took the
queen on G3 but he says Tempo first kick
him away Knight to C4 is probably going
to move
template quick
well it was screaming to be played
anywhere and now Benji Benji as he's
known forces white to fall back to C4
Queen C6 is a nice spot always watch out
for that square on F4 for the Black
Knight F4 putting pressure on G2 so
important for the bishop and C1 that
it's controlling it he goes Queen G4 you
were asking what is the dark spot Bishop
doing it has a devious idea I'm picking
up your 86 pawn and you're putting
pressure on E6 oh there is some problems
here E6 and H6 are hanging at the same
time don't tell me King F7 is the move
here if you gotta play King F7 there is
a problem so you play Bishop F5 so he
gets a bit of one and then I'm gonna get
rid of the other so he doesn't go with
the wild king F7 which he would get out
of it he just goes with the simple
Bishop F5 again the tempo right Master
the tempo so Bishop F5 hits the queen
Temple I gain that Tempo to gain time
and the King can move to H7 or h8 now
and we don't have to deal with the
bishop H6 any longer I think yeah pretty
stable for Bach here pieces are
developed white probably has a slight
Edge small Edge because of the E6
weakness
hmm Queen G3 like you're pointing out
the Kink inside step there is a
long-term weakness on E6 this one is
going to be an interesting middle game
fight while the players have a thinking
it's having your move as you called out
is on the board sidestepping defending
against Bishop 86 Michael continues with
development Bishop D2 connecting the
Rooks taking more control of A5 let's
bring up a bird's eye view because there
is some hot action on the other boards
and take a look on that top left screen
top left board on your screen Alice Lee
looks like she's doing really well in
that position her Queens out on the G
file meanwhile on the top right board
the top Board of the Saint Louis
Archbishop Fabiano caruana against Sarah
pop it looks like fabi's got things
under control with the black pieces we
see his Knight has jumped to the center
of the board currently attacking the
bishop Sarah falls back with it and I
have to say James the most interesting
one which catches my attention and I
know it catches yours because you love
these kind of positions the top right
Eric against Nicholas that king is not
going anywhere black has just made the
move Rook to f8 we've got to jump into
that yeah we gotta jump in that game
right there so in 13 moves here in 13
moves okay in 13 moves we have a plus
5.6 says the engine now the engine says
that you're down a roof and half of a
pawn and you got both your Rooks there
are both Rooks on the board that's a
problem
that is a problem that I don't see a
solution to and you know exactly what
you're saying right the material is
completely balanced but the position is
so horrendous from black that the engine
the evaluation bar it's giving an
advantage of almost being an entire Rook
up that's also understandable because
take a look at the position oh my God it
is absolutely ugly here the white truck
can jump to D1 pinning that Bishop on D6
black makes the move eight six all right
some questions here your knight is
attacked you don't have the best Square
are you gonna pick up the D at night and
then pick up the pawn on F7 yeah so
Queen side I was thinking the same thing
of course sack first thing later like
grandfather Tao says after you Castle
put this Rook on D1 and he's done Knight
takes E5 we live Rook E1 he's done get
him off the board this is over you bring
your Rook to E1 you can take on E5 I
mean what what else you want here Tanya
what else do you want this is everything
you want in a position especially from
an attacking player standpoint hassling
you don't care nothing about that night
have a good night night it's game over
here this is a wrap
I love that I love that and you know I
have to say you're absolutely right Sac
first think later he sucks at night then
he sucks a rook what is going on this is
this is too much oh my goodness oh man
just gets off the screen bro just hit
the button bro just hit the button oh my
God this is going to be this is going to
be Nicholas's Immortal I mean what is
happening here he sacrifices well the
queen could not have moved James if we
can just show that with the queen not
having any Square because the d8 Knight
was hanging black in fact let's say you
go Queen E7 and white just picks up on
d8 and that is game over with Knight E5
also coming in every Queen B4 is
Checkmate as you oh I've been before Oh
my God you're pointing it out and that
is uh the finish of all finishes so what
black in fact had to give up his own
Queen now if you look at the current
position as we see that there's a
material imbalance where let's just come
up to date with that where black in fact
has got enough material for the queen
you've got two Rooks for a queen minor
pieces three to each but the problem is
there's no development black skating is
super weak white snide is going to jump
to G5 the queen has got enough time to
even fall back to B3 your idea James and
pick up that F7 pawn and you know your
two Rooks they're never going to see the
light of day yeah this is so bad I mean
this is if this was the positions you
get out of the elephant sister and I
might go back to playing that all the
time which is crazy like wow that was
sick Queen D6 Bishop C5 is on tap here
as well like the queen goes into D6 the
dark squares are weak you are you're two
pieces down here your King's in the
center of the board when I go Bishop C5
I'm threatening to go obviously the f8
that's with Tempo then I can play Knight
takes E5 as well and then take it there
it is Queen T6 he understands I
understand you Nico I understand you big
fella Queen D6 Bishop C5 and you just
take on E5 what do you do you can't move
anything it's over you really do get him
this is unbelievable but this is not the
only unbelievable stuff happening let's
quickly jump to our bird's eye view what
is Alice Lee doing she's all of 12 years
old she is taking down matia's blue bomb
look at that top left James cannot sit
on his seat we're all on the edge of our
seats what is happening here James first
off let me try this blue bomb face first
off I gotta see what the emotions are
right here so he is in the zone but look
at look at Alice Lee I told you about
this she's fearless like literally same
face I don't care who I'm playing I'm
playing the pieces the board not the
person right so she's doing exactly what
she came to do here I mean how do we
even get here she crushing right now
what happened last year oh my God
so what happened here
she looks completely calm and composed
you were talking about checking out
expressions Alice Lee there is gold on
the on the screen she knows she has a
bishop F6 threatening that mate the only
move that black had was to push the pawn
Alice he doesn't care about that Knight
on F3 what a move James Queen G7 was a
massive threat and if we just back up
and go to our current position Queen H3
she's saying take my knight if you can I
don't care because I'm coming after your
king she believes in calculation over
everything she's gone for it Queen no
way to fight Queen G7 mate you don't
have rookie seven you don't have Rook C7
you've got no move you have Matthias
blue bomb is busted
crush on National Television in front of
everybody by Alice Lee and I understand
look hey she's a Fearless monster here
of definitely super underrated second a
whole night have a good night right it's
not a good night for Matthias right here
Queen takes H6 like what do you even do
here okay let's just give it one that's
a great question I don't know you can
put Queen F5 trying offer Queen trades
because you need to get your queen to
the defense and that might even be the
only move because after Queen A6 you
need to bring your queen to defend that
mid but then you end up with being a
million pawns down yeah you just lose
all the pawns yeah that's actually yeah
that's probably the best yeah there's
nothing else Queen F5 we have to click
on H6 threaten h8 and G7 so you bring
the queen to G6 or actually G6 or H7
right then we trade we take on G5 then
E4 is hanging yo Bishop about the game I
mean it's just a clean end game clean
stuff from Alice here Matthias under a
minute this is
and we're talking about a game where
Alice is 400 points rated 400 points
less than matia's blue bomb this is
right now oh my not right now James
Queen F5 on the board she's gonna pick
up the 8-6 pawn the entire King side is
going to fall oh my goodness what on
Earth is happening Queen G5 coming in
with the check
yeah yeah that's even better yeah I was
just saying Trey but now you don't have
to trade here you don't have to trade at
all Queen G5 and then just move the
Knight Queen G5 and we live it's a
beautiful move yeah you just take it off
we take sexy as a blunder because of
Knight H7 so Queen G5 yep Queen G6 and
now what
oh God and we were talking about
checking out Expressions at that time we
couldn't really make out but you can
clearly see it on Matias now we need
that body language read from you James
yeah again body language we hear you
know Matthias actually he is he's uh
disappointed he's like uh I can't
believe I got here yeah now he's taking
his head you see the eyebrows yeah now
is the now the emotions now he's letting
them out yeah yeah I understand
obviously it's just like it's another
day in the office I mean you can tell
she is not faced at all she didn't even
blink Alice blink if you and if you
flick twice if you're in trouble right
like hey man she just did not care like
and played an excellent game here and
she's she's gonna clean this one up she
trade she takes the pawn and into a
clean in-game completely winning
um James we were talking about Alice
being two bonds up she's gonna win the
third Bond as well because how are you
defending the E4 Pawn oh you don't Tanya
you are 100 correct exactly I'll take
that too thanks for the gumdrops and the
generosity have a good day Knight takes
E4 for the score getting him off the
board and the fourth board is gonna
strike oh my goodness that's what you
need especially in the games but you can
set the tone in the first match but you
definitely need yeah you definitely need
to have you know when you get that
fourth board taking out a few of his hot
dogs not only is that confidence but
it's huge on the scoreboard
unbelievable as Watchers candy
candy
oh my goodness right all the Coes well
for mine in the chat right now my
goodness she's just going crazy wow
great game she's you know the most
important thing in these situations when
you're playing a player who's 400 points
higher rated than you is to believe when
you have a winning position that you can
convert it then I look at Alice on the
screen I mean like you said she hasn't
blink she's cool as a cucumber as it's
been pointing out she looks completely
in control meanwhile Mathias down to
seconds but James when you're playing
against these Grand Masters they're
going to do everything to make it tough
for you big question will Alice convert
this into a full point is she going to
convert this one I mean with her eyes
closed she could put it in blindfold
give her an extra five minutes tell her
where the pieces at she'll do a
blindfold right so I mean this is a this
is a clean one very easy I got two
minutes on the clock for yo eight
seconds what is this what is that I mean
a lot of times you're you're scared are
you like oh man like how do I win this
in-game I'm up three pawns like I don't
know what to do I'm playing a GM and I
don't she's just gonna play G4 come on
you're just taking that F5 Square from
the King that was insane technique look
she keep the Debbie on him what's the
Debbie that's the devil rescue in gay
manual that's in chapter of four okay
chapter three of the four pawning games
they have on uh pawning games in there
ridiculous that's page 387. G4 right
here that was a beautiful wow
resignation resignation oh my goodness
protest league and Alice Lee that we see
her keeping her smile under control but
she knows she's done it for the team the
Saint Louis archbishops we call them the
favorite but it was not because of Alice
but she's proved us all wrong on the
four fourth board what a result for this
12 year old James I cannot believe what
we just witnessed I believe it Alice
just took that man to Wonderland it was
definitely some crazy oh my goodness
that was amazing performance from
Alistair and once you have that a lot of
times what you get is the confidence you
get a huge confidence boost like that's
your board one is that all you got right
well wait till you know let me play to
other players and see what happens right
and I think she's definitely in the in
the zone right now excellent job there
for Allison oh my God I'm still reeling
from what we just saw what a Flawless
game by her it's not just winning the
point but the style in which she did it
crushing King side attack picking up all
those pawns one after the other trading
off all the pieces and then come and
game she proves that she's got the
technique that's required she does the
job for the Saint Louis archbishops and
now it looks like Nicholas theodoru is
also going to do his job he's been
winning from the opening look at that
picks up the Rook with a check and
probably they might be oh yeah and then
98 right 98 and then Queen H4 yeah now
you have to take everything up all the
rookies oh my goodness my guy hit the
button yeah there's a resigns coming up
and there it is he just resigns
yeah I just came over Chichi and man
archbishop's he that's that's amazing
James on fire
two and a half raw with Bach yeah that's
it I don't have two and a half that's
three and a half that's three wins
is destruction it looks like Benjamin
box the one who only conceded half a
point to Michael Bizzle all the other
three boards Nicholas Fabiano winning
that games but of course the star of the
round is Alice Lee wow I mean absolutely
she definitely played some excellent
chess there you need that again on your
board four if your board four can take
out the board one what I mean how do you
feel right there right it's tough for
that team I mean that team right now
being the Berlin Bears and the Saint
Louis archbishops are feeling you know
euphoric right now they can under no it
has three and a half let's go but of
course the round it's not over we have
seen crazy comebacks but right now shoot
St Louis archbishops are having
commanding lead they come in this whole
match right now wow we have this kind of
excitement when we saw Josephine
heinemann taking down hikaranakamura
this is another Monumental day in chess
and definitely in Alice Lee's career as
well she defeats a grand master who's
rated 400 points above her in a
convincing crushing style I still can't
believe what we just saw it's been an
amazing amazing round one chat you don't
want to go anywhere because round two is
just coming up
thank you
struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki and
Josh Toth everyone's favorite social
media troll known as Anish Geary and so
many more chessable can help you raise
your game to the next level most
importantly all of our courses are
powered by chessable's exclusive move
trainer technology which uses the
science of space repetition to make sure
it all sticks
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
all right
[Music]
thank you
it's the result that we're all talking
about Alice Lee is the Superstar for the
St Louis archbishops the 13 year old in
woman International master from the
United States took down the first Board
of the Berlin Bears Grandmaster Matthias
a blue bomb what a game that was James I
am still getting over what we just
witnessed it was absolute destruction
there and if you see that I mean
honestly that's scary okay that's scary
when you see that you like whoa that was
Lee beat the top dude then like you know
the second board third board like shoe
well maybe I should you start thinking
you're in their head a little bit that's
huge that's a huge thing from Alice what
she did there putting the St Louis
archbishops on a map like that they have
another round like that this match will
be over by round three in St Louis
archbishop's favorite
Saint Louis archbishops need all the
help that they can get they have not
really lived up to the expectations so
far this season of the protestly because
the expectations are just so high from
them James they have been three times
Champion take a look at this in 2017
2018 2020 it was the St Louis Archbishop
team that took the championship in 2018
it was the Armenia Eagles and it looks
done it looks like Alice Lee is going to
be the one who's going to be keeping
that Legacy going what a round we've had
run to is about to start James what are
you expecting I mean the Berlin Bears
have to be super shaken up by that
absolutely damage control they like
three and a half half whoa we getting we
know we're getting hit right now if we
don't bounce back right now this could
literally I mean everything could go out
the window you know the morale of the
team goes down you don't play you're not
seeing a lot you just see blunders that
are uncharacteristic from players once
they just kind of give up right so this
one is the round where they really they
can bounce back what if they win on
three boards if you win on three boards
cool we're doing good we're in a tie
match here maybe draw one draw we have
four and four we have ourselves a real
match here but right now it's definitely
Saints St Louis Art's business favorite
bears are gonna have to you know use
some of that bare bite right now and see
if they're able to bite into this
impenetry to roll uh you know St Louis
Archbishop medal they got going on on
them Bishops they're playing really good
today
gonna ask where on Earth do they bite as
well because take a look at that they've
got Fabi Benjamin Nicholas and an
absolutely on fire Alice Lee here
playing and this is the round that's
coming up with Matias taking on Nicholas
Eric Brown taking on Alice Lee these all
will play against Fabi Sarah against
Benjamin now you know a lot of teams
James have got the top players the top
one of the top 10 players Heavy Hitters
of the Chess World as that board won and
some of them have made it to the hall of
fame with a four out of four performance
for that team we've seen Magnus do it
we've seen Sam Savion do it Hikaru Fabi
is yet to do that you think it's
important for him today to get that 100
win or do you think Alice Lee has this
that's a great question actually I think
Alice Lee is I mean she if she had F
here let's play like that she could go
4-0 three and a half she could not lose
today she could not lose in the next BCL
oh she that's Fearless that was probably
I mean that was literally the best thing
that happened today
um
says besides the Hikaru one in the first
game he covered played of his BCL match
right when he lost down that's just as
big as the Alice Lee Crush there Fabiano
definitely needs to I think step it up a
little bit here and just get his four
right get your four five right he wants
to get that four everybody else doing it
I'm 27.60 here right you know so he got
a beefy rating so he probably wants to
use some of that too as well on the
other side bear the blue bomb needs to
bounce back I got white I need to take
down Nicholas theodoro here and I could
use the white pieces to our advantage
here so he doesn't look too rattled
there but definitely knows look I messed
that up I can't believe I lost that game
but I have to short-term memory loss and
go into this next round ready to fight
you say he doesn't look rattled that
might be on the outside on the inside
blue bomb is feeling the pain James I
mean that loss is going to haunt him for
a long long time he does need to set
that aside he needs to start getting the
dubs in the players are ready to go
Michael bluebonn the big question can he
bounce back after that disastrous
thought that he had in the previous
round he starts with the Queen's Pawn
opening it is a nimso Indian James okay
A Little nimso India actually yeah this
is a classical opening that you've seen
literally in all histories of Chess very
solid flexible opening with lots of
dynamicism it could be uh very
aggressive sometimes but it could also
be very positional so yeah both ways you
could have played D5 or C5 there
Nicholas Theodore shows the C5 option
which is a little bit more tactical here
a lot of times you take on D4 and then
you might play uh eventually a D5 and
you put the bishop maybe back on D6 or
you're on f8 in many cases here so I
mean it's very standard so far
wow and Nicholas going for the center
with a
attack with the four point
four pound white to call a hand in
Matthias decides to pick up the D5 Pawn
C takes D5 and now black has got some
pleasant choices you very often don't
want to take with the Knight because
that allows white to go E4 and have a
full central control so that is not
advisable but on the other hand Nicholas
could either pick that pawn up with his
e-pawn or in turn pick up the D4 Pawn as
well C takes D4 James which one do you
like more do you want him to go for ed5
and keep these thematic positions of
nimso Indian or do you want to see some
craziness with C takes D4 I definitely
want to see some C takes D4 here C takes
D4 is crazy I'm always with that I love
crazy of course he plays D5 have an A3
and it's not going to be too crazy here
but I would like one of those Bishops I
appreciate that I am a fan of Bishops
overnights myself I am very Naomi I just
like Joe Baba London's and Bishop
openings where you you know you do lots
of things with the bishop they are very
strong pieces obviously the knights are
very tricky but I'm a big fan of the
bishop there so if I can get that A3
Bishop takes C3 here maybe take back
with a knight I mean I even like taking
what's up on here just to imbalance it
even further and the castle and have
options are playing E4 and C4 Pawn
breaks whoever controls Pawn breaks
controls the game and I can eventually
play E4 or C4 whenever I want to A4 put
the bishop on A3 even Bishop to B2 and
use this as well lots of things to do so
he goes with a c D4 I'm going to take
the bishop
because I like taking the Bishops but
let's see what he plays what would you
do you want them Bishop then Nicholas
will go on to take that Knight which can
be recaptured the pawn then will uh be
picked up with a beep on as well after d
takes h3b
it's gonna be a fun middle game while
this one's going to become fun in a few
moves I see there's some fun on on the
other boards already and the one that
catches my attention once again if we
bring up the bird's eye view is James on
that top right corner some strange pawn
moves I see by white there G3 F3 E3 and
a knight on H4 now that's not something
that you see every day and white is
still behind in development meanwhile on
the bottom left Fabiano caruana it looks
like a sicilian and everything under
control but it looks like it's the top
right board which is a little out of
hand and I think we should Deep dive
into that let's get into it that is the
Alice Lee game here
Perfect all right
um our points
yes honestly okay so how do we get here
let's first see how did we even get to
this position with C4 okay C6
four so just uh yeah natural development
good stuff okay Knight H4
easy
F3
oh and G3 it should be two he just puts
all these pawns up right here I like he
has the flexibility but definitely
strange
thinking how to currently respond in
this position you want these ideas of
taking in the center D takes C4
advancing your Pawn your E Pawn up the
board after DC4 Bishop C4 E5 but of
course first you want to get your king
into into safety uh this will develop in
this way James I'm expecting her to
capture that pawn and then Advance her
own Central Bond she has to decide
whether she pushes E5 or C5
that's correct let's actually take a
look at that pawn takes Bishop takes
okay uh well it's Quest whites move
because she did go faster so white needs
to yes Knight G6 makes a lot of sense
that's what he did he captured caption
now we have to figure out what to do now
the week of cd5 maybe I'll go E4 Catalan
style here E4 strong yes E5 though E5
doesn't see take take but I could go D5
E4 CD Bishop C4 E5 D5 yeah yeah that's
that's fine that's fine E4 sorry uh E5
and then uh after uh Bishop C4 E5 and
then D5 here so this Pawn is very strong
I mean this bishop not the greatest of
course you have to put down the dark
squares here but I go King H1
James but unfortunately for her your
idea of E4 would be great because it
also threatens E5 and she would not have
time to take on C4 because maybe white
can push with E5
but F4 this is a different way to play
and I like that yeah let's just show
that that this would have E5 coming in
so things would get very tricky for
black in this one but instead Eric
decides another way to go he does the
chess boxing but he goes F4 so he keeps
all the pawns on the dark squares
blocking that Bishop on D6
definitely blocks the bishop on D6 you
would like to get to Knight to E5 but
the Knight is on the other side of the
board my guy you have to get it over
here to F3 go to E5 it's also
controlling okay E4 here I mean playing
for an advantage here is gonna be very
slow very slow for black I mean for
white here the YP this bishop is pretty
gross you want to get it outside the
pawn chain a lot of times you can do it
this way Bishop E1 Bishop D2 to E1
playing H3 G4 and going all the way to
H4 this is a long way and I love this
move by Alice here with Bishop B4
highlighting the fact that this square
is extremely weak you played F4 pawns
don't go backwards and this square is
very very weak I can really bully the
square put the Nano E4 reinforce it with
F5 and Knight F6 I can kind of you know
play whatever I want here I even have G5
as a break at some point this bishop on
C1 is absolutely terrible
wow so it looks like out of the opening
with the black pieces Alice is again
holding her own against GM Eric Brown
and that is uh pretty impressive but I
have to say it doesn't even matter how
the rest of the day goes Alice has done
her bit for the Saint Louis Archbishop
but looking at the opening outcome of
this one it looks like there is going to
be no stopping her let's get the bird's
eye view up and take a look at some of
the other boards because the Berlin
Bears really need to find their chances
I look at the top left and it does look
like Matthias blue bomb has things under
control in this one look at those two
double pawns on the B5 it means that the
a file is open there's a strong weakness
in the center on the D file and that
gives white a lot of edge meanwhile
Benjamin Bach on the bottom right there
James looking good with the white pieces
well yeah definitely looking good let's
say can you take a look at box game and
see what's going on with the bach from
the archbishops this looks like a
Catalan I know he likes Catalan type
positions to see how we got there it was
Knight F3 C4 so sort of a ready-like but
Catalan
neocatalin by transposition D3 sort of
like a reverse benoni type position
that's exactly how he's playing it here
and of course B4 yes B4 could be
captured but the problem is E5 is the he
has a great position here I mean this is
a reverse benoni you have the yeah it
plays B5 yeah he's a he's he's in
control he's definitely in control here
B5 hitting usually a benoni right you
want to get the B5 but she in he already
got it in and he and he has B4 if you're
looking at it from Black's point of view
B5 B4 right and you need the Rook to the
B file but I mean this is great for
white already I think E5 has some
pressure here we obviously have G4 E5
can hang in many cases and this could be
loose as well so I mean I think uh he
has a very good position so far
wow so it looks like St Louis Archbishop
have it under control in this one and
now after that three and a half half win
in round one we were all trying to
understand what happened this has been
an amazing start for the team where is
the captain and it looks like who we
were looking for we were trying to find
Nemo and we have in fact found Nemo as
she does join us James she's here with
us Nemo welcome to the show
thank you so much Tanya I really
appreciate it and hello I'm going to ask
you how impressed how impressed were you
with what happened in round one Alice
Lee blowing our minds
honestly I am incredibly impressed right
now because
we haven't had exactly the best start to
the season we have unfortunately lost
our first two matches
uh you know Alice Lee had a very rough
first round
um she first match she she actually lost
I think all four of her games even
though she had some really good chances
so it it was a little rough but I mean
Alice just played so well against
blue bomb last round I I don't even know
how she did it but she spotted the
tactics she spotted the way to attack
the black king and she just went for it
and she won so it was wonderful to see
it's very aggressive very good chest
there she's swinging well above her
class right now if she keep doing that
the rest of these rounds Nemo it's gonna
be a great day in St Louis for you guys
anyway that's great
sorry go ahead how are you going no no
go ahead sorry I was just gonna say it's
three and a half to uh zero and a half
which hasn't happened yet so far so I'm
like I don't want to jinx anything I'm
just like this is looking good this is
going well
it really is and it looks like even the
board that we have in front of us Nemo
that Benjamin is doing well here but to
me James Nemo it looks like a very messy
position I mean not the center Benjamin
picks up the pawn what do you make of
this what's going on here anymore
honestly I I really like these kind of
complicated a lot of um you know a lot
of tactical positions because I think
Benjamin with his rating Advantage it
does it does indicate that you might
have a little
a little more experience so I think he's
got a good grasp of what's happening I
think he he understands that after you
know for example Bishop takes E5 Rook
takes E5
Knight takes D3 He he's got he's got
chances to take back on the D4 Pawn at
some point he just move his Rook away
there's there's a lot of things
happening in this position but
um
if everything swaps off it does at the
very end of the day it can become a very
Josh end game so I don't think there's
too much for Benjamin to worry about at
the current moment foreign
Bishop too on G2 as well it's pretty
pretty common to have these you know
strategically complex positions that you
have if you see Magnus play this type of
stuff all the time of course with the
bishop on G2 even game six of the World
Championship win 100 and something moves
right and he it was it was one of these
openings right it was very slow and
professional but this one's more
tactical so I actually you know this
favors us like anymore we like tags you
know we are so taxes are strong here
Bishop G2 is a thing I mean also uh
Knight B4 if Bishop takes E5 you have
options you have lots of options here
you also have H4 H5 as some case because
the was kind of loose it's a very
crazy position so I do like box chances
here but you know I think it's anybody's
game
absolutely
yeah I would agree with that this is a
messy messy middle game uh and Nemo I
have to ask you this because we've been
talking so much now you're the captain
of a team that has won the protest
league three times but so far well until
the last round it hasn't been smooth
sailing for you guys you are on O2 right
now you haven't had a match win
what happened what has not been working
for the team so far and did you do the
pep talk today before this very
important match
honestly I think what hasn't been
working doesn't necessarily have to do
with the archbishops I think it has more
to do with the fact that you know Magnus
Carlson is playing we've got Joe and Jin
on the female team we've got I believe
it was harika jonavali
um the previous week that we played
against I mean these are some just
really really strong chess players and I
I wanted to pay uh special attention to
the female players actually because you
know Alice Lee is a very very strong
female player she's also only 13 and
um as a 13 year old she doesn't quite
have the same experience as for example
Jun or harika who are both 2500 Grand
Masters who have been playing you know
for basically as long as she's been
alive so we've got a little little rough
matchups over there we have a lot of
very strong female players that are
quite Young on the team and they just
had a rough last two matches but this
time it looks like Alice is just really
really stepping it up and I just love to
see it I just really love to see it so
you know I think the team is just
picking up steam now
it's a great way to put a picking up
steam is it especially if it's coming
out like that after having to two you
know just two bad matches it happens
playing these strong players and then
today three and a half a half yo that's
that's crushing okay it's very scary and
trying to come back from that is like
astronomically you know sometimes
impossible but it's not it is possible
but it definitely it don't jinx us James
okay you're right you know what you're
right James James come on stops just
quiet okay you're right you're right
this is a commentators curse is a thing
so
good shots
it's it's so true that it's just been
two matches but definitely it looks like
a new Fresh theme Here Today by the St
Louis archbishops and let's bring up a
bird's eye view and I want to get your
thoughts on Alice's board we've been
talking about her chat's been going
crazy about her uh and I see her
position she's with the black pieces
right now it does look like Eric Braun
has taken control of the center what do
you what do you make of this end game
honestly I think Alice's end game uh
position is just a little worse her
pronoun does have the pair of Bishops
every chess player knows you love your
pair Bishops you would rather have them
over Paradise as long as the position is
you know a little bit open so it's
definitely better for white and of
course Black's Pawn structure is also
weakened
just a very very difficult end game to
hold I mean the principle of two
weaknesses tells us that white has you
know a pair of Bishops as their
advantage and then also potentially the
C Pawn the C4 Pawn as a pawn to attack
so it's going to be a little difficult
for her to defend so we'll see if she's
able to just potentially hold this
together
yeah it's kind of tough when being a
strong player lots of things actually uh
is is you have to learn how to defend a
very tough positions in fact that's what
this is it's just it is just worse so if
we had a bishop it would probably be
like okay it's not that bad but here it
is pretty rough with the Knights here we
just got to make some Maneuvers here
it's just worse I could just hate
playing his positions because you know
you're worse and like every move is like
I don't know if this is right maybe you
make a move like F5 here try to carve
the square or D5 but I mean how do you
even save this Pawn I think I don't
think right
I think playing for
a draw when you know that your best
result is a draw is very painful that
has to be some of my least favorite
types of Chess to play right
wow but honestly they're just moving
forward with her Knights puts it to B5 I
like that move it attacks C3 but it also
means that you're potentially allowing a
take on C4 right could take the Knight
on B6 8X B6 Bishop C4 it is a
possibility I think she's gonna Rook a
three there uh and let's actually take a
look at that takes takes and then just
say hey this end game is like you know
try to win this in-game right you know
after Bishop takes and then Bishop takes
B5 and takes like this is like you know
or even Knight to D6 after Bishop to C5
uh sorry not Bishop C5 Bishop takes C4
Knight to D6
oh here here oh yeah this is beautiful
Knight D6 even better and then Bishop D3
yeah and then we hit our A2 here this is
nasty yes this is sweet she's finding
some tactics in there that girl Coe boys
you can calculating I love it
calculating Alice who we
yeah she's she's on point today she's
got her tactics down
yeah
I better be doing Titans right now
we love it calculation over everything
and it looks like Alice really has been
watching candy and following that advice
Nemo thank you so much for joining us
and we wish you all the best what a
start by the St Louis Archbishop and
enjoy the rest of the games
thank you you guys too take care
oh all right so there we thought Alice
putting up some tactics but take a look
at what is happening on that bottom
right Logan hold on what happened
I mean let's just quickly jump over to
that what is going on Sarah Pap
demolishing Benjamin Bach according to
our eval bar James take it away it
happened okay we gotta go back to where
it was just equal right was this all he
sacked a piece somewhere in here uh all
the way back here still so right here is
where it happened this is kind of where
we left off after Queen F3 and then
rookie eight and he took on B7 and just
sacked a piece here he loses a piece but
he's saying my B Pawn is strong that is
that's way too far though because the B8
square is covered by the queen and the
bishop so he loses by in and out loses
obviously the engine says you're losing
here practically he's saying I have the
pass Pawn but he just you know grabbed
the piece says uh Pap here Sarah
push Knight E2 check I bring the Knight
out I get rid of your Bishop probably
too as well so you're not he didn't
allow it and this is the live position
after a few more moves here and here we
are here we are I mean b8's covered I
guess you do have some conversation but
black is up a piece here Tanya
yeah and that's a very very healthy
extra piece on F4 I mean you are
creating your own threat watch out that
Bishop E4 can never move out because
Queen D7 is coming queen E2 is coming in
all the way from E7 D7 Knight right now
is protected as you're pointing out B7
Pawn looks like the big danger but it's
completely in controlled by these two
pieces Bishop before that last move but
black still needs to find a way to
either he head to the white king and
Sarah Pap does it as Nemo said it she's
been impressed by the women players this
time it is the one on the Berlin Bears
team Sarah Bob looks like she's taking
down Grandmaster Benjamin he's
definitely swinging she is trying right
here she's trying very hard play F5 and
we lie very strong move the idea here is
obviously well let's just make a bishop
move something like Bishop to G2 or even
H1 it doesn't work here immediately
losing Queen E2 and then Queen to E1 and
you're done there picking up another
piece check and take on E1 so that's not
going to be any good there so you might
have to check meaning that you know
obviously we could take it but then
that's another piece that you're down
that is now gone we could take but I
probably wouldn't I would just maybe
sidestep King H7 or f8 something maybe
like eight seven I think Queen E2 is uh
still there it's also a bishop F3 but
then maybe I take on G4 I mean this is
just black right yeah even oh my
goodness 95 here James this is just over
5 is a brilliant move because you don't
have a good Square for the bishop you
fall back on F3 whether it is after the
check or before the check it doesn't
matter Black's got the other night
jumping into the game Knight E5 will be
coming in right now she goes King to the
only thing is if you go King at seven
watch out let's just point out king F7
is super precise because King 87 would
actually run into white capturing the F5
Pawn because then when you recapture
James it comes in with a check on Bishop
F5 so you don't have time to go in with
Queen E2 so King F7 saurop up that
absolutely precise in her attack with
just a minute on the clock and the
troubles continue trouble is definitely
uh continuing here B8 is on lock you
can't do anything with the BH Square I
got both pieces covering it and the
Knight on E1 is not doing uh it's a
great job of doing really anything it's
just kind of an annoying night that's
sitting on the back Rank and it's not
helping in our attack or I mean it's
just helping our defense here and we've
done a piece here and time is getting
closer doc has a small time Edge but
that is diminishing as he's sitting here
thinking figuring out what to do in this
position right now hey you have to you
have to take and play Bishop F3 or just
Bishop F3 like there's no option here in
time
yeah you don't have a good Square for
the bishop you have to guard the E2
square but that's the whole problem
James even on on the F3 Square your
Bishop is not safe the other Knight
jumps into the game to E5 creating a lot
of trouble Benjamin here taking time but
I don't think that's going to help him
Sarah needs to keep her cool because it
might look easy but in chess that's the
one of the hardest things to do when
you're in a winning position you're
playing against the Grand Master you're
playing for a team there's so much at
stake to just keep control over your
nerves she knows she's winning but as
they say in chess winning a winning
position is one of the most difficult
things to do yeah
yeah absolutely let's go back to our
board's eye view there and see what we
have there's a check there see anything
else going on there Sarah Pat wow look
at the eval bar Fabi with the lens stuff
going on everywhere everywhere where do
we go whoa take a look at that on the
top left board white is completely
winning Matthias is back he's getting
over that big upset in round one against
Alice Lee and it looks like he's two
pawns up he will be taking this end game
meanwhile on that bottom left Port it
looked like Fabi was the one who was
winning but this is the game we jumped
to and I see that Nicholas is playing on
second this could be matthias's game
he's got the clock under control and the
boat situation he's got a check I was
first gonna go Rook H5 and then I just I
realized
hold on let me uh let me try to I don't
know why I can't maybe OTB maybe you
could try OTB you can you know but here
it is Unfortunately they won't let you
do it in E2 okay F6 and now we have to
yeah probably just walk the king over
wait if this is hanging though
interesting this is winning but these
are hard actually the eval bar went down
to as well but this is these are some of
the hardest in games obviously right
make sure you and your Devore rescues or
your Jeremy Summit in games and then go
to the rescue but this stuff's difficult
here
and we do have our first result of round
two Fabiano caruana does win his game
against Michael B is also Fabi on two
out of two today he is looking to get
into the Hall of Fame of being 100
scorer for his team starting strong here
the problem with this position James is
that there is no good way to defend the
B3 pawn and blue bomb is going to end up
losing it
he did he trades on E5 I'm slightly
surprised with that I thought I was
expecting him to go B6 and keep the
bishop alive yeah I was thinking the
same thing because this one is very
close to a draw now especially the best
defense or offense behind is uh with a
pass Pawn is behind it so Rook B3 being
behind the pawn here is is the best
defense that you can have for any any a
rook in game right I'll just go King C7
here right we take and then even though
I'm you know even if I go down the pawn
yeah this is a Philadelphia position
classic drop make sure you guys are in
your devil ratsuki this is rook in Games
chapter two endeavoretsky right so this
is a philodor position you need to know
how to do this check so you need to know
how to do it on the pawn advances we go
through the back rank that's it cover
the third cover the rank
nicely done James you know your end game
manual as you're pointing out black has
got the king in front of the pawn this
will end in a draw meanwhile Alice it
looks like has is also heading towards
the draw take a look at that there's no
way that black and white she holds Eric
Braun
unbelievable stuff she says Rook at
seven pick it up that is a draw so it
just ends promo Alice man I would stand
up in place is doing it she is James
Alice is truly in Wonderland today look
at her on the screen she is a killing
killing it today what a girl what a
player and so calm and composed amazing
stuff there meanwhile we've got some
more crazy action on because take a look
at that bottom right mode it's not only
Alice who's shining but Sarah as well
with the black pieces let's jump to that
that is the Berlin Bears Big Hope in
this one after blue bomb failed to
convert his winning position wow you
know it was tough there of course he
wasn't able to confirm here but someone
at is is looking like Sarah Pepper now
wait a second one thing that I do notice
is the time for both so the time is
drastically low and when you get to
these bullet type positions almost
anything happens yes there is a two
second increment but lots of crazy
things happen in time trouble so
hopefully hopefully she's able to
convert this I think she she will so I
mean she can go night E3 was a move
there or even Knight A4 to go Bishop C3
and then uh Knight B2 and D2 check he
wants to give it yeah
and the best part is that White's B7
Pawn we've been talking about it from
the start is heading nowhere white
skiing is stuck to defend the D3 pawn
and now she wants to get that Bishop to
A7 Target that King on E3 but she has to
start making progress somewhere she
first pushes the king forward then
she'll Advance with her own King so once
white king Falls backwards sorry not
forward comes back to D2 black wants to
go King D4 give that check on B3 that
you were talking about eventually right
now Knight B7 wait Knight B7 check
Knight B7 check oh yeah just take she
wants to give the details there it is
I'm gonna take the D3 Pawn I'll take the
d Pawn see I get one you get one yeah
he's trying to make this as close to a
draw as possible and that is it's a very
nice from bot I mean very nice defensive
thing I mean this could this could you
know this could still go wrong
and now you're gonna end up losing the C
Pawn because it was a six one you didn't
have a way to keep both pawns defend
that James
you have to give a check on D4 with the
Knight she has to imagine once this
Knight gets to D4 you drive the king
away if it goes to F2 okay she goes H4
she wants to get Knight F5 and then give
a check on either D4 or G3 it's headed
there it's coming in James yeah Here It
Comes Here Comes This one is okay that's
a nice little tricky tricky almost
tricky maybe King G3 here it is
94.94 wins that pawn and wins the game
okay I don't give me everything oh my
goodness box going down no
no
that is always a nightmare to play by
the way because you know there's so much
pressure it's all eyes on you you have
to convert it but it looks she she has
to know the way and with just seconds on
the clock you know there's a 50 move
rule it can get really tricky and she's
gonna do everything to avoid that she
wants to push that pawn without giving
it away but I don't see I don't think
there's a widget you have to give that
ball you're gonna have to go Bishop a
knife
okay because it's definitely difficult
okay I'm not gonna lie even when you
know it like oh yeah
exactly that's the point James it's it's
difficult even if
even if it had practiced it but with the
pressure and the nerves and the seconds
on the clock yeah
yeah the move counter you know you mess
up one structure again
oh my goodness she hangs out look at her
look at look at the face oh my goodness
would have saved anything happens in
time trouble Anything is Possible Oh My
Goodness big buck From the Block here
came out and Gotti got himself a little
draw ski unbelievable now okay he still
needs to clean up
that hurts I was a huge blind spot that
was a huge blind spot such she plays so
good don't take the night
19th on ending is a draw as well and now
he just keeps the bishop on this
diagonal you're never getting it
anywhere black can give a check but the
king will go up this is a draw I can't
believe what just happened man that that
was a one more blunder it was and this
is what you were saying right James in
seconds anything nothing happens
anything happens crazy stuff go down yep
yep it's anything happens in the time
pressure and that's what happened time
pressure if you play King H4 and Bach
was looking what the heck is that is and
then he takes the bishop and it's a
clean draw here wow
some new merch ideas there maybe time
over everything oh t-o-e chair t-o-e
we're gonna put that in the chat we get
some emails made for that one today
c-o-e wow that was crazy another round
there but hey Bach was able to save what
could have been you know something very
big like almost a big you know
confidence booster for the Bears now to
draw and keeps the archbishops with the
lead
yeah and Greg saying that he's
disappointed he wanted to see that
bishop and Knight was his King oh my God
that's a scary scary thought for a
player let me tell you that and despite
not being despite holding that one it
does look like the Saint Louis
Archbishop did win again uh Benjamin
survives the scare now that match would
have turned it around had Sarah won that
game James it would have been a level
2-2 score but with Benjamin surviving
that one it is a Saint Louis
archbishop's win round two as well so
again widening that Gap whitening that
lead with this round win they take their
overall scores all right six to two is
still a ridiculous life that's that's
huge that's really big to come back from
I mean really that's two and a half
points right that's a tough time
James look at look at the board scores
there every player from the Berlin Bears
they've scored half a point up till now
up to now going into round three okay
going into round three stop meanwhile
Fabi is raked up two out of two Benjamin
surviving that scare with two draws is
that one and Alice Lee oh my God the MVP
of the Saint Louis Archbishop but James
this means that if they win the next
match two and a half to one and a half
it's match over and Berlin Bears get
eliminated they're going home right like
Levy said the Bears will be extinct if
they lose in this match here it's going
to be over they needed they'd come back
here and they need it right now I mean
they need to win on all boards or at
least three and a half at least win the
match to be able to uh hold them down to
maybe one and a half points in the next
match and hopefully make it to round
four and then and uh see what they can
do there so it's tough stuff they got a
lot a lot to come back from Tanya
they've got a lot to come back from
we're gonna come back into round three
action it's shot at the Berlin Bears
need to make their comeback they have to
do it now as James Canty is saying it
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
I do like positional styled games I may
try to keep it positional but I I I can
also uh change gears and I think that's
very important in terms of uh
you know anyone trying to develop their
chess game
um if you do find you know style of play
that you enjoy that's good but you could
also try to sharpen it by implementing
you know another form of
into your bag as we would call it right
International Master Danny wrench Chief
chess officer back again with more chess
terms here for you today we're going to
talk about the past Pawn the past Pawn
must be pushed you hear it said often
and that's because just about every end
game you see that isn't a blowout often
comes down to maybe someone's up one
Pawn or maybe even just the first person
to create a past Pawn is the person who
goes on to win that game we're going to
talk about what the past Pawn is and to
find it for you in today's video let's
do it what is a past Pawn a past Pawn is
a pawn that has no enemy pawns stopping
it from moving forward that means pawns
either on the file in which it resides
or on the adjacent files that would
therefore capture the pawn should it
advance so if a pawn has none of those
things stopping its way then it's time
to push them baby as our boy Yasser
would say and as you hear mentioned on
many broadcasts that you would watch on
chess TV and on that note as we look at
our game examples we like to do this is
taken from Thomas chefsky versus rajava
here white plays the move B5 5x Glam
which highlights again it's not how many
pawns you have but who's going to be
threatening to get a queen first after
black takes it white pushes forward with
gusto and because the Rook can't
blockade the pawn due to the light
Square Bishop this game is already over
black is going to have to sacrifice the
bishop for the pawn on B6 and white
would simply be up a minor piece note
that after the first move B5 should a
takes B5 have been played white would
have pushed this pawn and then trap The
Rook on A7 showing the power of the pass
Pawn as with it protecting the bishop
this Rook is completely out of the game
and white would easily go on to win
picking up pawns and just flexing the
rook's muscles over the bishop for the
rest of the game so here we see a
passphawn being used as a weapon to just
cramp down and trap all of your enemy
pieces so this has been another chest
rooms video hope you enjoyed it hope
you're enjoying all of them and with
that I will sign off hoping that you
learned something about what a pass Pawn
is and we'll see you around on chess.com
um
foreign
this match has been absolutely lit what
fireworks we've seen James so far full
of shocks and surprises there and of
course the Saint Louis archbishops are
in the lead they have had a
disappointing run but today is a
different day we see a different team
they're inspired and leading from the
front is none other than world number
eight former World Championship
Challenger Fabiano caruana with huge
responsibility on his shoulders to make
sure that this legendary team of the
protest league is not eliminated and
he's doing a great job he's on three and
a half out of four so far he has been
part of the two-time winning team of the
St Louis Archbishop we see him there and
James it looks like he's playing for
half hotel room or something oh yeah you
know he always traveling I can actually
DM I actually got his number too so
shout out to Fabio I was in his
Instagram we're like hey little brag
there real real quick hey bro where you
at you know I'm doing this good luck bro
here goes Coe cat right send us some Coe
gear shout out to him Fabi is a monster
here he's definitely doing something
somewhere he's playing chess that's
where he is because he's definitely in
the hotel
he is the reigning U.S Champion he's
doing his bit for the team but not just
him who is bringing on the fireworks
because look at that margin that
impressive score line six to two and of
course Bobby's been on fire with two out
of two but really James it's been the
last two boards that have been so
impressive and I think it's been Alice
Lee's day who in round one took down
blue bomb in round two Drew against Eric
Braun what a performance by the 13 year
old women International Master Alice is
taking everybody to Wonderland this is
her Wonderland right now she is going
off I mean literally as a board four you
want everything out of your board for
there I mean sometimes you're just like
hey just go in there and get some draws
she got a win and a draw and now she's
gonna face board three and four I mean
hey not to say the boy three or four are
anywhere weak that they not they're just
not weak but it is probably slightly
easier than the boards one and two
because they are four three or four so
it obviously matches up with Styles two
as well and certain other things that
can um it can go into the game but Alice
Lee is very Fearless since he's playing
out of her mind right now so St Louis
archbishops definitely have hugely
especially because of Alice Lee and then
Nicholas theodoro de los bottom boards
can really beef up that score
that is The X Factor and on the left
side of our screen we can see we're just
half Point scoring there by the Berlin
Bears they've got to step it up they've
got to step it up big time James because
look at our round three and now
potentially this could be match over if
the Saint Louis Archbishop win this
round with a two and a half one and a
half the minimum margin they take it
home it's wrap up bye bye Berlin Bears
Berlin Bears on the other hand have to
make sure they not only win but win with
a big margin now we see these lineups
where do you see them scoring how are
they going to do this are they even
gonna do it do you think we're gonna
have a round four so many questions
James so many questions right not enough
answers here Michael Michael bezel here
is
I mean no bro I can't say that Alice Lee
player out her mind man that's gonna be
a fight okay Michael Bezos is gonna play
I like his style and like he's
unorthodox and he makes things very
strange on the board so obviously he's
gonna have I think that's gonna be tough
she needs to navigate navigate her way
through the the complications Michael
bezo puts on her I think there and even
uh the final board there's Sarah Pap
actually if they can get those Bottom
Boys working maybe you have a drawer or
two at the top and one win then you know
Bears will be in good shape but of
course you you're playing against these
archbishops who are really strong and
only two and a half away from clinching
the match so so it's very difficult
bears are on an uphill battle
yeah that is a that is an up Mountain
battle really this is gonna be super
hard
I mean I don't it very well
good round but of course
blue bomb on the top board has to try to
do his best even though he's playing
with the black pieces to create his
chances against Benjamin who survived a
scare against sarapap and we see well it
could be a ragazim but the knights are
still not developed so it makes it a
little more unconventional we have these
positions with the Knight on G1 on F3
already but the players are playing so
fast and now uh it comes to White you
place it on F3 but because you've
delayed the development you have the
option to develop your bishop and put it
on E2 instead
and in fact we have actually quick trade
something nimso like where we're playing
against isolated pawns here C3 and D5
Bishops here I mean hey look I'm I'm
just playing a game here I feel good as
white I have the two Bishops already now
it is very level I have a bishop D6
which is very tempting to play here it
is holding and hitting the rook and it's
also a Tempo I'm a big fan of the tempo
but it also can backfire maybe in some
cases wait but how though interesting
obesity six is nice also Knight of three
natural development
it's also really nice he goes for your
idea Bishop D6 because not only you hit
the Rook but you actually keep your
extra Pawn alive for another move or two
Black's gotta show and gotta sweat it
out a little more to actually win that
pawn back anyplace 92 Queen okay so
Queen A5 hitting C5 twice now Knight C5
is the threat here maybe we just Castle
get out of the way and say all right you
can have your Pawn back bro because I
guess I have to do that C6 is also a
move as well then Bishop B4 but that
connects his pawns whoa A4 interesting
move wow that is aggressive stuff is it
Bishop
James
yeah you're really after blue bombs Rook
I see Bishop D6 Bishop B5 you really
want the bishop pair to do its job right
now right I mean there's lasers here is
how they're working but King's in a
center probably just needs the castle to
be honest you gotta get I mean I don't
want to give him this bishop there we go
come on there it is
wearing in Castle and get out of the way
maybe just Castle now this Bishop's
quite annoying in fact quite annoying
but it's not it's loose it's undefended
so loose pieces lose games so you have
to be careful of the loose pieces it
should be forced definitely move and
castling
wow I like Bishop before and you really
managed to keep those Bishop paralyzed
you're you're a fan of Bishops you're
doing them a favor in this one you're
not giving anyone away and it makes a
lot of sense because it's an open
position in open positions Bishops are
stronger than Knights and not just that
D5 is a long-term isolated Queen spawn
weakness that Knight on E2 once you've
castled will jump to F4 and start
targeting the pawn I like your move
Bishop B4 while Benjamin decides whether
to go for shot Castle or to come back
with the bishop he decides to get his
King to Safety First A6 pushing that
Bishop now the players are playing super
fast getting those Moves In in fact two
bombs got more time than what he started
with right I'm expecting you want him to
drop back with the bishop to D3 oh
definitely yeah Bishop D3 We're Not
Gonna Take on D7 We're not gonna allow
you to uh develop your pieces I want
Bishop D3 and if you go Knight C5 okay
whatever Bishop C2 I have to move it
twice so what I'm gonna keep my Bishops
because I have the bishop pair with the
queen on D4 maybe something like this as
well I mean hey aim at this side of the
board hope for the best maybe there's a
bishop E5 in there right if everything
gets aimed if you get Queen D4 in get
the bishop here tuck it on C2 tuck and
roll there Bishop on E5 we got some
stuff we actually have some pieces
aiming at this side of the board right
now of course it's still going to take
maybe a rook lift or another piece to be
able to really attack this side of the
board but the chances and possibilities
are there
I feel like you just dropped a diss
track on those nights
definitely a mixtape dropping soon right
these nights not anymore right that's
the name of it so okay pretty nice
working on that one I love it all right
James
he's deciding whether to fall back with
the bishop you know what while I was
saying that I just realized and I want
to make this point before we move on
that it's very possible that it just to
just to show something a move like Rook
to A3 you know you have to keep these
tactics in your mind always it might not
work it might be really silly
doesn't improve and I know why because
the point that I wanted to make was that
if you take on B5 you recapture on B5
and The Rook on it is hanging but in
this position you can actually pick up
the rook and pick up the bishop then and
you have a lot of material which is why
it approves this was a little tactical
idea we often see in these kind of
positions so always watch out for that
instead he of course goes for a more
sane approach with Bishop before yeah
yeah
that's a nasty one that's up my alley
there I love that type of chest and then
just work left and like we'll just swing
the Rick over to the side of the board
and just made them right you see Tyler
do this all the time shout out the
grandfather towel of course right we see
mini game with the Rook lift here and in
a game like this we root lift all the
way it was just ridiculous that was a
cool move though Rook A3 and in the live
position you have a six Bishop before
Queen C7 take take oh my goodness what
are you doing why take it of course
that's just gross but of course Bishop
takes D7 and A5 now we just got a boring
game very boring and the pawn on D5 is
isolated it's gonna be a long one it's
gonna be a long one and I think if
anyone has chances here it looks really
good for white because you pointed out
that Bond weakness the White Knight can
jump onto D4 that's a nice Square you
can start even take it to F4 and Target
that pawn as is the famous saying when
you're playing against the isolated
Queen's Pawn you know go for it attack
it don't put a piece in front of it if
you can win it but it's a long way off
let's see what plan Benjamin goes for
but while he has a thing let's jump to
our bird's eye view because there is
action on the other boards as well and
you were talking about creating attack
on the king side I do see on our bottom
left a queen has landed on G4 why has a
bishop on D4 and that's always super
scary look at the dark Squad weaknesses
on that one and here it does look like
Alice has to be on the defense and
defend this super precisely but this is
looking like it's going to be a tough
one it's definitely a tough one for
Alice it's just clearly white is the one
pushing for more in this game it feels
pretty smooth for white yes a dark
Square Bishop dominating the Knight
right now but you don't have the
clear-cut way to do things yet but
definitely white is for choice in this
game now a Michael bezel is actually
very creative player I think so let's
see how we got to this position C4 C6
okay so yeah E3 all right kind of
different yeah he played just move order
in a way to some type of ready type
position now with the bishop coming to
B2 very strong position now
um takes takes Knight B5 he took the
bishop pair and played Bishop E2 castle
and H3 okay
yep take take take yeah this is
practically these are very equal
practically very equal positions but AC
to eval bar like plus 2.7 like that's
crazy but practically I mean these are
more equal to than that because you have
to be so precise for this 2.7 to
manifest
very true but it's also sort of
sort of play with why
what rather than with black and why say
that James is because
white has got a lot of pleasant options
which don't ruin his position meanwhile
Alice won bad move and you can get
checkmated on those dark squares oh it
has a clear idea what Michael wants to
do is bring the other Rook to C1 and get
into that seventh rank or the sixth rank
hit the queen or hit the Knight Queen
hit six threatening the G7 mate there
are a lot of weaknesses in Black's King
side and I think this is going to be a
tough task for Alice to defend there's
lots of it is it's going to be very
difficult to defend but it is possible
as we saw with uh even in the back game
back down a clean piece absolute did not
work try again not today if this just
was not working and then he was able to
draw the game even down a piece so it is
possible you have to be able to hold
positions that are really bad or at
least fight be tenacious and actually
fight back as much as you can so um
we've seen a lot of that actually with
Alice Lee in fact in that last game she
was worse who gets the Bishops and still
was able to find a way to draw that one
very important and the move that she's
made is also very important here because
Rook see it it was really the only
chance to try and trade off one of the
Rooks before white doubled up and got
control black had to make this move and
now what you can do is trade on C3 once
and defend block the C file with your
knight she does it she's on fire she's
not only attacking like a monster but
defending like a monster that's that
that's scary a two-headed monster
sometimes I just don't know what to do
like cut off one and then the other one
grows back even stronger it's insane
right you have to defend it like a beast
too as well Knight C5 definitely is a
move I was considering B4 but then 96 I
was trying to figure out what to do
maybe there it is I see five you might
go B4 and Bishop you just have to think
go for it B4 Bishop E5 and Rook C7 and
hope for your opponent making some type
of mistake because there's like mates
everywhere there's all kinds of squares
you know we can draw more arrows here
Hikaru style but this is like really
really difficult I think from a from a
practical standpoint now after this
before for Bishop E5 idea right there's
lots of things that we can do so see
what he comes up with
I'm loving it I'm loving it the fact
that you're pointing out this night
Falls to E6 it's such a key Defender
because it guards the G7 Square it also
guards the C7 Square it's really the
superstar in Alice's position keeping
everything together now B4 is very
committal it invites 96 and Michael has
to be sure that he's okay giving up the
B4 Pawn because he's definitely not
going to give up that Bishop on D4 Rook
C6 you're pointing out and this might be
really strong because take a look at
this rookie eight might even run into
Rook takes E6 or queen F6 or queen FC
yeah Queen F6 I was looking at 98 and
what do we do on Knight d8 maybe I was
looking at Rook G6 does that work no
Rich E6 doesn't work queen h8 king F7
Queen is so close to working but so
close
C7 is like everything yeah I mean this
is really bad to say the least really
bad let's refresh and see what happens
let's see if we have any live moves and
we have Bishop E5 play first
that makes a lot of sense because you
don't want to create a weakness B4 is
always in the eye he could do it on the
next move so while Alice is really
trying to defend Queen D7 now before
Knight E6 still has everything under
control yeah it does it does oh wow
there's nothing after that wow that is
some good defense yeah he had I think he
had to go with that B4 route because the
queen was not well actually she could
have played Queen D7 anyway b496 Bishop
B5 you don't have to take on B4 you
could go Queen D7 it'd be
transpositioned into what we have now if
he goes B4 and Knight to E6
I mean I guess you just press and you're
just better see by King H2 yeah I guess
I understand that loses the entire
Advantage there I'm curious to see what
the engine thought let me actually turn
it on and it says
oh get out of here that's just engine
it's a get out of here bro it's B4
Knight E6 and then A4 A5 it's just it's
just better you know like before you say
it once you say it it makes so much
sense because it provokes a second
weakness in the position you're trying
to break it is the concept of two
weaknesses you know you've got this King
side attack the dark Squad weakness and
you want to create one more on the queen
side it's going to be hard to defend but
the thing is it's just such an
unpleasant position for black and even
what was played by Michael the move King
H2 it just keeps all these threats on
the board and it's just gonna be a long
grind and a long defense by Alice now
let's pull up our bird's eye view
because there are some of the other
players who are on some high defense
situations where they really need to
bring out their resources the games have
been so thrilling that we barely had a
look at Fabiano's positions in either of
the rounds because everyone else has
been on fire James right and take a look
at the top right board now it looks like
Fabi is the one with the space Advantage
we see that King side pawns have
advanced the queen Side Pawn on A5
Knight on H4 can look scary but it's a
lone Warrior it's got no support around
it and I think Fabi is doing well in
that one meanwhile on the bottom right
board the Lewis archbishops are the ones
who are clearly better there with
Nicholas calling the advantage against
Sarah and this looks like huge Advantage
should we jump to that and see why is
White's position so bad absolutely what
was this opening let's see what this
game was it was a sicilian and which one
before it is the Nicholas theodoro
versus Sarah Pap and I see that a knight
is under attack and black is doing great
here but I'm struggling to see why is
this position so good for black because
oh it's Bishop B4 right now I see it now
this is just here
oh that makes a lot of sense
wait okay thanks for the complaints GG
like
it should be four in the exchange and
that is why black has a clear Advantage
Sarah Pap in big trouble the H5 Knight
is hanging but I don't think you have
time you can go Queen F3 with the D4
Knight the E5 Bishop everything is
everything how is this only minus three
I mean it feels like everything's
hanging 95 is here Knight D4 yeah you
can get a knight but like I mean I'm
hitting this too like what is this
actually there's a very big chance that
white could very go so go wrong let me
actually see what it is yeah it's crazy
it's not even a queen move it's you have
to play Knight E6 is the best move
Knight E6 Pawn C5 or take the Knight on
C6 it's not even moving the queen
because there's so it's I mean just it
felt like that too like if you move the
queen like everything's hanging
everything's hanging but I'm pretty sure
she's gonna move the queen because
that's what a human would do like we
would just move the queen somewhere here
that's the most logical right correct
queen of B3 it builds up completely
Knight to D4 maybe first or maybe we
just take on E1 a little bit of Queen's
hanging right so that's cute so maybe 90
I mean you can take on E5 right that
looks really simple you go Knight E5
white the D4 Knight is hanging you can't
go Bishop page five because I pick up
the
what do I pick up right because they
pick up B4 this is tricky still there's
some tricks there is some tricks
probably crazy Queen B3 hmm maybe you go
Rook D4 Rook D4
Bishop H5
it's the same thing dang what is this
94 Bishop D4 Rook D4 Bishop H5 wow
that's actually really good
this is not as clear as it looks because
I really wanted to pick up that Bishop
on E5 and say that if you pick up the
bishop on E6 95 96 then eventually I can
it's still so complicated I could take
with the queen but then the bishop on B4
hangs correct
they're everywhere everything is hanging
everywhere oh my God everything is
hanging everywhere okay now I gotta
check the line let me see what the lines
now the bar says that black is just
winning here it's Rook D4 it's Rook D4
but the follow-up like it doesn't even
say Bishop H5 which is a very logical
human follow-up so I don't understand
why it says Knight C2 after Rook D4 but
Rook D4 I was concerned about Bishop H5
not not anything else so Bishop h5o is
the only thing I was concerned of so
after you know Rook D4 Bishop H5 happens
it's like you see that here Rook D4 and
then Bishop takes H5 the bishop H5
there's uh maybe you can just go Rook D2
here and start pushing recording
pressure on F2 and it just looks like a
position that's super dangerous for
white you could fall back with the
bishop to G3 but the Knight is jumping
to D4 the Knight is jumping to A5 there
are so many threats in the position and
whites just really lose everywhere this
is a crazy move crazy game so far queen
of B3 and he's still with the knife it's
understandable all right that's
I mean that's a very natural move you
hit the queen and now white has to
recapture you can take on H5 because
very important notice how the queen on
B6 is playing so Bishop E1 is not
possible so after Bishop H5 black will
perhaps fall to the go ahead with the
Rook to the second rank I still like the
move Rook D2 a lot
I like this too episode Rook V2 still
seems very strong hits F2 as well
um I don't like that for some reason
maybe nice no this is hanging rookie the
pizza is really good he does good
practically as a good human move I think
we refresh Bishop H5 is on the board and
we're gonna see a few minutes minus four
what is the move here engine definitely
baffled us today with the moves they're
making look at this Rook H4 nobody's
playing that nobody is gonna put the
Rook over here to H4 wait what about
okay one second Rook H4 makes no sense
to me but I'll have a question for you
why can't black just go I'm here I'm
hitting that Bishop on H5 I'm stepping
out of the pin I'm hitting your Rook on
E1 you hit the Rook on E1 that's a very
simple one actually simple well what if
I move the root though and then you take
oh I take on A3 then H5 then I take on
E3 and then I take on H5 yeah I mean I
don't understand Rook H4 because any
sense in C5
so nice same idea
same idea yeah very nice very nice same
idea but that actually wow Eva bar hated
that but I mean this this is a nice idea
it's the same idea different Square
but also James from A5 I think maybe the
Evon Rook would have been attacked twice
so it could have been but I I have no
idea I mean queen C5 also makes so much
yeah anyway nicely too I think this is
the idea here Rook takes E6 let me see
is the eval Virgo crazy it does this is
minus five after that six I was gonna
play nicely too and then four can get
the piece back but I guess you have to
take something else first so Rook D2
comes in and F2 is hanging so it just
would fall apart I mean that's a nice
Fork but Rook D2 is always in the air
man this is what a tactical game this
one was I mean crazy right brain's just
like wacky you know there's so many
things to look out for obviously all in
Black's favorite we would say here but
now white has a chance to bounce back
here
um so see what happens and I like Queen
C5 also because it always eyes that F2
Pawn you know that you
and
Sarah pop is in big trouble it is a huge
blunder you could take on E1 you could
play Rook D2 perhaps Bishop B12 Bishop
E1 yeah Knight D4 is what they want and
after 94 Bishop F2 first and then oh
Bishop F2 that's nice that's super nice
super nasty Bishop we have two first
take here C4s hanging this one's gonna
be all right and where do you go with
your king if you go King F1 let's just
show that Bishop F2 King F2 night before
First bishop F2 King F2 Queen D4 and you
go to F1 Bishop C4 wins the queen wow
King F1 that's a wrap that's why it's
minus eight I was wondering why I said
minus eight and after uh after Bishop E1
uh on the eval bar but that makes sense
now because of Bishop C4 which means you
have to run your kingdom ge3 that's or
queen E3 Queen E3 that one's in a queen
B2 and you take the Rook on A1 and King
G3 you probably get made it in a few
here maybe that would be Checkmate over
everything
silly for real chat check made over
everything that's exactly what that one
will be and then Queen H4 will be mating
or F4 actually that's pretty nice stuff
man that's a nasty game wow Nicholas
Theodore it looks like Nicholas will be
taking this one for the Saint Louis
Archbishop let's get some birds eye view
up because there is action everywhere
and Fabiano caruana looks like he is in
some little bit of trouble there stop
right Ward I have to say that I kind of
likewise position I see the eval bar it
says everything's fine but it's
understandable it looks like fabi's King
might be weak the C file is under
control let's take a look at that James
you've got to see fabi's board right now
it is an interesting position both
players down to well at least Bobby's
down to about a minute on the clock
because
he has to be quick and black meanwhile
Eric has control of the C file right
he's attacking H4 H4 could be a
potential weakness the Black Knight
could reroute itself from G6 from f8 all
the way to G6 and Fabi sensing the
dangers plays Queen C3 offering a queen
trade he just says you know hey bro we
can we can take a draw here I mean
obviously that's not a draw offer here
because there's still a lot to play here
but I'm really black probably is for
Choice here as I think the bishop is a
little bit better and white does have a
bunch of Pawn weaknesses it feels like
more than black does in fact so I mean
white definitely has some uh some issues
to handle if I had a better King
placement okay my king feels good right
you want that in in game anyway and a
weird weird maneuver would be moving the
king all the way over here to A2 try to
trade the bishop on A3 just so I can get
rid of the bishop why is that important
so I can use the dark squares to get the
king of C5 and B6 and B7 try to use this
King in game I like to do ideas when
you're in in games it's very important
to understand what is the overall idea
so that you can do that so he might walk
his King all the way over here and then
reroute the bishop if it's possible to
A3 and then you play King C5 at some
point so very crazy you also play C4
maybe try to make this week so lots of
ideas here hmm very nicely pointed out
all these subtleties that exist in the
end game but this is going to be a grind
meanwhile we do have a result on the
Sarah path board Nicholas took that away
as we were expecting with that crazy
middle game but we've got to go really
quickly to the bird's eye view because
there is mad action on the Alice Lee
board what is happening on that bottom
left let's do a deep dive a black Pawn
on E2 a white Pawn on E6 the G7 square
is currently defended we can see see
that with the queen and with that last
move Alice Lee uh cannot cannot Queen
because Michael's put that Queen on the
center of the board let's do a deep dive
on this one we've got to get that board
up oh absolutely five what is happening
James actually happened how do we get
here to this position so all the way
back this is where we left off we got
here wow there's a lot of moves happen
so he did he went for a king H2 okay we
got A4 in he right rerouted the queen
got the queen around so you got the Rook
to the seventh rank gave up the pawn
gave up the bishop just to get you know
sort of a winning rook and in-game rook
and Queen in game or whatever and then
G5 wow G5 what an aggressive move here
so that's gonna be almost I'll be
winning shoot because you play Rook F1
and queen now maybe just go E7
um yeah I like it why not E7 looks
really strong and you push the Rook away
The Rook but she picks up the E2 he
picks up the E2 Pawn also makes a lot of
sense because after taking on F4 you've
got to check on G4 so you can't just go
Queen G4 check drive that King away and
then pick up the F4 Pawn as well
goes for it Michael giving the check
only move and now it takes out F4 Pawn
you can't take with the Queen James
because Queen G7 is Checkmate you can't
take with the Rook cause Rook C8 is
Checkmate and E7 incoming Queen F4
actually was it was hitting us with
checks so we had to take but the problem
was Workshop sorry yeah I was just Rook
check E7 I mean you're still losing I
guess still losing after you trade the
Queen's Rook check E7 loses this is a
completely losing I mean it's pretty
tough I mean uh definitely Michael besso
is a very creative player and sometimes
like I definitely just got to her in
this game he was mixing things up he's
very strong and tactical too so that
combination there Alice's it was not
able
is game over oh yes game over yeah I can
resign on the spot 25 just forces the
trade off everything on the board and
that is and and you're like you're
pointing out you don't even have to
trade you can go see it after Rook G7
and everything wins and that is it
Michael Bizzle does what a blue bomb
could not do what Eric Braun could not
do he finally wins against Alice Lee
where you got action on on the other
boards and wow so so this is a 1-1 score
so far look at that top left the
Benjamin board that is madness we've got
to rush to that one with the players
playing in seconds
we gotta see the reaction he hung the
whole Queen wait was it Bach white one
no it was uh hung the whole Queen bro
the whole thing is not his day if you
just back up one move
wow
and we've got to rush to the last board
remaining after this blunder the match
does rely on this final board on the top
right Fabi is the one he has to make
sure that he at least at least draws
this game to win that if he draws this
game same is not only round over it is
match over draw what how you gonna draw
I mean like he got any pencils or pins
or any paper or anything around him
right now to draw this game boy wow this
one I mean you ain't drawing nothing
around here my guy whoa you're down a
piece I mean you're down a piece yeah
this one's really bad oh yeah oh my God
and the Apon and that's it can you see
the distrust on Fabi he can't believe it
everything was under control and now the
a pawn passes and Eric Braun is the
savior right now for the Berlin Bears he
keeps he keeps the match alive but
Saint Louis Archbishop could have
wrapped it up in this one going into the
next round James they're gonna need half
a point half a point I mean right and
all I gotta do is breathe right now we
can have a point right four games all I
need is a half point to clench the match
here somebody's gonna do it here I think
it is all but over here I mean I think
it is a it is for the Bears here you got
you need what four points you gotta win
all four just to tie it and go into a
tie break here it's very very difficult
for the Bears I don't think they're
going to be able to bounce back from
this one only a half point for St Louis
archbishops to send the Bears home
California unicond and and it is so
unpleasant to be on the Berlin Bears
side right now I mean you know you want
to fight for your team you want to get
those points in James but when you know
that your opponents need just half a
point on the floorboard it's just
psychologically so difficult to come
from that what a performance that has
been from the archbishops today four to
eight going into round four wow wow I
mean it's really it's really tough for
the Bears here they knew they were up
against some very strong opposition here
and the St Louis archbishops are
delivering they are here they're like
hey yeah we owe and two but we are still
defending Champions and we are trying to
work our way back up and climb our way
out of the hole that we put ourselves in
by beating the Bears in this match is
the first step and they're doing a good
job of that right now half a point from
clinch in the match
they're the only ones who are growling
in this one we've got round four coming
up chat we'll be right back
chess kit is fun Jess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest muscles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
oh
welcome into our new video lecture
series here with the one and only the
14th World chess champion vishwanathon
and on if you have to explain that
you're world champion and it's taking
longer than two words there's something
wrong with your adventure there's
something wrong but I believe in when
we're talking the 60s and 70s even the
80s and 90s
you could see that
the match format produced something
unique and I remember there was a funny
moment at the press conference where
I was trying to tone it down
not get very excited and also I had not
had time to collect myself in fact I
already wanted to calm down and think of
the next game because I knew this is a
wounded animal there I knew that I had
to play a game against a man who was
desperate for the match to be over so
that he could clinch his title he wanted
a draw at any price I mean you can make
a joke that he had spent a week out of
the swimming pool already so he must
have been exhausted and waiting to
finish so for all of us there was this
feeling of
um we got to grab this chance with both
hands because it's not going to come by
way
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
here is the man who has been leading the
Saint Louis Archbishop what a
performance he's had today so far for
his team he's the highest scorer with
two and a half points out of a possible
three there Nicolas teodoro looking
absolutely focused before this round
four now look at that score line I don't
even know how focused he needs to be for
this we've got a 4-8 modern margin with
that draw in the previous round a level
score of 2-2 Berlin bears survive to
take it to round four but that is barely
around that is barely surviving I can't
bear it Canty what's going on yeah
barely I think this is uh this is what
we talked about in the beginning where
hey right now is probably a time where
the energy is not as high for the Bears
I mean they're so it's settling in they
know look all they need is a half a
point try not to give it to them some of
them you know is as positive as you can
try to be like oh we can do this 4-0
right it's a very difficult practically
doing that you still have to do it and
not allow one draw on four boards and
sometimes I mean that's out of your
power in other boards you can only focus
on your board which it could go wrong
you never know what happens in those
games sometimes or you make a mistake so
it's very difficult you can't slip up
here but uh St Louis arm's business are
crucial and they're feeling good but
don't get too comfortable because it can
happen there's a possibility but it's
unlikely that the Bears will be able to
forward it
Fabiano Benjamin Nicholas Alice Lee any
one of them scores half a point the
match is all which means Berlin Bears
need to win on each and every board no
draws allowed and there the board one of
the Berlin Bears blue bomb what a
disastrous day it has been for him
starting with round one losing to Alice
and then dropping the queen with a one
more blunder against Benjamin Bach and
the reward he gets for that is playing
the last round against Fabiano caruana a
reward right and the reward and your
reward is you get to play Fabi oh my God
you know I'm going home like I'm just I
don't want to do this no more right if
that's your reward you get to play five
okay I get the white pieces okay I'll
stay there so D4 is C4 C6 right Knight
F3 and you play this boy out as much as
we can this could be the last and final
game of the Bears here this is be the
last of what you see of the Bears in
this round right now this is a what's
this Vienna or some semi slab
I talked to him at the cgc we had some
conversations and some drinks hanging
out with Fabi I was like uh yeah he said
semi-slave was a thing that he liked and
also uh regozen so if you guys like
semi-slab over goes and know that Fabi
actually likes these openings so
James when you're playing with white
against Fabi in a steam situation where
you need to win each and every board and
you're the one on the top board this is
exactly the kind of opening that you
want it's an absolutely ridiculous
opening take a look at what has happened
black already has a Pawn on C3 white is
trying to get the bishop there the
Knight is coming on to C5 if you take
that Knight on C5 Bishop C5 D take C5 it
opens up not only the D line but the C1
Bishop will jump to F4 will jump to D6
white doesn't care about Pawns in this
position white is looking for the attack
where's the attack E5 Knight G5 mate on
H7 there are all these ideas and
perhaps feeling a bit of the heat he's
slowed down a little bit after Knight C5
the bishop on B7 is hanging when you
play such an opening you've got to know
what you're doing you're right you got
to move in and it seems like there's
some kind of run off guard because you
are definitely right I love this
aggressive light position here and it
says something about you know I think
black's up a pawn here right three six
three six seven three six yeah he's up
that pawn right so he stole the pawn and
and here it says it's like the engine's
like you know eBay bar is like okay he
would it would say minus one right when
you're up a pawn usually or minus two
when you're up two pawns here it's like
equal and that's that says a lot about
White's position it's the conversation
and the activity of the pieces even uh
Kasparov says this as a material with a
peace activity trumps material most
times so if your pieces are active you
may you know it's better most times it
can be depending upon the position
obviously but
um you know if peace activity is more
important than that pawn right so we
have some peace activity the bishop can
go to F4 Bishop D3 you pointed out E5
Knight G5 stuff like that's some sick
stuff there you can also sack I mean
even Knight G5 Bishop C4 and Sac on F7
with Bishop E6 intentions there is a lot
here and black just needs to be very
very careful
um even though he's up to spot
but he's up upon and we know the engine
is some Material Girl it loves the pawns
and that's why it gives an advantage but
these positions are super super
dangerous as well very double-edged
Bobby on the screen looks very
comfortable going on to it because of
course black has his own trumps as well
that C3 Pawn is not just any pawn if
white cannot build an attack cannot
build an initiative it's just that lost
there's no going into end games anymore
you've got to finish the game as white
in the middle game you have to go for
the king all the ideas that you were
pointing at E5 Knight G5 take out the
bishop The Rook comes to D1 you can go
slow but the Queens have to stay on the
board and you have to go for black skin
that is White's task meanwhile uh we see
after Bishop E3 Bobby again taking a bit
of thing he's thinking about whether he
should go Knight to D7 trying to trade
off the knights or does he go short
Castle once you go shot Castle once you
Castle on the king side you're inviting
white to come ahead with that attack
with that move E5 or a potential night
jump to E5 James and then F4 F5 man it's
just like yeah I I honestly like white
in every position of these for summer
it's just like it's attacking I love to
attack it when you're aggressive and you
like to attack here this is the type of
the positions you would like of course
C3 is annoying but we just our goal is
to never get to an end game never get to
an end game just do anything else in
your power to not get to the end game
but in the meantime they have to win on
all boards so let's take a look at our
bird's eye view we have to win on all
boards here for the Bears so there's
anything that jumps out to you Tanya
wow and we know that round four is the
most evenly matched round of the protest
League where board one place board one
and bought four plays against board four
and I want to look at the bottom right
chord I see that it started as a queen's
Indian defense and Sarah's already gone
ahead on the board with her pawns on 86
G5 meanwhile white still hasn't castled
it looks like a really exciting middle
game let's get an up to date well it's
not even the middle game it's just a
very opening phase but we are headed for
a really fun middle game with the H file
open and black spawns on 86 G5 let's see
what happened here and we have ourselves
the Queen's gamble decline
okay E3 and very nice Bishop H4 just
developed the pieces
okay got the bishop here Castle Queen
side there we go that's what I'm talking
about Alice that's what I'm looking for
come on ah castle Queen side every game
if I could but this is very nice see now
before just immediately striking in the
center as well
that's still e girl aggressive get it
this is amazing stuff and I have to say
James I think black has to find a way to
Castle queenside as well if you go shot
castle if you go with with your own King
to the king side with that open H file
with the bishop and the queen lined up
it's going to be super dangerous in the
king side so I don't know do you take on
e4 do you first move your queen and just
rush to the queen side with your king
that's actually probably the best idea I
think maybe Queen D7 but you you will
allow me E5 is an option not that they
should play it but it is an option and
of course you have just space which
might be annoying if I'm white I do I
don't really like E5 I do want to just
open up things but D5 you have a very
nice grip on the D5 square and of course
A lot of times they say keep the tension
right so when Queen D7 it just keeps
attention I don't touch anything and I
want you to break attention obviously so
I can take on D5 isolate the pawn this
way so I think Queen D7 is probably a
move or like Queen something and then
Castle Queen side like you mentioned
here is probably a good route to go
because casting king size is literally
out of the question this shouldn't be a
move that you even could consider here
and watch her just Castle too like ow
Castle
probably just castles but Queen D7
um seems like a logical move and maybe
casting Queen side castles are the same
side see what happens especially with
these uh concessions H6 and G5
yeah exactly that's a huge concession on
the king side right and that stays there
which means it's super committal to take
your king to that side of the board and
as you're pointing out you know white
really wants to take on D5 open up that
e line and it's forcing it's forcing
Sarah to really think here using that
clock and this is not even the most
critical moment or the critical decision
that she has to take so Alice once again
with the white pieces putting the
pressure and I see our eval bar is
slowly inching and saying that black is
doing well here but I would be terrified
with black with that King in the center
he decides to trade on e4 and now she's
going to probably move that Queen and
get her King to safety of the bishop E4
what comes in my mind is maybe Queen D7
Queen D7 I am trying to get D5 to work
there but maybe it just doesn't work
ever D5 oh 95 you write that's even
stronger I like that and put something
on D6 afterwards too we need seven maybe
still 95 though 95 is a very strong move
it's a very annoying night I'm also
threatening stuff like maybe sacrificing
on C6 if you Castle it just depends on
what's going on here but I am definitely
liking what white looks like maybe even
rookie four we rookie won first and then
a D5 P1 it is yeah White's definitely
for choice
the king and queen are lined up it's
inviting the white Rook from H1 to E1
begging to be played then 95. uh Kanti I
love how you're always always looking
for the sacrifices I have one more idea
for you what about sacrifice over
everything oh sacrifice over hey Chad
y'all listen okay make sure when we
stream tonight I'm gonna need y'all to
come up with these out we need to talk
about these ideas Tanya bring it we got
to bring her on board you know what I'm
saying I won my commission if any of
them actually happened put her on
payroll we got you we already here for
our gaji Italian we put it some merch
lines out curtia Tanya Castle king size
he did it anyway she don't care about
life or anything wow that's a scary move
and I mean okay that's super Brave over
here yeah it's very brave right I guess
she's saying how do you get to me and I
am I believe you wow how do I get to you
I mean even if you don't get to black
skin immediately it's there for a while
you know you could give a check Bishop
87 check force it on the H1 uh H1 h8 uh
square and then bring your own Rook to
H1 at some point The Rook can transfer
back to H1 your Bishop could fall back
to F5 as well I like this move instead
of giving it to actually first goes with
the bishop to F5 because the Rook on E1
pins that Bishop on E6 and now black
spawn structure is going to be destroyed
yeah I actually like that actually you
know probably check and then Bishop back
might have been accurate too as well you
see that a lot in um in just random
Theory like you'll see it they'll play
the check on H7 and the reason for this
check is actually so the king is further
away from the center so just in case you
ever reach an in-game the king is
actually already on h8 so it's pretty
far away so Bishop H7 not only that but
also the Rook file being open it's just
a nice move I think a nice inclusion and
then going back to F5 but at Bishop F5
still a strong move and we still have
the option to go here and there but
probably not likely to go H7 back to F5
here so obviously F5 is nice though put
some pressure on it and maybe damage the
pawn structure maybe a G4 you also maybe
even have a 94 at some point after
taking try to go Knight to C5
hmm that's a really nice point to make
about putting a check in before doing
these trade just simply making sure that
black skiing is worse placed on h8 than
it is on G8 she goes for the idea of
destroying the structure now the Knight
can jump onto E5 it looks like Alice has
everything in control in this one she's
the one who has taken the wheels in this
game with the white pieces let's bring
up a bird's eye view let's not forget
the St Louis Archbishop need just half a
point to wrap up the match and we see on
the top right board Benjamin Bach
against Eric Brown that pawn structure
what is that pawn doing on E5 well it's
not there anymore on Passat done I feel
that top right we're gonna have a lot of
Trades and it looks like this should be
an equal position uh I this should be no
problem at all for either of these two
players well it is big problem yeah
it's a big problem for the Berlin Bears
right yes big problem because you need
something aggressive you need to win
right now of course this is still
possible to win like just because it
looks Josh doesn't mean it is a draw you
have to actually play it out you still
have to play the moves you still have to
reach the draw but you know it this is
definitely you know not better for
either side I think white maybe I'll
take for choice just because I have a
slight initiative very very slight that
is after Queen takes F4 here and I don't
even have any move that's doing anything
on the app file Queen F7 can be played
or f8 I do have a queen C7 and I can try
to annoy you here but I am playing a
very strong Grand Master Benjamin block
here of course so it is going to be
difficult to really try to create some
chances here but we're just going to try
our best we can take step four and try
to get a win here because we cannot
allow withdraw draws game over like you
got to win you got to go for it
you've got to take your chances Queen
afoyo pointing out but there are black
also has ideas of pushing those Central
pawns yes the material is equal but it's
far from over James I completely agree
with you uh Queen D4 taking control of
the f file sounds like the way if you
want to try to play for a win but I also
like black Central pawns and he goes for
it he plays your move but I want to
bring out the bird's eye view because
when we talk about pawns we've got to
take a look and what is happening on our
top left board and let's see if we can
bring the bird's eye view up because it
is madness on the Fabi board
born on C3 he's still up upon I don't
see the attack that's been created yet
by white but the Knight comes to D3 I
think we've got to do a deep dive on
this one Fabiano caruana with the black
pieces up upon but a crazy position b4's
attack Daddy what do you like do you
like the initiative or do you like
blacks extra Pawn on C3 I'm always a fan
of initiative here because that pawn can
definitely liquidate or I can get it
back and I am playing a human one Pawn
doesn't doesn't you know say the game's
over unless it's in game and it's not so
having that one Pawn okay cool you got
the pawn sometimes you don't even feel
that especially after Knight to D3 I
don't feel the pawn that that um that
Fabi is up right now okay B4 is
definitely threatened here in many cases
we have a rook A4 and if you end up
trading or if you trade on A1 we take
and then we go over K4 and we're hitting
B4 once again when B4 Falls C3 becomes
weak so then we go from being down upon
to now up a pawn after reevaluating or
regaining the material the 93 I thought
was excellent here it is completely
equal due to uh to to the engine in or
the eval bar saying zeros but I think
you know actually white has a slight
edge here Believe It or Not Bishop is
pretty gross on B7 Knight on D7 is kind
of restricted you know we got two loose
pieces meaning undefended right so there
could be tactics on this later on but at
the same time uh C5 is hanging is what
Fabi says so if you try to take my B4
I'll take your C5 everything liquidates
out we take on C32 as well so we're
level which I I understand the eval the
evaluation if we if we get the B Pawn
you get the C pawn and I get the C Pawn
okay everything's about equal even then
I'll still take white because you have a
weakness on C6 and a bad Bishop but
we'll see what happens
that's a very nice uh nicely pointed out
Vision that once everything gets traded
off black will be left with a bad Bishop
on B7 meanwhile white Bishop on C4 will
be more active and you couldn't feel
that extra Pawn because it's not going
to be alive for too long too long before
we'll fall C3 will fall C5 will be
picked up uh in return and that's why we
see Fabi taking a really long think I'm
getting a bit worried about his clock
he's down to about two and a half
minutes he's lost that last game you
know and that could still be something
that's playing in his mind right now but
we know Fabi I mean he's he is one of
the best players in the world so he's
experienced enough to handle these kind
of situations where you need to leave
that loss behind and he's taken his
chances he goes Rook d8 right now I
think night before would perhaps run
into grabbing the C5 pawn and Bishop C5
comes to mind after night before night
before Bishop C5 looks really nice and
then after Bishop C5 Knight C5 and then
we have Queen C3 in a little quotation
of uh really everything there and then
we just kind of have a dead position
where white is probably better due to
Bishop due to the bad Bishop on B7 that
Fabi has also as you mentioned the time
control or the time here for probably is
getting lower and Fabi is known to not
be the greatest Blitz player of course
when it comes to uh obviously playing
players of like 26 2700 2800 obviously
Carl points this out too as well you
know you just don't see Fabi all the
time playing you know in the splits
right so it's his uh time control right
now or his time is very low
some breaking news James we've got our
first result that's the only one that
matters it is indeed Alice Lee who takes
the Saint Louis archbuster to the match
Victory with her solid draw against
Sarah Pap and with that draw she wraps
up the match it doesn't matter what
happens on the other birds Alice Lee has
so many reasons to be proud of her play
today honestly is an absolute beast and
I will bring her back every week now on
my board four because this is what you
did you took out blue bomb and then you
drew and you only lost to one GM and
then you know Ricky seven here I guess I
don't know if this was by repetition
yeah so she kind of had to go for it but
I mean with that being said like Alice
Lee is the star today clinching a match
beating blue bomb in her first round
come on man honestly somebody get that
girl a medal right now and cut the check
to her cut the check to her right now I
appreciate it thank you
I love it and we see her on our screen
she knows that she's done her job let's
bring up and see how the other boards
are doing what a performance by Alice
water performance by Saint Louis
Archbishop the match is over but the
games continue and take a look at that
bottom left board it looks like
Nicholas's attack is continuing against
the black king he is the one in driving
seat meanwhile we look at top left Sabi
against Matthias blue bomb this is a
dynamic equality that we've got in front
of us the B4 C3 pawns are weak we will
see a trade-off meanwhile top right
screen is headed towards a draw that
brookpawn ending there's nothing to play
for Benjamin against Eric will end in a
draw James I think we have to go to the
Michael Nicholas game because it's the
most fun one
okay oh yeah Nicholas well what in the
world happened here this was a perk oh
yeah I have a YouTube video called Canty
works the perk I mean I've never had a
problem with the perfect event or in
fact it's called a pierce right for the
people that are like sticklers oh it's
pronounced Pierce but in fact it
definitely looks as a perk right many
Grandmaster say it too as well but you
know I never had problems with it and it
can be aggressive but I mean you can
attack it so much like you it's you just
get attacked all the time with the black
pieces and as you see there's a vicious
attack going on from Nicholas theodoro
after Rook 86 is looking it was you
couldn't even say it couldn't even
finish my sentence right Rick H oh man
oh my God oh my goodness what was that
you know five any of course doesn't
trade he gives a check and queen of
seven in this position is busted look at
Black's pieces James they are in so much
trouble effort is hanging if you move
your knight it's going to and where do
you even move your knife oh you can't
move it yeah you can't move that you
can't move at it on Knight D6 take take
take and queen f8 check and then we pick
up the roof there we also have a nice
night G5 look here in many cases Knight
G5 because if you take we have Queen G7
this is after you move the bishop
obviously maybe the D6 but even then
takes takes takes Queen f8 what do you
even do actually you don't do anything
even if you're just resign right now I'm
like there's just no way to defend that
Bishop there's Knight F6 in the air
might oh I mean we forgot about this
that's when she moves at night I mean I
might even without moving enough you
could just play Knight F6 if Rook E3
Rook H3 on top this is this is resign
time this is just over button it just
says 7.5 that's like a rook in a pawn
I'm not even up anything really that's
crazy wow maybe a pawn but that's it
yeah I don't see it Knight D6 I think
Queen E6 just giving after this ship and
then Knight G5 check winning that Queen
on E6 Knight F6 we've been pointing out
he's gonna go Queen season that's it it
is resign time it is done and that is it
Nicolas takes that win we were talking
about the Benjamin Rook Pawn ending that
has ended in a draw indeed and the only
game remaining is Fabiano caruana
there's no pressure on him the team has
done the job but there's personal
ambition here he wants to try to get the
maximum in his game here but looking at
the board I think bluebomb has got
everything under control
also see Fabi I think a quick body
language there before he looks how he
looks now he was definitely you could
just tell you like I'm not happy with
this position and we understand like
that activity that white had in the
beginning there was so much activity
activity is very important active people
you mean activity over everything
exactly oh my goodness right Tanya just
come on yeah we gotta we gotta put her
on the payroll MD night y'all y'all hear
that MD night yep MB night Tanya on
payroll we got her for sure definitely
put her on the team yep yep AOE
absolutely we got we got some new merch
coming out this week definitely great
stuff there so yeah looking good James
you called it you called that Bishop on
B7 as the sore point in Black's position
a while back and that is the biggest
problem here there's just no activity
The Rook coming on to A7 the control of
the center if there's anyone who's
trying to get anything it is white but
Fabi he's just so good in these end
games and I think with little motivation
for blue bomb in this one I think Joy is
a very likely result here yeah correct
but I mean I'm going to push for more
because fabi's time is very low and I
saw this coming just from seeing so much
fobby in Blitz Jess against the very
strongest players and this is where Fabi
actually fails a lot Believe It or Not
Fabi actually does have problems here in
the time trouble and I mean who wouldn't
right it is time trouble we got 15
seconds and like things happen in time
trouble so I definitely see this still
in Matthias blue bombs favor but I mean
it really doesn't matter it matches over
and by a unanimous I mean that's that's
five to ten double they absolutely
crushed this round and they crushed this
whole match if they keep this up you
know St Louis archbishops won't be
losing anymore
just amazing stuff
and we're just being traded the King has
come to the center but again the B7
Bishop no activity there and blue bong
bringing his own King into the game
wow this looks like everything's under
control but fabi's got 15 seconds
yeah you know 15 seconds here well okay
now blue bomb is getting closer he's
giving him you know some hope here which
is uh not what we really want here they
both made some blunder in fact blue bomb
hung his whole Queen getting low on time
right so the whole thing don't not half
the Queen the whole Queen he just
dropped it right one move it does happen
but that happens in time travel Rook A7
hitting the bishop here or at least uh a
little bit of pressure his Bishop's so
bad it went here and never moved
yeah
and you were scree about this
fat Bishop on B7 is
absolutely stuck Knight D2 trying to
trade off this bishop bitter Knight
versus Bishop end game would be great
for white wow now finally the bishop is
talking C5 but the bad point about this
is that C5 could be a huge weakness for
fabina and it's a block completely what
happened what just happened wonder how
did he blunder
how did he blunder wait what was the
move I was Bishop F3 it's a simple move
whoa he's gonna have three wow
[Music]
something like that maybe
it was just unbelievable stuff what the
players are missing but this is what
time pressure does to you and we see
here the Rooks have been traded off and
after this we're getting closer to the
draw don't take that Bishop don't allow
white skin to C4 C5 will be a weakness
both players playing on seconds right
now blue one's got six seconds Fabi down
to ten Bishop E4 you know James anything
can happen right now
age five that thing is four seconds
three seconds okay you move Bishop make
a move this is the drive it's probably
gonna be a draw apparently draw that was
a smart one if you play Bishop
ever just pick up that Bishop
oh that was great that was great that
was great oh man okay he trades off the
bishop if you pick that up the Knight
can transfer to D4 as well hitting that
B3 Pawn G3 Pawn will be hanging so he
keeps the bishop alive I think that's
the safer way to play with white knight
C4 Knight is coming to D6 watch out F7
can be weak F7 as well we also have
Bishop B4 okay I don't know who's gonna
win now but definitely is yeah I don't
think this is gonna be a winning
position wait C5 hanging hold up yeah
you just play C4 though just push right
push only move one step Queen side
and this is a job it should be four you
can trade everything and now you can
pick up the bishop move your king to F3
and they're gonna find a way to repeat
and this is all done
this is Rob playing on seconds but I
don't believe that anyone super
ambitious black skin cannot go too far
because the F7 is weak white skin can't
go too far because G3 is weak and that's
it they do repeat it ends in a draw
perhaps not super happy with his own
performance but he can be extremely
happy with the team performance
definitely beautiful play there
beautiful play from the archbishops as
they are able to close it out guys ten
and a half five and a half is a five
point lead huge absolutely huge there
now archbishops are now trying to show
the strike not only do they win but they
crush this and then they after going oh
and two this is definitely a huge relief
you know so now we want more of this and
this was a very nice lineup they might
actually see more of this lineup
this is incredible stuff this is a bit
of a low out uh by the St Louis
Archbishop that is a huge Martin going
into round four needing just half a
point but what has been very impressive
the contribution by each player to this
match everyone delivered for the Saint
Louis Archbishop team
but on the other hand the Berlin Bears
it wasn't the case with the top board
scoring just one out of four and when
your top board is not having the best
day or even a good day you know it's
going to be tough at the at the protest
league and that was the I think that was
something that really went against
Berlin bears that first round loss to
Alice Lee yeah I mean look at Alice like
with a two-piece here I mean two points
right I mean right behind Bach and
Carolina by half a point I mean as huge
as the bore four she didn't even feel
like a board four at all like what is
that she felt like one of the board twos
or threes easily right she played great
chess here in a St Louis archbishops
should be nothing but proud of this is
unanimous pretty dominating performance
that they had today against the Bears
sending the Bears home eliminated out of
the PCL gonna have to qualify again next
year in the St Louis archbishops are
here to fight and Live Another Day
one more team eliminated while St Louis
Archbishop finally starts scoring on the
scoreboard and making their way towards
those three match wins but they still
have a long way to go it is their first
match win and it's been a positive day a
very positive day exactly what Nemo's
team needed and we've got a big
interview coming up with the leader of
the team the first Board of this of the
team who has reasons to be very proud of
what they achieved today we're gonna
have off the shot break of the honor
carwana joining us to talk about all the
action that we saw chat send us the
questions that you have for Fabi with
the action that we saw today we'll be
right back with Fabiano
[Music]
he's I was here I was I was lost oh okay
well hey
let's go no 15 unreal no first try eight
in a row nine in a row baby let's go
let's go I gotta oh cool I got a little
achievement thing I honestly really
enjoyed that that was really cool become
a chess.com Community streamer at
go.chess.com start streaming
looking for a new way to learn chess
meet Dr Wolf the ideal chess coach and
companion
against Dr Wolf as he explains
everything step by step points out
strategic ideas and alerts you to your
mistakes
train with him and go over your past
mistakes until you master them
choose from over 35 lessons created for
all skill levels no matter your level
everyone could use a coach download
Learn chess with Dr Wolf for Android or
iOS devices today
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
performance there by the Saint Louis
Archbishop winning their first match and
joining us is the reigning U.S Champion
and World number eight Fabiano caruana
Bobby congratulations
thanks Tanya
I have to ask you this was such a big
match it was an elimination match
you must be relieved right now with
Saint Louis Archbishop continuing their
run
well I was pretty optimistic before the
match I thought that
we're probably uh going to do a bit
better on all boards most likely and
unless something goes really wrong then
we should be heavy favorite
and I I thought that the previous
matches we were
probably underdogs but this match I was
I was fairly confident about
but it is a great relief of course to to
avoid the elimination
right exactly avoid that elimination bro
being such a Powerhouse
um and like like of course the St Louis
Bishops are ours Bishops do you have any
plans on how to make a comeback for the
team in the PCL so you guys are you know
one way one loss away obviously you do
think about that but we have chefs to
play and there is a chance right so what
do you guys have
yeah I I still think there's a chance we
do have a very strong team
and if things go our way depending on on
who we play against next then
yeah we we should have a chance against
any team of course we are going to be
underdogs against some of them but we
have players on the team who can can
perform really well if the if the day
goes well I mean like today we saw Alice
I think she's she scored okay first GP
bluebum in the first round I was already
almost secured the mattress I think and
her performance was it was so good I
mean
so if we have performances like that
then we have a chance against any team
of course there are teams that
uh probably outrageous by by a little
bit
but yeah we'll see you know I I'm still
optimistic
it means a lot to Alice to hear these
words from you and you must be so proud
of your team Fabi it also tell us about
the day for yourself personally how did
you feel about your play today
it starts really well and at that point
I feel like we had pretty much secure
the match after the first two rounds
and then I I don't know what I was doing
in the third game I mean a draw would
have secured the match but I was only
thinking about a win I didn't I didn't
check the results with other games so I
was just thinking okay let's let's
finish this match before the fourth
round and and for that I should probably
win
and then we had an endgame which is I
think most likely a draw although I'm
probably slightly better I have to say
that I I was never like seriously better
in the game but I I felt like I had a
slight Plus at that point and then I
just started blundering everything
it thankfully it didn't hurt us too much
because uh my teammates did well in the
third round and so all we needed was a
draw on the fourth round and I I don't
think there was there's any team that's
going to wipe us out 4-0 so I I wasn't
really worried uh of course it was still
very upsetting to lose
but okay I I thought at least it's
probably not going to negatively affect
the team
very good Fabi was there any kind of
team meeting prior to today's match to
emphasize the seriousness of this
beginning of the elimination match of
being an elimination match
there there wasn't a meeting but I think
that we all understood the seriousness
of it and
you know we're one step away from
elimination every match now is is going
to be super tense and
hopefully we'll have what it takes
um I mean for myself I didn't really
have time to meet with or talk with the
other guys because I'm traveling at the
moment I'm playing from a hotel and like
right after this I'm going to run
somewhere uh for a conference so
I'm I'm a little bit you know running
from one place to the other but I was
glad that I was able even just like the
schedule allowed me to play this match
because when I heard the date that it
was gonna be on the third then I I
really wasn't sure I would even be able
to play and I checked and I was like
even if we go to uh to a playoff if it's
eight eight then I'll still probably
make my conference
well luckily for you that wasn't the
case and you guys had a crushing
performance today uh now Fabi the team
needed you today it's gonna continue
needing you as uh it's gonna continue
needing you actually because it's only
gonna get more tough and more serious
and I'm gonna bring up our week three
fundings that we've got now probably we
see these themes that are on one one and
two and St Louis Archbishop with that
win
are also on one and two now looking at
this what we have in front of us is
there any particular theme that you
would want to fight in this field
um
well it's very difficult because they
have a lot of different sort of
strategies like the blitz have like
really top heavy two boards and some of
the other teams are more balanced
between the four boards uh Blitz is like
Maxime and grishoup so that's really top
heavy which is which is one strategy for
sure and
like if I had to pick one team that I
would
think we have the best chances against
it might be like with no disrespect
meant of course it might be the the
Spanish Maniac shrimps I feel like we
might be slight favorites there
um
I think it would be interesting to play
like I was watching the the California
unicorns like right before this right
before my match started uh watching them
play so they're a very interesting team
um maybe from like the interest point of
view it would be fun to play against
them
but I don't know I mean also it would be
fun to play against Blitz because uh
then I'm I'm playing against some of the
the guys who I regularly play against
which is also an interesting challenge
I'm not all of them but yeah I think
they're all they're all quite
interesting teams
um
yeah so finally got feature chat
questions these are chest uh questions
from chess chestins wow we do too much
chess these are questions from the chat
and that we have a question from jtf
doodle he says
um do you think the PCL format
encourages exciting chess
oh yeah absolutely I mean all the
matches are fighting
like for me the most interesting sort of
match is the one that goes eight eight
and we've seen a few of those we have
seen a few blowouts as well because some
teams are really stacked
but uh overall the interest has been
very high I don't think you can complain
when you have you know two matches first
you watch one it's exciting and then you
watch another and it's also exciting so
you have like four or five hours of
Chess to watch
um right and you also have a lot of
players who aren't maybe the most
familiar to to fans like okay for
example on our team I don't think too
many players know about Alice uh know
how strong she is but I I saw her in the
American Cup last year I saw her in the
U.S championship and
and so I I knew how strong she is but uh
it's interesting and it's good for her
to get some outside exposure as well so
I like that it has a mix of like the
known guys and the Lesser known players
very nice
archbishops today were the favorites
going into this match as you yourself uh
pointed that out but I think the one
thing that very few expected was Alice's
run today and we've got a feature chat
by md90 and I'd want to get your
thoughts as well on this what do you
think about the power back performance
that Alice put out today
yeah that that like really secured the
match for us because when you have a
fourth board who's performing that well
then like it's really difficult for the
other team to recover from that and
especially like the first round for the
fourth board to beat the first board
and I think she did in like a very I
only catch the the last bit of the game
but it looked very dominant she had like
three minutes and she was up a million
pawns so so it was a very confident
performance as well I think that like if
you would point to one factor that uh
differentiated the team today would
probably be how well Alice did
that's awesome I was definitely
performed at a very high level there
actually we do have um another feature
chat question here let me actually pull
that up this one is from
amethyst613 how does Fabi keep it solid
in a cramped position like that last
game
well the last game I I was sort of
torn between two things which was I knew
that a draw secure the match but I was
also sure that like even if I lose that
we would win the match so I felt rather
free in terms of my play and I was
mostly thinking about how do I get
winning chances while also not doing
something crazy so I wasn't really
approaching it from the point of view of
like
uh am I like trying to equalize this
game because I felt
like okay of course I'm cramped but I
have the C3 Pawn so his only idea is
really to to try to win B4 which is what
he was doing with this whole night he
wants a D3 thing and after he wins that
pawn I'm going to take C5
so like the worst case I'll get the
tiniest tiniest slightly worse position
so I wasn't too concerned about
the position from an objective point of
view but I was still like trying to
search for some chances and even at the
end I was I was kind of ambitious
because I thought I was getting a
slightly better position but I I was
probably never really really better and
also had I didn't like I wasn't too
worried about a draw either because of
course it's also a good result to secure
as a match with
right three win
wow Bobby it was not just a great day
forward but you're not gonna believe
this but your prayers have been on said
we're just getting a confirmation from
the PCL League commissioner that in fact
for week four the matchups are the
Spanish shrimps playing against the
Saint Louis Archbishop after what you
just said the pressure is on
yeah no now I don't I don't want to have
to eat my words
but it's I mean it is it is a very good
team and I I haven't played some of the
players there which is interesting I I
don't think I've ever played Jaime
Santos I've played pisho iterizaga uh
Santos Ruiz in in like online Blitz
um but some of the players I'm not
familiar with so I'll have to do some
some prep for them
but yeah I think it will be it will
still be a very close match but I would
maybe slightly prefer our chances so I'm
staying optimistic
way to be well it was
at the back performance today and we
also wish you all the best
restaurant is going to be an elimination
round the St Louis Archbishop win their
first match Fabiano congratulations and
thank you for your time
thanks guys
see you Bobby
James Bobby should have asked for
something else at that point
what if you ask this time
well he did get what he wants he goes up
they go
dig shrimps that's the big reveal for
week four right now with the power
performance the St Louis Archbishop it
has been Alice Lee's day she's been the
MVP board for scoring two points a huge
upset against Blue bomb what a day of
Chess your thoughts James on what we
witnessed dominating performance this is
the St Louis archbishops that are the
defending Champions these are the ones
that you like oh yeah I would never
think that they would be O2 when you see
this result you're like yeah I expected
that because it is the St Louis
archbishops how strongly are they when
like last in 2018 1920 or something like
that or maybe one year in with a break
with the Armenian Eagles in there but it
was definitely very strong performance
from St Louis archbishops this is the
Bishops I was used to seeing um in the
in the previous PCL so if they keep this
up I mean they are gonna do some great
things and maybe make it to the playoffs
and have some other stuff for us to show
or show us as well or uh Bears they just
got there they're going home but they
did get a lot of knowledge here and
hopefully they'll be able to qualify and
get back in next year
absolutely and I love that every player
on the St Louis Archbishop we see the
score line really played a role in the
team phenomenal performance there and
they had to do it it was an elimination
match it is goodbye to the Berlin Bears
their Road in the protest League season
23 comes to win and St Louis archbishops
keep their hopes alive these are the
week three standings as we come to a
close of a very very fun week that we've
had at the protest league but of course
the action will continue this is where
we stand we've got two teams that have
already made it to the playoffs the
Indian yogis the Gotham Knights these
are the two teams six spots still remain
two wins and one loss to these other
teams that we see including Shanghai
Tigers the Wizards the Bulldogs chess
bras Norway gnomes they need one match
win to secure their spot don't forget
three match wins and you're into the
playoffs team MGD one was the other big
winner in today's matchup against the
California unicorns which leaves the
California unicorns with just one match
win and let's take a look at the
remaining standings now we've got two
teams that have made it to the playoffs
and two which have been eliminated James
Berlin bears and Charlotte cobras it is
the end of the road for them and going
into week four we're going to have more
teams come in and I want to ask you who
are you expecting out of these teams who
are fighting for life and death on the
brink of elimination to really show
their grit and determination this coming
week well first off I Gotta Go My Garden
State passes I am the captain over here
so pass us the ball and we gonna do what
we have to do so definitely Garden State
passers I definitely have to say St
Louis archbishops especially after
seeing a dominating performance like
today I mean a lot of times you see 10
points when you see double digits that's
strong when you see double digits in the
match score so double digits 10 and a
half here they was able to do that it
was pretty nice there and I would say
actually California unicorns is one more
team there California unicorns are
really strong I like to see them I
actually do laughs and fan favorites
that I like on that team American some
American talent a lot of American
talents from 2700s too as well so I
think those are some good teams that'll
make it uh make it through at least have
the some good potential to make it
through they all do but these are my
favorites
hmm very interesting the Garden State
process that is James contestina I have
to ask you we asked Bobby this question
right that who they would like to face
and while he got his prayers answer
James I have to ask you is there a
particular team that you'd like to play
against in this yeah actually I think we
want to we want to take it we want to
take a look at those Brazil Capybaras
right even uh Danny is like what is that
you know what is that even this thing I
guess what it says in the in the in the
intro video or the the promo video like
what is that thing right so of course we
do want to go fight that thing which is
the caliburras and I think we have some
nice lineups against their lineups too
we all do but uh definitely if you're
looking to face somebody yeah Brazil
it's a bit heartbreaking to see two
teams end their Journey on the protest
League now with the Berlin Bears and the
Charlotte cobras and you come in with
Hope and Dreams for the team that it's
been tough and the protest league is so
competitive and every game is so hard
that's right everything every game is
hard and then every match is hard
especially when you're down and like so
many emotions and this and that and back
and forth the surprises and upsets but
this is the protest League of course
this is the best of the best fighting
against each other getting this training
in it's all good training because when
you go play somewhere else you should be
playing good as well you get this
experience Etc you get to see these
players and teams go at each other so I
think this is very good not only for you
know the players but also for the people
watching so you can learn something and
also get the entertainment that we're
looking for so it's been awesome
too much fun and I have to ask you
before we wrap up James what's been the
highlight for you in this last match
that we saw Alice turning up like that
Alice of course is the youngsters the
youngsters I like to train with the
youngsters believe it or not it's a very
good thing for yourself especially as
any player training with up-and-coming
youngsters that are very good keep you
sharp get you tactically aware it also
like ambition and hunger that they have
is contagious so it's very nice to see
Alice Lee do what she did there today I
think that was a huge thing I think it's
inspiring across the globe for everybody
on what Alice Lee's performance today
we do know who the Garden State passes
indeed will be playing in week four and
of course again it is an elimination
match so so much at Stakes you guys are
up against the California unicorns oh
lost today to the MGD one okay what was
that oh man break it down for us okay so
the old man with the unicorns I like the
team you know they're cool and
everything but first off the unicorns
unicorns don't even exist secondly we
gotta beat them okay I love that team
and they're fine but when it's when it's
us against them it's always going to be
us so I'm sorry to say this but they
gotta go down no other choice this is
elimination so no hard feelings my guy
see you at home I won't see it at home
because you're going home California
unicorns but of course it's going to be
uh fun to see it's gonna be a great
match
oh so much excitement coming up in week
four and there we heard James Canty
about the California unicorns they are
saying they are taking them down shots
fired here we've got some very exciting
chess coming up with so much at stake
James we've got Blitz with amveol and
Grisha playing against the Brazil
Capybaras we've got the Croatia Bulldogs
up against Shanghai tigers and of course
the levitar Wizards versus the chess
bras now that's also a huge matchup
that's magnus's theme who will be
playing against the Wizards who've been
one of the strongest showings here at
the protest League wow this is amazing I
mean there's so many matches coming up
and like I actually this is one thing I
actually look forward to every day it's
like oh shoot PCL like I make my
schedule around watching the PCL so I'm
sure some of you in the chat are doing
the same thing even taking off work to
be able to watch these matches it's
absolutely entertaining great
entertainment great commentary and in
great chat too as well right so it's
amazing Tanya I'm excited to see these
next matches and at one chess
elimination matches too as well so you
know the best is yet to come
as you said The Best Is Yet To Come well
we do come to an end the week three of
protest League action so much drama and
swindles and attacks and blunders and
hits and misses we saw it all big upset
what a day of Chess we had with
dominating performance by the MGD one
and the Saint Louis Archbishop we do go
on to week four we've got so much action
coming up next week that with more
matches more at stake as teams face
elimination as they go through their way
of getting to the playoffs and I just
want to say you don't want to miss any
of that as Kanti said plan your schedule
exciting matches coming up next week
once again we start on Tuesday and we'll
be back with the protest League action
thank you so much for joining us in this
journey that we've had today candy it's
been so much fun so exciting and we'll
be back next week with the protest
League it was great Tanya and chat good
to see you and we'll see you on the next
one
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign